there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody
it's wednesday
and it's time for our big main show yep
dj maniac says uh this one is my fault
lol
because he's the one that uh
mentioned this and actually yeah i knew
that we would probably get around to
doing a show on this [ __ ] uh at some
point
but
i didn't realize when we
you know first like when i first put it
in the poll and it won i didn't realize
that netflix had just done well i don't
know if it was just but they
did um like a mini series i think it's
just two episodes and uh you know so
they had put that up i think in february
or march or whatever so i guess like
jimmy savile is kind of in the zeitgeist
at the moment yeah if you don't know who
this is this is a famous
uh british [ __ ] creeper file
and i kind of feel like everybody knows
who he is now like well until
honestly until the
scandal broke after he was dead yeah i
feel like in the united states nobody
knew who the [ __ ] he was he's very very
famous in the uk i knew who he was
because
you know during the early 80s i was real
into like post punk and stuff like that
so i was real like i was real anglophile
and i watched a lot of like british tv
like i was really into that i never saw
any of the shows that he was on because
he hosted like top of the pops but that
was like before my time that was like in
the [ __ ]
seventies tv yeah but it's like i had
heard the name you know what i mean i
didn't really see a lot of i'd heard of
jim will fix it i'd have heard of all
those shows so i kind of knew who he was
peripherally
accuse him of doing some crazy [ __ ] on
television then they'd be like don't say
anything and it just well
that's kind of like this yeah
okay i know he's up to something bad you
know i mean the thing about it that
makes me this i mean we cover a lot of
[ __ ] up people on this show serial
killers and true crime and stuff like
that they all make me angry
this made me angry in a
particular way because
he had been there had been rumors and
accusations about the [ __ ] that he was
up to going back to like 1955 yeah right
he was a [ __ ] creeper and
it seems like if like everybody kind of
knew but nobody really did much of
anything about it and he was just like
allowed to get away with it and i think
the thing that pissed me off about this
the most
was that i saw like all of these clips
of like interviews with him like over
the years
as the years went on he got more and
more brazen he would just like come out
and say [ __ ] like on tv that was kind of
like in hindsight is horrifying
but everyone just thought it was funny
at the time you know what i mean yeah it
was uh i don't remember it was creeping
on children were they boys or they girls
both mostly girls
mostly girls uh but some boys too uh
somebody i was watching to i watched
like a [ __ ] ton of documentaries about
this
and um one person said anything that
moved quote-unquote um
you know and it didn't have to be
children it usually was
but he liked real young kids young
teenagers but he would go after pretty
much like i said anything that moved
free money thank you very much aaron
erin thanks yeah some 13 o'clock in gym
time thank you have fun with it thank
you baby
the uh yeah now
seville's mentioned in the uh
on the on the [ __ ] aj [ __ ] side of
the web too
and you never really get a straight
story um
there's uh
i don't want to say conspiracy theory
because now the time for com conspiracy
theory to news is about three or four
months but
evidently he was hanging out that he was
doing some of this stuff with some
members of the british royal family and
possibly some kids were killed
we don't know
i think that's no that's a bit much okay
um he was i'm not saying that there
weren't other people involved like he
knew other pedos and [ __ ] like that he
probably did evidently he knew rich
pedos and some of them might have been
but certain families let's just say it
that way don't make it but i mean well
yeah but the thing about it was like he
knew
um you know he was very high up in the
echelons of you know he knew prince
charles and margaret thatcher and all
those kind of people and he hung out
with them i don't know
if they knew what was what they were
doing i think well i was watching this
one interview with like a guy that was
kind of around at the time and he just
thought he's like well prince charles
was kind of he called him gullible i
think he kind of wanted to say he was
kind of an idiot um and i don't think
that they necessarily knew i don't know
maybe they did i wasn't there rich
people are sheltered but yeah so it did
seem like
i don't know but i'll get into that i
think the thing that pissed me off the
most though was that he would come out
and say things in some of his interviews
and
he had a thing which he wasn't a dummy
he was in mensa so he was like he was
actually really really intelligent he
had a thing that a lot of psychopaths
have where he would deflect everything
and if you got offended by something oh
i was just kidding or blah blah blah and
he would say things to sort of shield
himself from criticism like oh things
like oh i lie when it suits me or
something like that and he would just
say stuff to be outrageous
so that he would get away with saying
some [ __ ] that in hindsight is like
openly horrifying but at the time
everyone just thought it was funny you
know what i mean because it's like oh
that's him being him he's so wacky so it
was that kind of [ __ ] and he absolutely
i think he absolutely knew
that he was doing that on purpose
because he knew that he was deflecting
because he kind of changed tactics as
the cultural zeitgeist changed because
you could get away with a lot more in
the 60s and 70s because you could like
grope
girls and like no one would really say
anything it would be like oh boys will
be boys it was that kind of [ __ ] but
when start when that started getting
less acceptable he kind of like changed
his tactics up a little bit but some of
the [ __ ] that he said on tv
now that we know what he did
was [ __ ] up and the thing that pisses
me off the most is that he would say
[ __ ] like oh well he could get away with
anything and he did
he died
he never got arrested i think he got
questioned by the cops like once or
twice but they never did anything to him
and it's just like everyone just thought
like when he died he was still seen as
his big national hero like thousands and
thousands of people turned up he had a
[ __ ]
pimpin gold coffin
he had this really ridiculously huge
tacky
gravestone with all of his
accomplishments on it and [ __ ] like that
and everyone was like all super sad and
they did all these [ __ ] tv tributes
what a wonderful man and then like a
little while later people were like oh
wait a minute he sucked yeah and then
all of the [ __ ] came out get into it all
the [ __ ] came out but it made me angry
that he was right he did get away with
it
he had like a life of luxuries so
everybody loved it well not everybody
loved him but i mean
he got away with it all of it
he never got in trouble mango said he
was kind of protected from on high
and uh
that could be we'll we'll see i don't
know much about the case i just i've
heard about it i've also heard rumors
that
it wasn't just molestation he was
possibly killing them but it
we don't know
you know no i mean other than the no
it's i don't think that i think that's
going a little bit in a satanic panic
direction i mean the [ __ ] and again this
is what kind of pisses me off about like
this conspiracy theory [ __ ] is that you
take something which is
you know
99.99 percent
yeah like we're talking hundreds of
cases 400 500
accusations okay we're talking about
that rape sexual assault molestation um
most of them children
that's bad enough um i don't think you
need to add
murder on top of it now i will say there
weren't enough missing children i guess
that's what i'm saying like that would
be noticed oh yeah like i said that's
kind of like you know i hate to you know
in case they did do some [ __ ] like that
but it's kind of i think that's a
satanic panic kind of thing where it's
like yes you know murders like that do
happen like terrible murders do happen
but
you like taking the next step i think
that's like a step too far now i did
hear about um there were some
accusations i don't know if these are
true but there were some accusations
that
he um
was a little bit into necrophilia
but
i think as far as i know that was only
like maybe one person making that
accusation so i don't know if that's
true or not but so that was i didn't i
never heard about any murder accusations
but i did hear about like one or maybe
two people saying like necrophile but
like he had access to dead bodies and
[ __ ] but
one thing that he was very big on
which we'll get into was
he was really astute if you want to use
that word um of going after people that
were really vulnerable
and once he had gotten to a point in his
career where he was like really famous
and had a lot of money and had a lot of
connections um you know a lot of people
in high places that liked him
um and he was making a lot of money for
the bbc
he kind of
felt like he could operate with impunity
well i guess he could and well yeah
that's what i mean that's that's what
pisses me off is that he was right he he
actually could um because like i said
people there were rumors about the dude
swirling since like the 50s right so
it's it wasn't like nobody knew about it
it's everybody kind of knew
but it just i don't know so it just he
he was very good at targeting
the vulnerable
and because he had so much power
one thing that he would do because he
had money and [ __ ] like that was that
you know if you threatened to like tell
anybody he would just say
i'll i'll either sue you i mean the
libel laws are a lot stricter in the uk
or he would say who the [ __ ] gonna
believe you
i'm famous and rich and you're not
you're nobody
so and he's probably right about that
and that just was right that's what i
mean so that just like really really
made me angry so honestly
yeah
there's a lot more of this [ __ ] going on
a lot more
well yeah just look look at those pitot
islands and [ __ ] that went down here
taking these uh
pretty uh
florida floridian girls out of these
trailer parks and dressing them up and
pimping them out on those islands to
[ __ ] presidents and [ __ ] dudes
from other countries and [ __ ]
what's happening here
got away with that basically
yeah i mean i guess he got killed well
supposedly he got killed in prison the
thing about it is that
if you have enough money yeah you can
pretty much get away with anything and
no conspiracy necessary do you think
that dude really died i have no idea um
i you know i don't know i wasn't there
like i said but like i said if you have
enough there's no conspiracy necessary
if you if you're wealthy yeah and by
extension yeah have a lot of wealthy
friends who are powerful you don't even
you don't even need a conspiracy you can
get away with anything yeah you got dirt
on them so you can't go down or you'll
rat them out so they'll [ __ ] do
anything especially if you target as
jimmy savile did if you target uh for
example like girls at a home for
troubled girls or people in hospitals
like children in hospitals he would
target people like that vulnerable
people children children who wouldn't be
believed if they said anything about
however the case here in the united
states i don't remember if that was ohio
or whatever it was that catholic girls
yeah yeah girls
it was like kind of like a school right
and they were yeah they were pimping
them out to the cops and the local
politicians
and that was the 70s there was a yeah i
think there was a documentary on well
actually no it might have been earlier
it might have been the 60s 50s yeah um
one of the nuns was going to go
yeah that was it and it killed her there
was a documentary about that on netflix
it might still be on there yeah matter
of fact you wouldn't think that that
could happen but hell yeah that happened
here they covered that [ __ ] well gotta
say too that in uh jimmy savile's case
uh catholic church also kind of involved
in this too because jimmy savile was a
very very devout catholic and had kind
of the uh
blessing of the pope
i mean even the pope like gave him some
[ __ ] yeah well pope's probably into some
[ __ ] too
i mean you know and this wasn't even
this was pope john ball this pope john
paul the second was in and i think he
was the one that
what happened are you trying to turn the
tom ross ventilation system on the timer
cool all this [ __ ] voluptuous meat
off
just getting hot
getting hot you're trying to cool off
your voluptuous meat that's right yeah
okay
i had to make that just sound cool
somehow
all right all right but uh yeah so
yeah this is like i said
we did like a little bit of a little
intro but like i said i feel like
probably now that netflix has done the
the mini series i feel like probably
most americans are familiar with it now
but i
i think that only happened because of
the sexual predator angle i don't think
anybody knew who he was before that so i
think it's hard for it well it's kind of
like i guess it's sort of like the
british equivalent of like the bill
cosby case was because bill cosby
was same kind of thing he was real
famous he was real rich um you know and
he had a lot of like powerful friends
and stuff and so he got away with this
[ __ ] for like a really long time
and then even when they called him out
like when people came out nobody wanted
to believe it you know what i'm saying
um i think it's like a similar kind of
situation going on although i don't
think bill cosby well bill cosby was
like pretty famous but i don't know
if he was famous to the extent
that because the thing about jimmy
savile was that he wasn't just famous
for being like a dj and a tv personality
and stuff like that but he was also
really really
uh you know famous as like a charity guy
like he gave like i mean he did give a
lot of money to charity like 40 million
pounds or something like that
um
so he was kind of known he got knighted
and everything but i'm not calling him
sir or nothing i'm just [ __ ] that
even though that's what the wikipedia
page calls him because that's he got
that but
that was margaret that was margaret
thatcher's idea she gave him that in
1990. when you think of her she
recommended it bbc
is the [ __ ] state state-owned
propaganda outlet
so
the government knew the british
government knew at least one branch of
it knew well they did an independent i
was watching some [ __ ] earlier they did
an independent uh after all this [ __ ]
came out
they did an independent investigation of
the bbc to like to figure out like who
knew who knew what like when and [ __ ]
like that they said they weren't sure if
the people at the top they didn't really
seem to know anything but the people
like maybe on the managerial level that
kind of dealt with them day-to-day
that they probably knew he was up to
some [ __ ] i don't think they knew
exactly what but they knew enough that
they should have reported it or done
something about it and they didn't right
so um
so they did like the bieb did come out
and like they apologized and they said
we changed all our [ __ ] like you know
most of the people that got they got
fired and all this other kind of [ __ ]
but they changed all their stuff to make
sure it didn't happen again because that
absolutely should have been reported
some of the [ __ ] that he did but they
weren't sure if like the super heads
like knew what was going on because they
weren't even there but they said like
the people that dealt with them all the
time actually probably did know
absolutely what was going on
but uh yeah so
it's a it's pretty [ __ ] up and like i
said
you know there were
multiple times that the cops
could have done something
and also didn't
so
there's a lot of people turning
a different you know turning away from
it turning a blind eye to it and
it's almost and i hate to say this but
it's almost like it was more
understandable when it was happening in
the 50s 60s maybe 70s because oh he's
just like grabbing girls asses or it's
oh it's cute or something like that
because it was like a lot more
acceptable back then um even though the
girls were like hey knock that [ __ ] off
and actually there's if you could look
on youtube and actually dermot sent it
to me
it was a clip i think it was from top of
the pops
and he's like standing there like doing
his spiel or whatever and there's like
all these people that were you know all
these teenagers and [ __ ] like standing
around him that were on top of the pops
and he absolutely does like just grab
this girl's ass like right next and
she's like hey what the [ __ ] you know
what i mean and it's like it was on tv
it was like totally brazen but nobody
everyone was like oh yeah nobody did
anything about it and she was on they
like they interviewed her later and she
was like i didn't know what to do she's
like what the [ __ ] it's like this dude's
like touching me and it's like i
couldn't but like i said back then it
was like seen as sort of acceptable and
you just kind of had to you couldn't
really complain about it everybody'd be
like ah you know
that's what that dudes just do that yeah
i mean back in the back in the 80s you
know growing up in brazil that's just
the way it was in latin cultures is it's
like that it's but you're not supposed
to do that to a woman you don't know
that's what i mean you do that i'm going
to punch you right in the [ __ ] teeth
and the
don't you come up and [ __ ] touch me i
don't know you you can only do that to a
girl that you're friends with
you know and it's leaving still like
even if you if you're not dating that
girl you shouldn't be going like
grabbing her [ __ ]
ass or anything like that culture though
that's like a man paying respect like oh
that put that ass and then but yeah you
know you didn't want me yeah but if you
do that here like see how well that it's
just a different culture that's what i
mean different culture
uh oracle of the monday mundane says
jenny are you familiar with the
expression the missing stare i've heard
it before but you know what i'm not
really uh
cognizant now of like what it means
so you might want to explain that to me
because like i said i have heard it but
i can't remember what it means um yeah
oracle said pity the sword hadn't
slipped a little when he was knighted
and mango also said feel free to call
him a [ __ ] oh i will absolutely
i mean and it's the creepy thing is like
just
there isn't a single photo and there's a
lot of photographs of him because he was
very famous there isn't a single
photograph of him where he doesn't look
like a perverted freak that's what he
was and yet he had a lot of money
everyone's just kind of
well like i said i think a lot of it was
like a very
calculated persona yeah
he was like
he had this kind of like malignant
narcissism type of deal it got him far
in his career because he came from
nothing like he was like really report
and then he you know clawed his way to
the upper echelons by basically being an
attention [ __ ]
um he's like i'm just gonna like dress
crazy and say crazy things and
everyone's going to pay attention to me
and you know everybody does that
nowadays but so many people are doing
that that no one cares but it's like
back then that was probably like a big
deal so he just like wears these crazy
clothes yeah well done i got famous well
yeah so it's like you know it's harder
nowadays like i said um
but you know we wouldn't stand out
that's what i mean because everybody
does that that's why it's all collapsing
yeah and to be honest i think that was
another aspect of why this case pisses
me off so much because i hate
hate attention [ __ ]
i hate people that are like that like
look at me i really really hate that
that personality and so every time like
i saw him in an interview he comes
across as this really
arrogant douche
that
absolutely knew that he could do and say
whatever and like no one was gonna do
anything and he's always kind of like
talking about like his
oh this and that was like how cool he is
and blah blah blah and it's just kind of
like oh my god shut the [ __ ] up i wonder
i wonder if dick clark was like that i
just wanted to like pull his [ __ ]
head out his head off what if dick clark
was like that
who was it dude from soul train what was
his name again oh somebody said it
earlier voice like that he had a real
cool voice
he did yeah what was it a [ __ ] man i
can't somebody said it earlier but i
can't remember what it is
but yeah it might be like up toward the
top
but
so i think that was what mate
because
but i think i've said this on a couple
of the serial killer shows before
like it's bad enough that you're a
serial killer or a pedophile or whatever
the [ __ ] you are but it's like don't be
a [ __ ] arrogant douchebag who thinks
they're better than everybody else on
top of it that's just like the cherry on
the [ __ ] sunday that's just gonna make
me hate you
that much more you know what i mean
because it's like
i don't see it i can like you know he's
like making threats about [ __ ] and like
[ __ ] i mean i got some quotes i wrote
some quotes down because
i went to because um louis theroux did a
show with him
and uh he said some crazy [ __ ] on there
i like toward the end of the show like i
did like all these quotes that he
actually said on tv
that millions of people saw and
now that everybody knows what he did i'm
like holy [ __ ] like he actually said
that on [ __ ] tv he all but like
admits it and it's almost like he's just
like oh but you're never gonna do
anything because it's just like funny
zany me ha ha and it's just and he
totally knew that he was doing that he
was a total psychopath what's the name
of the guy from soul train
yeah somebody needs to repeat it because
i'm sure somebody
said it up there because i was like oh
yeah that guy but then i just promptly
forgot it again with that dude's name
sucks getting old it's been forever
since i do my poor little brain i
remember his i remember what he looks
like he had the suit and everything he
had kind of like the very white sound
and he was just look like uh
just like a good looking black game show
host that's kind of what he looked like
yeah what was his name to be any and he
would announce it
he just would announce the next song he
he was first sounding real [ __ ]
smooth he'd be up there in the women dog
dancing around him i wonder what he was
like
come on bring it over here baby back it
up on me back it up on me see i kind of
wonder yeah yeah he probably was i kind
of wonder but he seems like he'd
probably be
cooler about it of course that's right
go ahead
put it on a [ __ ]
i mean at least like people like that
like are fine as long as you're not
doing [ __ ] without their consent like
just don't go around grabbing people who
don't even is like hey buddy what the
[ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna keep that hand if you
keep [ __ ] doing that but yeah john
cornelius that's right that's right
tammy's got oh who came up a camp guy
[ __ ] got on it first
don cornelius soul trade yeah i remember
that [ __ ]
i was a kid last time i saw him i got to
pull up some of his old material look at
him again see if i remember him as well
as i think i do i used to like soul
train don cornelius
[Laughter]
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah uh oracle's saying because i was
talking about the missing stare and she
says the missing stare means that person
who is dangerous in some way but rather
than getting rid of him will just figure
out how to deal with him yeah and that
seems like exactly what happened in this
case
and honestly um
i was looking at you know i watched a
bunch of like documentaries about it and
like people in the comments so we're
saying you know oh my mom or my grandma
or somebody like that like used to work
at a hospital that he volunteered at and
they used to say stuff like i was like
all the women
hated him they just like thought he was
the [ __ ] creepiest [ __ ] alive
but it's like they couldn't really do
anything about it because they didn't
you know they weren't high up in power
or anything like that so they would just
again like she's saying there's like a
whisper network where you're just
warning everybody stay away from that
person because it's clear that nobody in
authority is going to do anything about
it so it's just kind of like and um one
of the things that i read was that
one particular hospital like i said
we'll get into details but one
particular hospital where he volunteered
um
the nurses would tell the patients when
he's here pretend to be asleep not
really
why
because if you were awake when he came
in your room
then some bad [ __ ] was gonna happen
so she's like just pretend just pretend
he's not there pretend you're like
really deep sleep so like the nurses
would tell them that isn't that [ __ ]
up ugh this is jack's sense of mind this
made me so angry um yeah thank you zack
apropos nothing but i just discovered
the horror of what happens to oj when
the pump coagulates at the top of the
bottle
ew
[Laughter]
yeah mango said um saddle was never zany
always creepy i watched this yeah it's
like i'm watching the [ __ ]
maybe people just didn't have the
framework to
or maybe people that knew he was creepy
like you didn't really think about it
that much because every single clip i've
seen of him he looks like the creepiest
person he looks like if you told
somebody that had never seen him draw
what a sexual predator looks like that's
pretty much what he looks like
he looks like a [ __ ] freak
and it's just kind of like and i can't
believe that he got away with it for so
long i think part of the reason like i
said is because he was so brazen about
it he had dirt on somebody he well i
think that he was kind of like i said he
was playing and i saw this um one woman
she's like a psychologist or something
like that and she was saying what he was
doing was playing like a double bluff he
was coming out and saying look how wacky
and i'm saying all these outrageous
things that seem to imply
that i'm
a pedophile or that i'm a sexual
predator but it's like because i'm so
wacky and over the top no one will
possibly take me seriously because i'm
just being funny so it so he and that
was absolutely calculated i think he
absolutely knew what he was doing
but yeah it's [ __ ] hiding behind yeah
and in a way
that's kind of like that's a lot
better that's not i'm acting like an
angel then acting like yeah then like
coming out and being like i'm against
porn and then they find like a bunch of
porn on you because everybody knows that
ruse you could just say no she's just
making that up based on my
my it's on-screen persona i'm not
actually she's just no no
that what you're hearing about me i put
that out there as a joke
well that's kind of what he did
like starting in about the 90s like i
said in the 60s and 70s he could be a
lot more
kind of open about it because nobody
really you know nobody really thought
anything about like oh you grabbing
girls asses or anything like that like
ever like
like i said the girls didn't like it but
you know no one was gonna take it all
that seriously
but then you know by the time the 90s
2000s came along because he was still
doing the [ __ ]
up until i think the
um the last accusation that they have on
file was from 2009
so
and he died in 2011. and he was like in
his 80s so his old fart is like going
around doing the show because it's not
any better when he was a young fart i'm
just saying
you know he's still like [ __ ] old and
he's still going around being a [ __ ]
creeper jesus christ
what the [ __ ] is the matter with this
dude i don't know but it i don't know it
just made me really really angry this
whole thing made me so angry um yeah
yeah tyler said uh savile looks like the
kind of dude that would walk into a to
catch a predator sting yeah that's what
i mean he just looks exactly like that i
don't know why it flew under the radar
for so long like i said maybe because
nobody thought that he could actually be
that because he was so blatant about
being that you know what i mean
everyone just thought it was some kind
of like weird
role he was playing they're like nope
that's really what he was like so maybe
that's what it was i don't know
um yeah so before we get into that let
me do i don't know is is uh hernandez
here is louis here i don't know i
haven't seen him so far but i know i
said this earlier that i did this
earlier in the week but i always say
like i want to save the stuff for the
main show too so louie
sent us these two movies that are we got
them a couple days ago
he sent us
the steelbook
karate kid look at how cool that is i
love that illustration that's beautiful
but yeah steelbook
beautiful
and he also sent us this movie called
the accountant which a lot of people
have told me is really really good i
have not seen it yet so
we will be watching that at some point
in the future and possibly reviewing it
and i also want to say thank you to
dermot one of our british fans for
sending me
an amazon gift card
uh he says that we need to buy the mummy
and the mummy returns so that tom can
seen them can see them the brendan
fraser ones not the tom cruise ones um
because tom's never seen them and
everybody keeps telling him that he
would like the movies and now he's kind
of curious so thank you very much for
that dermot
uh yeah camp guy said he was in pretty
old shape in the 80s i gotta say that
from what i could like i said most of
the pictures of him were
from later onwards but i saw some
pictures of jimmy savile from the 60s
and that [ __ ] looked like an old fart
even when he was like 30. he was one of
those people that looked like an old
person
like from when they were from birth
you know what i mean
tom hasn't seen the mama yet see that's
what everybody says
it seems like exactly in his wheelhouse
so i'm like really surprised that he
hasn't seen it but uh but yeah so we
need to like rectify that situation
uh
zach says wasn't there an australian
kids show host who did a similar [ __ ] in
the uk around the same time maybe i'm
not really sure
i do kind of feel like and i'm not
saying that all hosts of kid shows are
pedophiles that would be silly but um
you know it's just like saying you know
obviously not all priests are pedophiles
and blah blah but
there is a certain percentage of people
that have that proclivity let's call it
that and um you know to have access to
victims then they're like hey i know
what i'll do i'll become a priest and
like at a boys school or i'll dress up
like a clown and go to little boys
birthday parties and [ __ ] like that so
they're gonna
they're gonna position themselves in
places where they can have access to
victims and that's exactly what jimmy
savile did like he
you know i don't know if he started out
doing that specifically at the beginning
of his career but he for sure like
parlayed it into that where he's like oh
i'm gonna go on like i'm gonna run a
dance hall and then we'll be on top of
the pops and you know and i'm gonna
volunteer at all these hospitals where
all these vulnerable children are uh you
know what i mean so he could have access
to all the victims that he wanted and
you know and that no one could really do
anything about it so there's that
so we've done the thank yous everything
like that everyone's saying i haven't
seen a mummy yeah everyone is like
flabbergasted i haven't seen the
original mummy i haven't seen any of the
mommies
i saw the moment with tom cruise isn't
it that's a sad life when that's the
only mummy that you've seen
i liked it honestly honestly i like the
board i like the boris karloff mommy i
almost like
the mummy makeup
more than the frankenstein's monster
makeup that board that they did on boris
karloff
um
i know that's maybe a controversial
statement
as far as like universal monster people
go but
man
he looks so good as the [ __ ] mommy i
just i don't know i just really like the
look of that film but um even though he
doesn't play the mummy he's plays like
the other
you know the the human
character for a while too
uh yeah the brendan fraser and that guy
yeah savile was always in character at
all times he was in public kind of like
a creepy pee-wee herman yeah and the
thing about pee-wee is that i kind of
feel like peewee gets a little bit of a
raw deal because peewee herman as far as
i'm aware
and maybe you guys can correct me if you
know something i don't know he wasn't a
pedophile though no all they did was
catch him jerking it in a theater in a
porn theater which i'm kind of like well
that's kind of what a porn theater is
for yeah probably what you're doing
there jericho so you didn't go into the
[ __ ] places yeah because it's gross
so i'm just kind of like so he got
arrested
doing something that ever that's kind of
what that's for even though technically
it's not legal but everybody goes in
there to do that so it's like just
because he's famous he got arrested and
now like everybody just knows him for
that and i'm just like man leave the
dude alone he was he was just in there
jerking it to a porn movie that's what
you're supposed to do to porn movies he
wasn't like you know he wasn't after any
children or anything like that
i don't know i don't get it like i said
no there was no non-consensual [ __ ]
going on
it's you know it's like in light of [ __ ]
that other people were doing it seems
like uh you know pretty
harmless it's like it's very harmless he
wasn't hurting anybody but yeah
uh
yeah dj maniac said peewee was a high
profile victim and they dragged him
through the mud for it yeah that was a
total like [ __ ] moral panic hit job
right there like i said he wasn't
hurting anybody
you know
it's like you know it's not like they're
letting little children into porn
theaters or nothing like that corner
hornets sent me a picture today of this
female mexican female federali and he's
he's crossing the border and she's got
her sub machine gun there and she's in
her uniform he's he's trying to put a
move he's trying to put the moves on her
he said he almost got her number he was
trying to get her number but she was she
would give them
there's something trying to pick up the
federal agents when he's [ __ ] coming
in through the board well you know yeah
man's gonna be a man
he's in a picture unfortunately
he sent me a picture
unfortunately in the light of what we're
seeing
[Laughter]
yeah uh somebody says uh he did bad
things with the dead did you hear about
that yeah i mentioned i mentioned that
earlier like i said i don't know if it's
true or not but um
at least one person has made that
accusation that um that he had a little
bit of a neck all right before we get
off too deep in this i just got to tell
the audience about an hour ago i started
cooking carnitas all right in the
instant pot
that pressure cooked at 45 minutes it's
been out of the pressure cooker cooling
but in a bit i'm going to go down there
and plate up some of that meat and let
it cool off a little bit more he's going
to plate up that meat yeah i'll plate up
that meat then i'm gonna i'm gonna brown
it later in the broiler
that's gonna be the taco meat
you gotta make time
yeah yeah i have to show i'd make tacos
it'll be ready so just so just like
looking at the camera and saying meat
break yeah so if you see me get up and
walk out i'm either going to the
restroom or i'm working on working on uh
he's not just being rude yeah
checking on carnitas i'm letting him sit
in that hot gravy for a while you know
it kind of did that hot did you smell it
yeah i did kind of yeah
i used
the instapot recipe from a youtube
channel little girl in mexico the name
of the channel is
cooking con claudia and it's a real good
um
i'm gonna have to subscribe to that yeah
kanavatsalan recommended her so i
subscribed to her shoot tell you i like
watching cook i like watching cookies
yeah tell you how to make everything you
know and she's got all the damn mexican
stuff this big [ __ ]
mortar and pestle that you got from
mexico and she's
cooking up all the chilies in the
tomatillos and browning them over the
oven i need to get this rack she's
putting over the over the uh electric
oven element it's a rack that it's just
a wire rack it's got little eggs on it
and you can roast your
peppers and your tomatoes over the the
oven before you throw them in that it's
i forgot the word she uses she uses the
mexican word for it's not in spanish
it's like an ex-mexican indian word
for a mortar and pestle
she mashed it up there and made salsa at
it that was good but i'm using her
uh recipe the only thing i messed up is
i forgot to put the garlic in it
oh [ __ ] i can add garlic
but um jason says will you guys post
food pics on instagram
we should you should like take pictures
of some of the [ __ ] you cook and then
send it to me and i'll post it on the
13th photograph well unless you have the
lighting perfectly right it always looks
a little [ __ ] funny
yeah so
um yeah yeah instant pots are killer
nice to have great for veggie soups as
well yeah they're i mean yeah we've used
ours a lot that that in the air fryer
that's that [ __ ] is like uh we've made
all kind of [ __ ] yeah i got i got uh
what's a power xl air fryer it's big you
can do a whole it's got baskets and
broilers you can
do pizza in it you can air fry you can
broil
you can bake in it it's like an electric
oven it does everything it's called a
power xl i got it for like a hundred
bucks at sam's that's a great man's air
france that's a massive airfryer
and
the wire racks it's like a wire fry
basket i put pizza dough in it make a
pizza and [ __ ] put it on the pizza
settings
man it comes out good and i cook really
good pizza makes good pizza real good
and it's nice because you don't have to
like because before like i said you were
heating up the oven at 500 or 525 for
like out of like an hour or two before
you put the
you know it's gonna be stone baked pizza
the stone has to be preheated about an
hour yeah uh this one no it's instant so
it it's not quite the same but it's as
good as yeah it comes out it's just a
good idea i think like just wearing a
street pizza from a pizzeria it's like
that
and if you look at the bottom of a
pizzeria
the crust you'll see like a mesh pattern
in there it's because they're cooking it
on a wire on a wire uh pad
which is and that's how they're doing it
it's like very hot air induction
it's just another way of doing it mango
says meat break sounds like a movie for
men yeah damn it it does movie for me
i probably watch that it sounds like a
gay porn which i'm not saying which i'm
all about yeah so she's talking girls
watch gay porn yeah all these men on
each other
what it's fun
i also watch lesbos
[Laughter]
you know what i'm just saying same thing
all kind of fun stuff okay meat break
uh
that's just now i kind of want to now i
kind of want to like write a novel
called meat break
not necessarily like a porn novel i just
think that's a funny name how does tom
not know about the mummy trilogy from
the 90s his boyfriend the rock is in the
second one that's what [ __ ] don't
didn't send it to me i asked twice i
said send me dermot send sent me money
to buy it for you okay
i didn't i didn't get i didn't know
that's what i'm saying i didn't know i
told you that the other day all right he
sent me money to buy it for you buy it
for me because he said why is he not
seeing the mummy i'm sending you money
right now see you can buy it so i'm
gonna buy it i get it on blu-ray or dvd
you probably you could probably get it
as a set huh uh i'd imagine you can yeah
i thought there were only two but i
guess there are three of them
chang says uh jimmy savile had a ring
with a glass eye set in it allegedly he
stole it from a corpse in the morgue
yeah i heard that story
um let me go check it out so
yeah
apparently he did have
allegedly like i said the [ __ ] that he
did is bad enough i don't know if he did
the dead people [ __ ]
i wouldn't put it past him though i'm
gonna say because the [ __ ] that he did
was like [ __ ] up enough but yeah i
heard that story that
he apparently knew somebody
that worked at a morgue or ran a morgue
or something like that and gave him like
carte blanc i can't imagine i can't
imagine working at a morgue
and having a friend
and being like hey go to town and like
giving them i can't imagine
a situation where that would be okay
where i would do that you know what i
mean like what kind of person would i be
if i had a friend like that that came to
me and said hey um
can i have the keys to the mortgage like
i want to go in like and you know
commune with the dead bodies for a
little bit i'd be like get the [ __ ] out
of my face with that
i'm not like oh here you go have a good
time jesus christ what the hell's
the people i don't know but yeah so
apparently the story was that
he um
got a glass eye from one of the corpses
and uh made a ring out of it so
like i said i don't know if that's true
but
from what i learned about him that
sounds like some [ __ ] that he would do i
don't know if he did it but it sounds
like some [ __ ] that he would do because
he was really
like i said not only we see like a
pedophile a sexual predator everything
like that but he was also like really a
dick he was like just an [ __ ]
like he was just really arrogant and he
just you know he knew absolutely that he
would just get away with everything and
he was just like so [ __ ] smug about
it and i hate [ __ ] smug i think i
hate smug more than anything so it's
like if you do all this bad [ __ ] that's
bad enough but then if you're smug on
top of it and it's like yeah you'll
never catch me
then i oh man then i'm really gonna want
to [ __ ]
punch your face off because [ __ ] i hate
that so and that's so every time i
watched him talk i was just like yeah i
just wanted to like bust him right in
the [ __ ] face but yeah
uh let's see
cheese on toast is like having pizza you
know what i mean
it's just kind of like cheese on toast
is one of those simple pleasures of life
like i said it's just two things just
bread and cheese and kind of toasty but
it's so so good so good
yeah sabrina says if we get the mommy
movies you should also get the scorpion
king that the rock is also in i re i
think i saw that a long time ago but i
don't remember that much about it so
yeah he probably liked that as well
um yeah jason said he used charity to
cover up his crimes and yeah that's
another thing i think that
and like i said it's kind of like
the way that his personality was like i
said he wasn't dumb he was actually
really really intelligent and really
manipulative
and i think that he absolutely on
purpose
cultivated
um friendships with
famous people like rich people like
other people like way up in society like
the royalty and [ __ ] margaret
thatcher and the pope and [ __ ] like that
as cover and he also did charity work
too
and pretty much like even people at the
time
said that he would always choose
charities and like i said it's you know
i'm sure the charities were glad to get
the money because he did actually give
them the money
but
he seemed to choose charities that were
more high profile or the events were
high profile so i think that he did it
more for him
um
and the weird thing about it is that
it could be
that he was doing it
and he said this
like this is what i mean about him kind
of like saying [ __ ] out loud like
sometimes and people are like
you know at the time maybe people just
thought he was being funny or glib or
whatever but it's like now that we know
all the [ __ ] that he did it seems like
maybe he was
trying to tell everybody like what he
was actually doing because some of the
[ __ ] that he says is like pretty blatant
but i think that
he was kind of the thing where
he gives money to
charities that are very high profile and
i think that was part of his cover
but
i also think he was a lifelong catholic
and he was apparently like pretty um you
know he was raised like that and he was
apparently like really uh you know uh
devout
and
i think
and he did say this one time
that he thought well if i give all this
money to charity then god will like look
the other way at like the bad [ __ ] that
i do and he even said something like
almost exactly like that like out loud
like on tv one time so i think that
even though i do think that he was
manipulative enough and intelligent
enough to like do that [ __ ] on purpose
like oh nobody will suspect me because i
give all this money to charity and i'm a
wonderful person it's like he was
absolutely doing it for that but i think
maybe subconsciously he was also doing
it as kind of like a
balancing of the scales like i'm like
well i'm doing all this horrible [ __ ]
over here but i'm also doing all this
good [ __ ] over here so it'll kind of
like even out i do kind of feel like he
maybe felt like that so
i don't know it's like really
complicated i did see like um a couple
different psychologists and
psychiatrists and stuff like that that
gave
kind of uh breakdowns of him most of
them say that he had like he was totally
a psychopath
and honestly like a couple people uh on
some of the documentaries
don't well don't yell at her because
that's more distracting
than the noise like i said she turned in
front i'm used to her tearing up the
furniture it's too late now yeah so
and if you yell at her she just stops
for a second and then
yeah
but um
yeah one thing that people noted
was that
he was one of those people that was
completely
emotionless like i that was one word
that people used um a couple people used
the word soulless
um that they looked in his eyes and they
disabled like everything was a facade
almost like nothing was behind it um a
couple people did say that about him as
well so i kind of feel like he was all
show like he was all facade
he knew very well like how to manipulate
people but he didn't really seem to feel
anything to any degree and he actually
again he even like said that outright
like i don't have emotions i don't or he
said something and i think i wrote the
quote down i have it on in my note
somewhere
he even said to um louis theroux on that
show
he said um because louie said oh you
said one time that you didn't have any
emotions and he said well you know i
don't do emotions it's like if you tell
people you have emotions then you have
to like talk about it for two hours and
blah blah he's like and then he said i'm
just very good at masking them he said
that
and just like the way he said it was
like super super creepy
so
absolute psychopath i mean and i really
don't know why like nobody called him
out on that because a lot of people even
up going back decades like said that he
seemed like a [ __ ] psycho but you
know that's kind of what happens in
hindsight hindsight's 20 20. you know
what i'm saying
so
yeah
uh let's see scotland yard let's kind of
give a little bit of a thing
um
here what
i can't he's showing me that
he's showing me his little uh
that's that's a murder harness
federally girl there that he's talking
about
okay man i i i looked he's gonna check
your messages check your messages dude
i'm in the show yeah we're in the middle
of the show in the show dude
yeah camp guy said he didn't cry when he
was on this is your life yeah and like i
said people that knew him
said that even though he was very good
at
at like playing at emotions like he
would do like the kind of a theatrical
blah blah they never got the sense that
he actually felt it i think that's why a
couple people um on some documentaries i
saw they said that he seemed like
soulless like you looked in his eyes and
you didn't really see anything oh
[ __ ] psycho
yeah one guy even called him quote
unquote robotic
yeah he said he was like a robot like he
didn't feel anything he didn't and like
i said he seemed aware of that
which
you know
yeah
and you know pretty much everybody that
looked into it like that are experts in
that field uh said yeah he absolutely
seemed to have all the uh
earmarks of psychopathy big time
and he seemed well he seemed like one of
those people that and he even said this
a couple times too was that well all
that matters is just like having fun
um you know obviously fun for him not
fun for other people
um you know what i mean uh so he didn't
really care i kind of feel like he saw
other people as just like means to an
end you know i mean which like i said is
one of the very definitions of
psychopathy you don't see other people
as people you just see other people as
like npcs who you can just like
use as you wish like for your own
entertainment and i kind of feel like
and i kind of feel like he was
absolutely that type of dude
so uh all right so let's kind of go into
this motherfucker's uh background a
little bit
and broil in that meat so i'm just
watching the timer you're just watching
the timer okay
so what might be going down here
she's like rolling around yeah she's
fighting your hair um rubber your hair
bad she i went into my i have a little
drawer over there that has like a bunch
of like little rubber bands and
jewelry and stuff and i opened that
drawer like to get a necklace out
and she looked in and she was like ooh
rubber band thank you and she plucked it
out stuck it in her mouth and jumped off
the sink and then ran over here and
started like flinging it around
she for some reason she's
she likes her regular like you know toys
people buy for her and that we bought
for her but for whatever reason she
[ __ ] loves this just little black
like little ponytail bands because she
can pick them up in one little claw and
she can throw them and she chases him
and she carries him around her mouth and
it's like it's really really funny
um
yeah didn't he host a musical game show
and it was not so much
he was on top of the pops
and he had his own show we'll get into
that but yeah he started out in radio
but then like he went on to tv
all right so uh so he's born in leeds
um kind of
during the great depressiony kind of era
he was the youngest of seven children a
very devout roman catholic family
uh his family were actually quite poor
uh he was quoted as saying later that
his dad was quote unquote scrupulously
honest and also scrupulously broke
so
there was that so he apparently grew up
uh you know
really really uh destitute so you know
not destitute but poor
holy crap
she's having a good time back there if
you can see her like every day i'm like
running around back there
so he went to school until he was 14 and
then uh started working in an office and
then when world war ii came along he was
actually conscripted as what they called
a bevin boy and that was like if you
weren't old enough to go into the armed
services
um but you were still like a teenager
they'd be like well we need coal for the
war effort so they'd send you down to
work in the coal mines and that's what
he did so he went down to work in the
coal mines now apparently while he was
working down there he got like a lot of
uh injuries like i think there was one
kind of like explosion or something like
that he got like some spinal injuries
which is why later on like he gave to
you know spinal injury charities and
things like that wasn't the only reason
but you know what i mean that's what i'm
saying where he got the the idea
um after that uh when he was maybe like
in his late teens early 20s he went and
became a scrap metal dealer
now in the early 1940s he starts out
just going around to like dance halls um
and playing records
now this wasn't really
he kind of claims that he was the first
dj
this is a disputed claim but
it's kind of possible because nowadays
it was like djs are like ubiquitous but
back in the early 1940s that wasn't
really much of a thing you know what i
mean where somebody would just go and
like
play records and people would dance to
them you know what i mean it wasn't
really a thing
so he started doing that
claimed he was the first dj uh in his
autobiography because of course he
[ __ ] wrote one
uh he was the first he says he was the
first to use
two turntables in a microphone and a
microphone like at the same time and he
says that he did this in 1947. however
uh this is
not true
because
uh twin turntables
were actually there was a
illustration of them in a bbc handbook
from 1929 many years before he said that
he was the first person to do it but
like i said he was very
self-aggrandizing
so there's that that's not really that
uh much of a stretch say he was a big
[ __ ] liar about that
uh then he went on to do a bunch of like
uh professional sports [ __ ] like that um
he was a race bicycles
and he was also a wrestler for a time
um you know so there was that
professional wrestler he was kind of uh
he was a fairly big dude and he was kind
of like a scrap like he would get in
fights he was you know he had kind of
like a violent uh temper i guess sounds
like yes sounds like tbi
which is brandon
maybe brain injury or maybe he was just
the [ __ ]
maybe i mean it's possible that he could
have got like some head injuries and it
said because
that's something that we've talked about
a lot of times like on some of the
serial killer shows it's not
a hundred percent because some of them
don't have that but
a surprising amount of serial killers
did have head injuries in their youth
so there is i mean they know that
there's probably something to that
because if certain parts of your brain
are damaged particularly the part that
uh inhibits
bad behavior yeah then obviously if that
part is damaged then uh yeah that's
gonna cause you some problems later on
uh so yeah so he lived in salford in uh
outside of manchester just you know
salford lads club i always remember that
from the
all the uh the smith's photo shoots in
the 1980s
but so he lived there from the mid-1950s
to the mid-1960s
managing a the plaza ballroom in
manchester city center
uh he also managed another kind of dance
hall in leeds in late 1950s and early
1960s and a couple of other ones around
this time he had a really really popular
monday night uh dance night you know
what i mean so just like nowadays he had
like a club night and all the teenagers
would come and dance there
now we'll say in 1955
is the first
incident of abuse that was reported to
the police 1955 is the first one they
have on record
uh don't have a lot of details about it
but they know that it took place
somewhere in manchester that's all i
know like during the time that he was
managing one of the dance halls but
there is actually a record of some abuse
of some type happening in 1955 and
that's the first
uh time that they had heard about
anything like this
now while uh jimmy savile was doing his
dj thing like at all these dance halls
there's this music executive from deca
records and he hears about like oh
there's this popular dj guy and blah
blah blah so he goes there and checks
him out so he gets like discovered
and so they let him be a dj at radio
luxembourg and he was there for like 10
years
so by that he was doing like um a show
pretty much every day like you would do
a program every day and he would do a
show on saturday
that like six million people listened to
so it was like a big deal
so by the time the 60s had rolled around
he was actually
one of the most recognized if not the
most recognized radio dj in the uk
because like i said in america it's kind
of hard you know for people to imagine
but in the uk all their radio stations
are national because it's not a big
country
so you know when you hear stuff on the
radio like everybody in the country if
you're listening you hear it whereas in
the united states
we don't really have any that's you know
there's there's [ __ ] that's like
uh kind of
you know broadcast to different radio
stations you know sent out to other
radio stations but radio stations tend
to be very local like usually just like
within a city or a county so
it's i always just thought that was
really weird when i read about
because that like i said i was really
into like new wave and stuff like that
in the early 1980s so i read a lot of
stuff about the uk because that's where
a lot of the bands were coming from and
that always kind of like blew my mind
that
if you got on the radio in the uk
like you you were like a countrywide
sensation because everybody on the radio
heard you where it's like if you got
played on a radio station in the united
states it's like
you know if you got played on a race
station like new york people in new york
would be like yeah cool but everybody in
the rest of the country be like who the
[ __ ] that you know what i mean because
it's everything's just so far apart but
it's like yeah i thought that was really
funny but yeah so
so yeah so he's like pretty much the
most famous uh dj but by the time the
1960s roll around
now uh at this point like tv comes
calling so his first thing that he did
on tv
he was on this kind of music show called
young at heart like back in
1960
this show was black and white
but this was kind of where and like i
said i think this is maybe
he knew pretty early on um i will give
him that he was very savvy that he's
like well i need to stand out i need
people to like remember me
so he would do like outrageous [ __ ] and
you know to be fair it was like a lot
easier to be outrageous back then
so all he had to do
all he had to do like in 1960
was even though the show was black and
white i'm gonna dye my hair a different
color every week which like i said
nowadays big deal as i put a different
color wig on every time we do the show
but well not always but you know so he
did that and like it was kind of like oh
look at this crazy person and like he
would wear kind of like weird clothes
and stuff like that but
it worked i mean it ensured that people
remembered him hey it's the weird guy
with the different colored hairs the
weird guy with the gold chains or
whatever um because like i said it was a
lot easier to stand out back then
so uh
1964 so he did that for a while and then
in 1964
he actually was on the first edition of
top of the pops the iconic uh british tv
show
now
1960 though when he was still doing
young at heart
this was another year that there were
several reports
of him doing some sketchy [ __ ] [ __ ]
one of these
uh was a 10 year old boy
who told the police
that
he had asked jimmy savile for his
autograph outside a hotel because like i
said jimmy savile was on tv by this
point
so this kid allegedly asked him for an
autograph outside a hotel and then
savile said yeah come in here and i'll
give you an autograph and uh yeah and
then sexually assaulted him so there's
that
uh so yeah that happened in 1960
1965 um
he had started doing top of the pops in
1964 which was a bbc show
so he's working for the bbc at this
point
um
now so he starts doing some [ __ ] there
and also right around 1964 1965
he also starts to
volunteer
at leeds general infirmary the hospital
he starts volunteering there as a porter
and he also volunteered at another
hospital called stoke mandeville
and
from about this time it seems
that he started molesting
patients at the hospital
so there was that that was
mid-1960s
1966 is what
in hindsight
police have started to call his peak
period of abuse this is when most of the
abuse cases although like i said they go
all the way back 1950 1955 to like 2009
so that's how long this [ __ ] dude is
doing [ __ ] what's that
try it on the show that's claudius
carnitas
okay
tell them what you guys talk about
something
i don't like dead air
it's not radio i know but i'm just
saying i still don't like it what do you
think of that
it's delicious yeah
those are better than mine
very lit very subtle spices
and just done done well i'm gonna do
them like that
yeah that's really good yeah because
then from that you can change it to
anything you want
you can add any kind of sauces it'll mix
you know yeah like i said i kind of like
the uh
the milder
spice yeah
plus less likely that i'll get heartburn
later
okay where was i
sorry about that
all right so 1966
starts
his decade-long
quote-unquote peak period
like i said that's what he was still
doing top of the pops
1968
he started at radio one
now at this point he starts doing a show
which he called saviles travels this was
a weekly show
uh which came on sundays he would just
go around britain and he would like talk
to people and then he would do a show
about it he also
um
kind of scammed the bbc into paying for
like a
camper like an rv type situation uh
because he said yeah i need it for my
travel show
um
and he would later use that trailer
camper van whatever thing uh for a lot
of his exploits because he could like
kind of take it anywhere he was always
kind of like
he said a lot of stuff about oh i travel
around everywhere he almost kind of had
like a gypsy type of lifestyle so he
would go around in this [ __ ] camper
and stay in different towns and
presumably like get
i saw this one documentary and they said
yeah his little van or whatever was out
in the parking lot
one morning and then like these two or
three like 14 year old girls like come
out of it one morning yeah you know what
i mean so it's that kind of situation
she had like a mobile
molestation vehicle yeah let's call it
that they're they're fighting and
they're saying tbi other people say no
he's just a piece of [ __ ] i've had tbi i
mean it could be it could be both things
it could be both things i've had tbi
went to walter reed army hospital went
through the whole [ __ ] trading
program how to live with tbi and what
could have
what tbi does is it can magnify the most
[ __ ] negative aspects of your
personality
so he might have been kind of like this
and then tbi that made it worse all
right
the thing is though is i'm gonna [ __ ]
back off on that slightly
they used to think that tbi lasted
forever for your life
nah not really depends on how severe the
damage is
most people over a period of years can
heal back up from it well brains are
incredibly plastic
meaning that you know it provided that
the damage is not too severe
and where it happened your brain can
kind of like rewire itself and kind of
fix itself to an extent like over like i
said depending on what the damage is
mine was frontal left hemisphere
which uh has a lot to do with
inhibitions and [ __ ] and that was when i
started seeing the damn monkeys and the
[ __ ] monkeys that raged and wanted to
kill me all the time
she knows exactly what i'm talking about
you're kind of uh in a in a bad place
when i met you yeah not you were getting
better but yeah it was still pretty bad
for a lot it was off and on too
uh under stress
that was that cost my military career
uh for 10 years after after my head
injury
you couldn't put me in the front lines i
would have had to have been in a
training and support role only and i did
time the corporate world and then did
some step timing
basically in the training world training
military and
and military guys from across the world
on how to do certain things with a post
blast investigation running ranges
running ranges
um
compared to what i was in
94 or 95
oh [ __ ] man i'm a lot better than that
you know what i mean
hair
just a hair trigger [ __ ] yeah you've
settled down a lot yeah hair trigger
[ __ ] temper you still got you still
got that but oh it's nowhere near as bad
as but not like it was yeah well not
even as bad as it was when i first met
you yeah and i'm sure it had mellowed
out it hadn't been said
right you know because i you know i
think a lot of that happened before i
even yeah
and um the more stress i was under the
more
of a hair trigger i would have
um
bad dreams and
i and i also have uh ptsd
so the head injury and the ptsd kind of
had like a [ __ ] could play off of one
another
and part of my ptsd was [ __ ] hyper
vigilance where i couldn't sleep
constantly hyper yeah
i was constantly on security constantly
you know looking over my shoulder uh
couldn't sleep
and to this day i have to have
headphones on i have to have noise i
mean like i said it's better than it
used to be because back in the old days
[ __ ] i was just kind of like
you know touch you or something like
that you'd be like
you would like flip the [ __ ] out yeah
you know what i mean yeah
and you'd be like you'd be having
nightmares all the time and
noise for me always meant that it was
safe
if it was quiet it was dangerous
because you know being infantry see i
like you you work in a very quiet dark
environment striking from the shadows
from ambush you know what i mean ambush
counter ambush this is the old warfare
not what they do now you know world war
three [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's going on right now actually
over what you call it but
floor
forest and jungle tight warfare vietnam
style stuff is what we were trained for
in 101st but that in that era
and what i what we did is now lost art
which they're gonna have to retrain for
it because that's what's coming again
if it ever does if there is in america
we'll see
what's up look at she's fighting well
yeah it's like it's funny because you
always kind of had to have like noise
when you were sleeping and i'm like the
opposite i'm very very sensitive to
noise i don't like
i like quiet you know what i mean you're
right so anytime there's like any kind
of noise if there's noise i can't sleep
noise means it's safe and [ __ ] the
safest is like wines jet turbines
or
engines generator motors
i mean [ __ ] like that doesn't bother me
like the sound of like a ceiling fan or
so that doesn't bother me yeah but
anything that's because what you used to
do was you used to always want to like
listen to a podcast while we were
sleeping and that just kept me awake
half the night yeah or it kept waking me
up right like sometimes i'd fall asleep
but then i kept waking up like when the
tone chill like when the voices changed
or something going all the way back to
military because i i was also grew up
partially at a military academy
constantly in a crowd of people that are
talking and
talking talking all the time so there's
just this
constant 24 7 because even in the
military not unless you're way in the
rear the fort or something
in a fort
everybody sleeps at night but you know
on missions only half of the people are
sleeping at night you're sleeping in
shifts
so there's no such thing as quiet
you know what i mean not when you're in
it well you know why the unit can't
sleep it has to have at least 50 right i
get that but you know why i think that
i'm kind of more like a quiet person is
because
i grew up in a family with a lot of
siblings yeah and you know i was around
little kids all the time i was so my
whole and i always like lived with other
people yeah so i got
so it's it's always kind of like there
was always noise going on it always like
annoyed me yeah and like the older i got
like the more and more annoying it got
and i was like why can't i just have
some [ __ ] quiet like for one time in
my [ __ ] life you know what i mean
because it was just like so much noise
like all the time i never got any quiet
yeah
my just upbringing and my life is just
was very inverted from what a civilian
is what comforts a civilian is dangerous
to me what what feels dangerous to a
civilian is comforting to me it's very
it's very opposite you know
and you look at ptsd and you say yeah
that's it
a high energy
danger risk taking motorcycles almost
getting killed oh that's great
being still quiet oh no this isn't right
well no see i want and another thing too
i want it especially nowadays i want it
to be quiet yeah because i want like if
for example like if pookie got hurt like
in the middle of the night like if she
got into something she couldn't i wanted
to be able to hear her cry so i can get
up um i couldn't totally understand you
know what i mean so it's like i don't
want to have headphones on i don't want
to like not look if somebody like breaks
a window i want to [ __ ] hear that
[ __ ] i don't want to have headphones on
i wanted to be quiet
y'all [ __ ] who've been with the show
for years and years you know jenny's
like a saint okay she can put up with
quite a bit
i'm not i'm not a normal human being
chances are ain't that the truth
i love you the average woman wouldn't
have put up with it
but i i was never really relationship
based you know what i mean so
had it been anybody else they just would
have left and i've been like okay and i
just would have gone on to something
else you know what i mean
but well that happened yeah that
happened
okay
i know it's your life yeah i'm like that
you know here's another one okay
two or three months okay she's gone okay
where's another one
because it was just the high attrition
the high attrition relationship ratio
because when she met me
i actually
was dating other people but she saw well
i was too i was this yeah i was a serial
monogamist
but i really didn't care if i was single
or not
um
yeah he didn't really give a crappy no
no i mostly cared about how much money i
had or what my clothes looked like or
what the motorcycle was men have
relationships with machines and things
yeah not so much people
not just you like my ex
kind of like that yeah yeah like that's
what most men i've known have been yeah
they're not all like that maybe but most
of the ones i've known it's hormones i
think less than what's happening yeah i
think they find it easier to relate to
inanimate objects yeah
well inanimate objects are systems
and they don't talk back well they're
predictable yeah they don't do yeah they
don't do anything
right yeah you can expect everything and
you can control that i get it and you
can do this and that and this and then
oh and that awesome that's so fun well
that's our version
that's our version of creating a child
that's no fun i'm gonna make this and
now make this motorcycle make that gun i
like this excitement i'll make this and
it's you know that's our version of like
bearing children
they're not people though they're
machines and creations but see i get
that a little bit because you know i as
someone that writes books and stuff like
that i don't i'm not one of those people
like stephen king has said like he
thinks of uh books like his children
even though he has actual children i
don't think of my books like that but
you do kind of like have a relationship
with things that you create yeah you
know what i mean so i think it's the
same thing as like a dude that builds a
machine or like a person that writes a
book
um it's kind of the same thing it's
still like a creative process and i have
like these ultimate broham [ __ ]
discussions with some dude at the bar
which is between bros you're just
trading information you're talking about
world war ii engine compressions on
[ __ ] fighter planes and what the
stall speeds were and [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
like that women are like oh we're in the
club stop talking about it
i mean your real [ __ ] fabio me and me
talking to talking to fabio we can sit
there and talk about man mars he knew
that
his name's not fabian but he looks kind
of like bobby they call it that's right
he looks like five big ol long he did
actually look a lot like bobby yeah so
that's why we called him did he know
that we called him that do we ever call
him that to his face oh [ __ ] sorry no
sorry but um yeah i don't know if he
watches the show or not we haven't seen
a long time yeah but um he's not around
anymore but yeah they were uh you know
they're both into
machines machines and well i mean i get
it like look if i find somebody
like because i've done this a couple
times too like i'll get in a
conversation with somebody that's super
into horror movies or super into mystery
science theater and i will talk for
[ __ ] five hours about that [ __ ]
and that's probably boring for people
that aren't into it so it's kind of the
same sort of thing
but
i feel like when you're in a nightclub
everybody's drinking you want to drink
and dance
and like hang out it's like you don't
really need to stand there for like two
hours one time talking about
a motorcycle well in one time and i'm
like are you gonna come dance are you
gonna do anything one time
i [ __ ] kicked my ass because we
talked me and him talked for two hours
it was two hours about ernst through
debt and she has no idea who that was
but we were talking about earth to debt
i was so drunk by that point i didn't
care who that was i was just kind of
like are you gonna like have a good time
are you just gonna like stand here
talking about [ __ ] when nobody cares
about you
mars dude was this [ __ ] it's like i'm
gonna go dance to some [ __ ] come on
champion [ __ ] stuka pilot he blew up
like [ __ ] 300 [ __ ] german tanks on
the eastern front and [ __ ] he ended
up working for fairchild industries and
bill he helped build the a-10
all right so that that
see there you go again
[Laughter]
we're talking buster we're talking about
okay okay yeah
pedophiles
and you're getting like all right excuse
me i got messed up his name is hans
rudel that was hans rudel not origins or
dead or hazardous i think i think it was
dude
and plus like sometimes you shouldn't
assume that i don't really because i'm
into like a lot of [ __ ] that
traditionally maybe like girls aren't
into
but
and i know a lot of [ __ ]
about [ __ ] that you would think that i
wouldn't know about just because i've
read a lot of stuff like over a broad
range of topics so sometimes in all of
my readings i've come across some of
this information like oh well yeah i
know who that is blah blah maybe i don't
know a huge amount about it but you know
what i mean so don't ever assume i don't
know anything about that [ __ ] but
um
i'm not really into
uh being in a nightclub where
you know i just want to dance and have a
good time and hang out with my friends
and stuff like that
um
that's him right there his name is hans
ulrich rudel he ended up being an
american
during
operation paper clip and built the a-10
and he was a tank busting king and he
he's got he wrote a really good book
about being a stuka ace pilot on the
eastern front i recommended reading he
got shot down multiple times lost a leg
went flew without his leg
uh a [ __ ] shot down [ __ ] who needs
legs he who needs legs he
shot down fighters from a phone he might
have said
got shot down several times and then
walked back and got another stuke and
went out and [ __ ] blew up somewhere
he hopped back probably uh he had a
wooden leg
[Laughter]
don't [ __ ] up my joke
[Laughter]
tammy said went to college with a guy
who looked like a ken doll his name was
todd of course it was but after a while
everyone called him ken so much he
answered to it
it became his [ __ ]
did he have like plastic hair that
didn't move
and was he smooth down there because i
kind of feel like that's ken's defining
feature but yeah at man ray we had a
girl who was [ __ ] she was one of the
local college students she looked just
like barbie [ __ ] from and we had
everybody called her barbie
and she was looked like a barbie doll
huh and she wasn't gothic but she
[ __ ] loved the gothic scene she would
just show up she was just uh
and she wasn't like she wasn't like no
she was like a preppy
interesting she loved the guy now
yeah long long hair long blonde hair and
everything
everybody called her barb well i mean
good for her yeah she went with it we
don't we like we don't mind normal
people like i said as long as they're
cool as long as they're cool and like
respectful don't come there if you come
there like all the time and you're like
into the music or you just like people
or whatever yeah then everyone doesn't
really care what you look like she was a
regular don't just come there and like
be like oh look how cool i am about them
and then like start making fun of people
and no she could she learned she saw the
[ __ ] wavy dances she could do the
[ __ ] gothic dances she liked all the
[ __ ] music
she didn't have any gothic clothes
though and she was a college student but
that's okay and that was her thing was
to [ __ ] show up and be barbie be the
local barbie dog i'm kind of more into
people that if if you know about the
music and you know about the culture i
don't really give a [ __ ] what you look
like you know what i mean like it's cool
if you have the look and everything like
that because i like that aesthetic but
you don't have to have that like as long
as you know what you're doing you know
yeah well what helped her is that she
was like a 10.
you know what i mean she she was a bar
well yeah hot chicks yeah she was if you
just look like a schlubby dude yeah it
wouldn't have worked or a fat girl no it
wouldn't have worked she was a [ __ ]
man so i hate to say but that's she look
like a model
maybe not so much fat girl but it's just
like somebody that's not like all that
attractive yeah mega says tom you're not
human you are a tom
he's a tom yeah
you're one of a kind what it is you're
one of a kind i don't know
i don't know
it is what it is
i've been drinking just just be you tom
yeah just be you
you know that's what that's what jenny
tries to do i decided i'm going to pull
a grand thread where is grantham's by
the way i decided i was gonna show up i
decided i was gonna be a granters and
like start referring to myself in the
third person
i don't know why i just decided that
where was i
all right so let's talk about this
[ __ ] again because we still got
a lot to cover
um you know okay
where was i
okay so he's on radio one
uh
for a while like i said he scammed the
bbc into like buying him a
what they call over there a camper van
it's kind of like an rv is what they're
talking about recreational vehicle
that's what he's talking about
which he would use subsequently to
go around and travel from place to place
and like be able to like pedo and like
[ __ ] molest people all across the
nation so you know there was that
uh so 1969 to 1973
uh he was on another show called
speakeasy which was like a discussion
program for teenagers he ended up
working at radio one for 19 years 19
years he worked for radio so it's like
among other things
1970 though
according to later investigation this is
when jimmy uh savile started to abuse
girls at this place called duncroft
manor which is like a girls school it
was a school for
girls that were like troubled or you
know had problems in regular schools and
they kind of put them in this school
young [ __ ] that's what they're talking
about or yeah it was that kind of stuff
well like not slut-shaming i'm just
saying these were girls that back in
1970 smoking and doing this and right
they were doing [ __ ] that girls
shouldn't be yeah they were promiscuous
or they were doing stuff their parents
didn't like essentially so they're just
like well we're just gonna put girl jail
we're gonna put you in girl jail yeah
and uh these poor girls
and some of them are like travels like
this well probably we'll see that's what
i mean and that's what and some of them
probably had some mental issues too
which like which they weren't real
understanding about in 1970 gotta say
so they put these girls in this home and
he's like uh yeah i'm gonna volunteer at
this girls school because i'm so [ __ ]
good-hearted and everything like that
and it's like here are all these teenage
girls who are a very vulnerable
population
and yeah he just did that his whole
entire [ __ ] i can't [ __ ] believe
this somebody gave him somebody gave him
the lowdown on it
the wild ones are over here that's
[ __ ] that's what happened that might
have been what happened it was sad
enough he's probably had some kind of
like [ __ ] hook up
like something there's some creep that
like worked there i think that's what
happened with these girls they're so
like they're they're so [ __ ] up you
can like you can tell them whatever
they're all damaged and you can do all
kind of well
i'm not going to name any names okay but
we knew we knew a guy
who actually said out loud
and i heard this
firsthand
that he likes to go after the vulnerable
girls like the girls that have just like
broken up or they've had some really bad
[ __ ] happen to them because they're like
much more
malleable i don't i don't think that's
the word that he used but that's what he
meant that's not a [ __ ]
white-haired [ __ ] slob [ __ ]
that i'm thinking of is it armpit licker
it's not that guy is it no okay i don't
know who that is i'm not gonna say who
it is don't worry about it but um
but i heard him say it was a long time
ago but i heard him say it and there is
a subset
of dudes
that know very well that when
younger women
uh come out of relationships or when
they're at a vulnerable point in their
lives they might make some questionable
decisions and the dude like was like
well i want to be one of those
questionable decisions
and they will absolutely swoop right in
any woman under the age of 30 is making
questionable decisions from my point of
view if you're or 40. i made some
questionable decisions in my 30s as well
it's even worse under the third women in
their [ __ ] late teens and 20s or
[ __ ] make some stupid ass decisions i
you know what i didn't really make any
dudes are even worse that's awesome i'm
just saying dudes are even worse yeah i
would [ __ ] do stupid [ __ ] good thing
i was in the army that i mean everybody
does stupid [ __ ] when they're young yeah
okay yeah
like don't kill anybody don't rape
anybody like don't do anything like that
everybody does stupid [ __ ] like you know
everybody's gotten drunk and like
[ __ ] had dicks wrong on their faces
like as long as it's [ __ ] like that
that's fine everybody's done that like i
said don't
a stupid decision doesn't mean oh i
raped a chick or that's not a stupid
decision that's not a guy that's like
[ __ ] monstrous right guys stupid
decision he's already [ __ ] had he's
already drank half a fifth of [ __ ]
whiskey
or vodka he gets on his motorcycle with
a [ __ ] loaded pistol in his hand and
tries to run across the [ __ ] top of a
[ __ ] four by four stretch between two
buildings see that's a good idea two or
three are here that's a good hold my
beard hold my beard [ __ ] is what is what
young guys do oh i can do this
yeah i can do this hold up i'm gonna
fire up two rounds get this [ __ ] on
[ __ ] camera yeah that's the kind of
that's what the army was saving me from
doing stupid [ __ ] like that that's
totally you would do that now yeah
you'd have if i didn't stop you yeah
if he got drunk enough that absolutely
sounds like something that you would
right even now and you're 50 something
you have to [ __ ] you have to put
couch and i'll be like tom you have to
couch it in a way that it's a challenge
you know i'm talking about
like for you know what i mean like
you're a [ __ ]
but dude i know you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because this and that you you're not
even close to what evil knievel could do
and then you start talking about evil
knievel and i was starting to be in but
see i'm a girl and even i know that
right it's like it's so easy to get you
guys to like do something dumb right
now
all you have to do is like eat again all
you have all you have to do is like
imply that you're maybe like not as
manly as you think you are yeah right
exactly and they'll do like whatever you
start bringing up mental health
legendary men from the past
[ __ ] you know the next thing you know
i'm i'm trying to very easily i'm trying
to out and do evil knievel and i'm
[ __ ] drunk as [ __ ]
like i said i could totally see you
doing that that's that's what can save
saves a lot of young men from that so i
can imagine like back when you're in
your 20s i didn't know you i didn't know
you back then it was probably like 100
times worse yeah and like i said i could
still imagine you doing that nowadays
yeah i had to have if i wasn't here you
probably would because i'd be like tom i
had to have a very structured
environment
uh and be around nothing but alpha
men that kept other [ __ ] alpha men in
check
you know it was a big [ __ ]
it was a tough guy competition but it
was for real
you know what i mean yeah you're a
person that definitely needs to be kept
in right yeah
by some other yeah yeah for really not
gonna listen to you unless i'm scared of
you
that's really what it what it boils down
to are you scared of me
no but i respect what you say but i'm
not scared of you now
no [ __ ] not in that same way
there were dudes in the army
that i that i thought might kill me and
that's i'm not lying because we had
murders happen in my years well i might
kill you you're right
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
my unit you never know my my unit helped
change the army
we had guys in our units that [ __ ]
murdered dudes in the chain of commands
and mass shootings they shot up the
goddamn
they shot up and killed [ __ ] the
girls at the damn massage parlor down at
fort campbell
that was because dude found his wife out
there giving hand jobs he went berserk
and killed her and [ __ ] all every
other person in the massage parlor and
then himself
yeah and he was like
just start with yourself and save the
world a lot of time
the mind-altering experience you know
and uh they just they stopped making bad
[ __ ] like us after all that
kind of [ __ ] started to happen
well and thankfully killed that first
sergeant nobody needs that
[ __ ] aggro yeah
because you never know when you're gonna
like pop off you might get mad at me and
like [ __ ] do some [ __ ] those days are
over but it was uh you beat on a dog
long enough they'll bite back and that
was just the way it was back then
we were training for world war three
it wasn't a joke it was not a joke at
all you know [ __ ] okay mars attacks
he watched that the other day they they
showed old [ __ ] dumbass joining the
army and he gets [ __ ] but it's just
kind of [ __ ] it was just a joke
but really in the 90s the army was not a
joke at all [ __ ] we thought that we
were going to go to [ __ ] some kind of
nuclear warfare with our soviets well i
mean it was possible even i mean even
though that was more an 80s thing i mean
there was still like a carry over sure
oh yeah
yeah
it was the same guys training who came
up in that that culture
and it wasn't a bad culture it was just
that even good things can become extreme
over time and
well that's just the way it was
tyler the guy says turns out tom crash
landed on earth like superman and
somewhere there's a planet populated
entirely by toms yeah i got to get back
there
i want to see what the female toms look
like
i want to see what the female times yeah
i don't know if they're ugly if they're
ugly i'm coming right back
i see a short story in this situation
i think the female toms look like laura
cause she's a ross too
you're hoping that that's probably what
they look like because laura's beautiful
yeah our friend laura well a lot of
louder she has like they're not related
but her last name is also wrong
uh and she's like a really good friend
of ours and she is [ __ ] gorgeous and
the thing about it is that she's
gorgeous and she is also real friendly
awesome really yeah she is like just a
lovely lovely person she's a lovely
person she looks she actually looks like
the rosses in my family don't look like
that they're all they're all red skinny
redheads all right including my my dad
kind of he's kind of a stocky ridge but
in a way laura kind of looks like
most of the women on my mom's side of
the family she doesn't really look like
her she she looks i wonder if you're
like distantly related um they probably
prefer pretty dissonant she says she has
a lot of greek
influence in her family i don't know um
i can show laura
i got picture laura yeah we might i mean
there's yeah there's like i said laura
would talk about it we would laugh that
that we do
we do look a little bit alike but
slightly but we're we're not related
yeah they have the same last name but
yeah we used to like joke about it
but yeah i might i hang out with laura's
like she's like that's laura and jen the
one in all black is laura yeah and
that's jen in red yeah i don't know if i
can get it to yeah that's at our house
i can't get her nose to focus in well
nobody knows he's focusing in yeah
i mean that was a while back but yeah
and like i said she's not only i mean
jen is like this too they're not only
like ridiculously beautiful
physically but they're also like real
nice really awesome people you know what
i mean which
is pretty cool
it's pretty cool yeah uh all right so
yeah that was me in military school
shaking the hands of a [ __ ] general
and [ __ ] i i grew up in the [ __ ]
at southern california military academy
the same military academy that was
featured in the movie over the top with
sylvester stallone
i was in that school wait was that the
arm wrestling movie the arm wrestling
movie
the arm wrestling movie yeah
we should review that one no we
shouldn't i don't want to watch that
[ __ ] again
i've seen it a couple of times
uh you know like i said i used to be
married to somebody who's really an
american actually yes so i've seen like
all the stupid ones
uh yeah planet of the rise of the planet
of the times holy crap
john gore says my grandma's boyfriend
eddie once said
priests have the best means of getting
what they're after in the confessional
they can figure out which of the naughty
boys and which are not
yeah and like i said i would never
i would never like do a blanket
statement like oh i'll pre-serve this or
all you know truck drivers or serial
killers or whatever
but
on the flip side of that there is a
disproportionate
amount of people like pedophiles and
stuff like that in
jobs where they have a lot of uh
interaction with children like i said
priests or daycare workers or something
like that that's not to say that they're
all pedophiles obviously
but there's probably like a tiny
percentage or like a larger percentage
than in the general population because
people that are that have that
proclivity like i said are gonna go into
that line of work so they have uh you
know access to
victims uh you know
so there's that
um yeah so we were talking about the
duncraft uh duncroft rather manor which
is a girls school
so he starts volunteering there and
everyone's like oh this famous person he
wants to come and volunteer oh he cares
so much about like these vulnerable
young people yeah uh sure that's what he
wanted everybody to think uh and later
on
you know a lot of people came out and
said yeah he had [ __ ] raped them or
molested them [ __ ] like that
1972
uh there's another police report and
like i said some of the [ __ ] was
reported to the police but
one because the dude was famous and had
some money too
uh because
this was
60s 70s they didn't really take this
[ __ ] as seriously as they take it
nowadays i want to say
um
so people were kind of like meh it
wasn't really that big of a deal i kind
of feel like they thought it wasn't
maybe that big of a deal
um so 1972 there's actually a police
report though
of
jimmy savile
groping a 12 year old boy and his two
female friends
who had come to be on top of the pops
now top of the pops later on went to
like 18 plus you know you had to be or
16 plus yeah you had to be like older to
be on the show but prior to that
they let
younger kids like come on the show stop
the pops you know what i mean it's like
everybody's gonna come and listen to
records and dance is gonna be a fun time
but after this [ __ ] happened they're
like yeah now everybody has to be like
[ __ ]
of age we don't want any more like
[ __ ] 12 year olds in here getting
groped by
creeps because that's what was happening
you know so yeah uh that ended up
happening and like i said there's
actually a video
of
jimmy's having
it's [ __ ] mind-blowing when you watch
it i don't remember what year it was
from it was from
pro i think it was the late 60s or early
70s
and there's like i said there's a group
of people he's standing there talking to
the microphone and this girl like
standing right next to him and you could
tell that he because she jumps like that
like like he grabbed her ass or he
grabbed her
you know he grabbed something and she
was like what the [ __ ] like she goes
like that and like some people around
were like huh look at that but nobody
like did anything yeah
and
look let me tell you let me tell you
boys some
don't like please don't please don't
please
please don't grab anything you don't if
you don't know her okay
i mean that shouldn't have to be said
but and especially apparently it does
especially if you're not eight plus if
you're famous
and you're [ __ ] at eight or a nine or
a ten yeah you can do that no you can
yes you can no you can't [ __ ] arnold
schwarzenegger used to do that the
[ __ ] women they [ __ ] loved it
arnold schwarzenegger did that to me i
would kick him right in the [ __ ] tape
that's not what happened though he's
very charismatic and they were there to
see him
and he would do that kind of [ __ ]
it all depends on the [ __ ] zeitgeist
of [ __ ] who's involved and what the
situation is
arnold that all the time this is my
arnold did that [ __ ] all the time so
he's also a sexual predator is what
you're saying well he'd show up
hey you know yeah yeah [ __ ] right he
was a sexual predator hell yeah he would
get it he would get [ __ ] too yeah
it depends on how you look and what the
situation attitude was contributing to
why
why this [ __ ] never got caught
because of attitudes like that
well another thing
jenny jenny's looking at this from the
point of view of a normal person of a
normal person okay oh exactly imagine
that that is not imagine that is not the
life i apologize
that it's not the life out of well i'm
not from planet tom
you clearly are there's
[Laughter]
she can [ __ ] she'll attest to it
before we were going out
there were girls that would come on to
me
and i [ __ ] grab them
and they'd [ __ ] damn have the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] showing and [ __ ] and
they'd give me head in the back of the
club
yeah but one but they weren't miners no
of course two they were girls that were
already into you yeah well the dudes
that are doing that are usually into
doing that to girls that are already
into them well that's a different
situation we're talking about people
that right
right that's that there's no consent i
did this [ __ ] this is just somebody
that's standing there like next to a
person you don't expect this person to
like saying and i'm saying not to do i
did it but i knew i could do it
because of who was involved yeah so did
jimmy savile
[Laughter]
no i knew i could do it because they
were interested
but see that's different like i said if
you if you know that person right
right that's what i'm saying i said that
the problem with jimmy savile was like
these were just people that showed up
for the taping of top of the pops right
he's like they knew who he was because
he's famous he's assuming that girl's
there for him that girl is probably
there for one of the other dudes that's
in the [ __ ] car that's what i'm
saying
it's like and you can't assume that
because you don't know that person
personally
like i said yeah you did some of that
but you knew those girls yeah personally
like you knew them or knew somebody that
knew them
they were crazy as [ __ ]
it's not like they were strangers to you
right right that they had just turned up
for a taping of a tv show and they were
[ __ ] 14. right that's like a
different situation
it's still not a great attitude but
it's a different situation yeah
um you can't just randomly grab [ __ ]
14 year olds no
so that even if you're famous that's
that girl is 14 he's grabbing in the
crowd i don't remember yeah i think she
was 14 14 15 nasty [ __ ] that's
what i mean well that's he liked him
that age yeah
so
well that's the thing it's like you
can't just assume
even if they did come there because they
know you and you're famous and like you
still can't assume
and i kind of feel like that's what
pissed me off
the [ __ ] eye contact well that's what
pissed me off the most about that dude
was that he just assumed well they
probably became here because i'm famous
so i can do whatever the [ __ ] i want to
do that's he really did seem to have
that like attitude and that just like
really made me want to like punch him
right in the dick like the whole every
time i saw him talk i was just like i
would really like to punch your head
right off your shoulders right right now
it's just like he just made me so so
angry because he was so like i said smug
i hate smug oh my god i hate smug so
much and it's just like
don't do [ __ ] like that and then be
[ __ ] smug about it that just like
[ __ ] amps up the [ __ ] oh i hate
that stuff john jumped in and says
arnold spent most of his adult life in a
hyper-sexualized environment yes he did
he did
i don't really
i don't agree with [ __ ] the way
arnold turned out in his older age but
but i understand arnold i've studied
that [ __ ] from an early age you
cannot take him seriously he's a joker
he's funny as [ __ ] he's very
charismatic and he trolls the [ __ ] out
of people just because he comes out with
a video talking about vegan [ __ ]
bodybuild
that
that [ __ ] has lied from day one
okay you can go all the way back to
pumping iron and that [ __ ] was lying
back then about what it was he was doing
he never admitted to [ __ ] steroid use
i can understand why he never did that
but because in those days people thought
and it's partially to this day that they
think that if you take anabolic steroids
that you can just inject anabolic
steroids and get huge and sit on your
ass and eat and get huge that is not
what happens they
they would they didn't admit to it back
then
because they didn't want to undermine
the work that they had created you still
have to [ __ ] lift lots of weights to
get as big as arnold you still got to
have big good genetics
and a great diet
to look as good as he did
but i'm gonna give arnold this before i
move on because we're in the middle of
the show
arnold got [ __ ] huge when he was
young
he won all these competitions but really
man arnold looked best when he was in
predator one at 41 42 years old
he was [ __ ] much much lighter and
smaller than he was when he was a kid
he was a lot closer to the what's
possible
for a normal man
who wasn't on steroids i think
uh
so
for me at arnold zenith was [ __ ]
predator one and he was not [ __ ]
super super jacked like he was when he
was a kid
so
i don't know what i mean by that i'm
just saying you know he was a legend
even when he wasn't [ __ ] jacked to
the gills that's what that's what i'm
talking about although i will say from a
woman's point of view like or at least
from one woman's point of view to me
uh back in the old days after i saw
pumping iron i was like oh he's gross
and he's a creep
well he was supposed to be kind of a bad
guy in that way but yeah i thought he
was he was funny you know he was an
[ __ ] he's fun
i don't really find [ __ ] all that
funny to be honest with you i'm just
gonna especially ones like that because
like i said
dudes like that is the reason that jimmy
savile got away with what the [ __ ] that
he got away with after all this time but
hold on you're blaming jenny you're
blaming him no no i'm just saying that
the whole no no i'm just saying that the
whole culture around it
the whole culture around it where oh
dudes will do that that's that what
they're like and it's just a joke and
you're taking it too seriously
that's why he got away with it for so
long i'm just saying that like the whole
like uh culture
no it wasn't no i'm just saying no i'm
just saying that it was part of like a
larger narrative
star culture yeah that's what i'm saying
that was the old school that's part of
that whole like attitude and that goes
back to the 20s
yeah it goes back to the 20s it was bad
then
yeah the world's changed uh but like but
i'm gonna go back and and said what i'm
gonna say
arnold's greatness wasn't his size it
was
his [ __ ] story and his [ __ ] his
attitude and the [ __ ] that he did all
those movies that he made
and i thought he looked best in predator
one and he wasn't that g he wasn't he
was half the size as he was
uh when he was [ __ ] doing ifp when he
was doing olympia half that size
sizes and everything
well most people oh tina jumps in tila
says more for tom's test team don't give
him any more don't encourage him no no
i got that [ __ ] stockpiled we're already
trying to like talk about other [ __ ] i
guess they're talking about arnold
schwarzenegger for whatever reason oh
[ __ ] coming we're gonna see where to see
okay
honestly i'm not i'm not really a big
fan of like what the [ __ ] is doing to my
voice
um i have a friend
uh my friend angel
she says to me
watch your book reviews from uh a year
ago yeah and listen to how much your
voice is different
and i was like listening to one the
other day because i'm rewriting like a
lot of my book reviews like for a new
blog that i'm doing because i want to do
like written versions of them so i went
back and listened to one of the
uh book reviews that i did like a year
or 18 months ago or something like that
and my voice sounds completely different
yeah well part of it part of it though
is psychological you're a lot more
confident than you were because it does
make you a lot more aggressive
so you're um you speak from your
diaphragm now then you
uh as opposed to speaking from no i know
what that is because i did singing my
whole life i know what speaking from the
diaphragm i know all about them really
because i grew up doing that but
it's not that
it's not that well
you you
you're not doing as much as you used to
do
okay
so all that's just temporary
it should go back to i don't know we'll
see yeah
because now i'm like listen to my voice
i'm like oh my god i sound like a dude
no you don't sound like a dude
to me i do no you don't sound like a
dude
i'll let you listen to [ __ ] bakar
nabiva's voice she sounds like a dude
but she looks gorgeous
but she she does she's well i sound like
a dude compared to what i used to sound
like is what i'm saying like a year ago
yeah
no
no you don't sound like a dude if you
listen
i'll play you that video i'll play it
you just have a louder voice i was
shocked you enunciated because i didn't
think yeah a lot like when she said
something about it i was like ah you're
tripping but then like i listen that
video the other day i'm like oh my god
she's right nah she's like she's she's
trying to uh no she was right
she was right
yeah
it was a it was a huge difference well
you can come off if you want to
you'll gain weight
you'll gain weight
you know but you'll take you off if you
want
i didn't really want to be on the first
place okay we'll take you off i'm just
gonna take you off
but you know prepare to get fat
i'm already fat nah you're not fat
[Laughter]
it's not gonna be any worse i promise oh
it'll be much worse no it won't okay
that will all right we'll take you off
then you know you know what you're
no you you don't you know okay i'm not
you it's it's a different thing okay
all right so yeah tila is like talking
about your tester and does it look like
funny yeah all right so
uh all right so where was i was the
whole girls school thing yeah special
all right so we got the whole great
groping the 12 year old boy thing so
like i said i kind of feel like
80 85 percent of his victims
usually fit females but
uh he wouldn't pass up a boy if it came
along
uh like i said he would pretty much like
uh molest anyone that moved so there was
that
but nobody really knew about this
they did but
it wasn't like huge public knowledge so
he's still like allowed to [ __ ]
operate with impunity everyone thought
he was an awesome dude
so he's getting real famous at this
point they decide they're gonna put him
in a bunch of like uh those old like
public information movies you know i
mean like
you know uh doing some [ __ ] so his first
one that he did probably the most
popular one that he did was
promoting road safety or more
specifically promoting
wearing your seatbelt in the car
so he was kind of like in all these
commercials for
doing your belt up and it was called
this is like the dumbest name ever
clunk click every trip
that was what the whole campaign was
called and it was like a whole wear your
seat belts dumbasses so you don't like
die in a [ __ ] accident
now
uh so he's doing all that he did like
some commercials for like the rail
system and he did like a bunch of other
[ __ ] too
now at this point he's still hosting top
of the pops
but
he's getting into his 40s at this point
and the makers of the show were like
well it's looking a little ridiculous
because like i said
if you don't know he had um
he seemed to want to look as ridiculous
as possible so he had like this bleach
blonde hair that was like kind of long
and he had like the bangs and [ __ ] and
he would always wear
these like really stupid looking outfits
like he always wore like [ __ ] track
suits and they were like gold or
metallic or something and he always had
like these [ __ ]
gold chains and like i don't know he
just like wore crazy [ __ ] all the time
so people would like talk about him i
guess
um and that stupid [ __ ]
bleach blonde hair that he had
that just looked awful so he's in his
what oh okay
but that was a super chat team
i know i taught i said that a long time
ago i had said that a long time ago i'm
already on it all right um
but yeah so
so yeah he had like this white wispy
hair and blah blah so he's on top of the
pops which is
a show geared primarily toward
teenagers or people in their 20s he's
kind of in his 40s at this point and his
like old because like i said he's one of
those people that like look like an old
person even when he was a young person
so this creepy old dude is like dancing
around with his cardigan and his [ __ ]
white ass hair and his old ass looking
face and he's in his 40s and they're
like yeah this is looking a little
ridiculous so we're not going to have
him on top of the pops anymore but
they decide to give him his own show
now he had an idea for a show
and they actually allowed him to do it
now this show i remember hearing about
the show like back in the 80s and
thinking wow that's a cool idea for a
[ __ ] like back in the 80s when i was a
kid
um and it was called gym we'll fix it
now because
jimmy savile was so connected
and so wealthy by this point he was able
to like pull strings and get [ __ ] done
right so what people would do is mostly
kids
and they would write into the show and
they would say with the thing that i
want to do like most in the world is
swim with dolphins or
meet this famous band or whatever the
[ __ ] um you know it's and he would like
do it so he would like pick out a letter
and he was like this kid wants to do
this that and the other and
we're gonna fix it and they do the show
like about this kid getting to do this
thing it was kind of like the
make-a-wish foundation except the kid
wasn't dying is that like [ __ ] up to
say but yeah it's kind of like a similar
kind of concept
so it was his idea and this show was on
for like a really long time it was on
from 1975 to 1994 so almost 20 years uh
this [ __ ] show was on like i said i
never saw it at the time but i heard
about it and i thought oh that's a good
idea for a show where they just have
like kids come on and getting their
wishes granted it was usually like to
meet someone famous or something like
that so he could usually like set that
up so it's like super super popular what
what maybe oh i feel like you're like
looking back there like smirking like
something's going on okay
so the show was like a massive hit and
you know it's kind of part of a lot of
uh
british people of a certain age it's
kind of part of their childhood
uh and this is this will never not be
funny to me but jimmy savile won an
award
from mary whitehouse's national viewers
and listeners association 1977 for
wholesome family entertainment mary
whitehouse
the stupid old conservative crone behind
the whole video nasty debacle
gave jimmy salman
an award for wholesome family
entertainment that is [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious she was lost she was
the one
she was the one that was like we can't
have any of these horror movies and
pulled all the horror movies off the
shelves and they're all video nasties
and they were actually like arresting
video store owners for like having these
particular
that's hilarious yeah i did a show about
a long time don't trust these [ __ ]
politicians man they're not qualified to
tell you how to live [ __ ]
she's lost in the [ __ ] matrix she's
dead she was i mean she was old back
then yeah
she's like they're just in there for the
money they're just trying
to well the thing about it like some of
them i think mary whitehouse
from what i know about her she seemed
like one of those kind of like true
believer kind of she's just like
regulating everybody's morals we can't
have like people watching these horror
movies yeah but she can't see immorality
when it's right in front of her don't
listen that's what i'm saying they're
not saying the fact that they're not
qualified to lead you they're not
leaders they're politicians and
politicians are [ __ ] they're just
[ __ ]
zach said thank you zach show on mary
and the video nasties when i did um
i did a show on video nasties i don't
remember if you were on it or i might
have done it by myself but that was a
long time ago i kind of feel like we
maybe need to update that because
if we did the show it was probably just
me and it was a long time ago and i had
to cut it a lot out because it was just
an hour
but that would actually be a fascinating
topic i mean the movies they picked to
be on the video nasties list were just
so [ __ ] random you could tell that
they didn't really do like a great deal
of
uh research into what was actually in
these movies
and
actually i'm always i'm actually really
fascinated by the whole history of like
censorship
of movies particularly horror movies in
britain and the us because the us did it
too i know we like to like [ __ ] [ __ ]
on the brits for doing that [ __ ] but we
do it sometimes worse uh so
we we do it as well but uh everybody
knows about like the video nasties thing
so yeah we should probably like do a
revisit on that maybe i'll put that in
the next poll and we'll see how that
comes out
so yeah so he got an award from her
which i thought was like very funny
and uh so he was like i said he was in a
lot of commercials and [ __ ] like that
uh they did public info [ __ ] about like
the rail system and blah blah
now
uh sometime during the 1980s there's a
police report
uh of a female victim we don't know her
name or age or anything like that
and she actually reported to the police
that she had been sexually assaulted by
jimmy savile in his
camper van
in the parking lot of the bbc because
that's where he parked it when he wasn't
out traveling around doing his show
right
now they can't find this file they don't
know if they lost it or something like
that but they do think that it was
reported at the time
uh and as i mentioned earlier this
camper
he kind of like talked the bbc into
buying it for him because he said it was
like an expense for his
travel show so uh so yeah so but he
parked at the bbc and he apparently like
assaulted some people in there
now uh so he
during the time that all of this was
going on uh as i said he was involved in
like multiple charities they think that
over the time that he was involved in
all these charities he raised probably
about 40 million pounds which like i
said it's not nothing it doesn't negate
what he did though but you know i'm sure
the people were happy to get the money
but you know
now one of the cause that he raises one
of the causes that he raised money for
was the stoke mandeville hospital which
i think i mentioned earlier
now he had uh volunteered there for many
years as a porter
and he also volunteered this [ __ ]
blows my mind he also volunteered at uh
leeds general infirmary which i
mentioned earlier he also
volunteered at broadmoor which like i
said we brought up broadmoor before
because [ __ ] bronson stayed there
like [ __ ] serial killers stayed there
like i think one of the craze was there
the [ __ ] york ripper [ __ ] like that
it's for like the criminally insane
right
um i'm sure they have like regular like
mental patients there too but it's
generally for the criminally insane
that's what people know about it i think
we did a show about the about broadmoor
didn't we yeah and i think we brought it
up on that
so
he was basically
put
like he doesn't have and he met he's
just like a [ __ ] dude he's a dude
that
was a dj and then he was on tv
he doesn't have any medical
background or nothing
and they put him like on this board that
was kind of like in charge of and they
gave him pretty much the run of
broadmoor they gave him keys
to the hospital
and they gave him like pretty much like
he had his own like little quarters like
his own little living quarters on the
thing like on the grounds
and he could just like come and go as he
plays like nobody said boo to him
uh which
didn't work out so well spoiler alert i
mean he was just basically going in
there and
these are people that you know had
mental issues obviously
and
if he did things to them and they
reported it they would probably not be
believed
you know because
they had mental issues so and he
absolutely knew that
so like i said he was somebody that was
very very manipulative and was targeting
people
like that on purpose he was targeting
vulnerable populations on purpose and i
think that that's probably why he
volunteered at so many hospitals over
the years
uh you know and wormed his way into hey
give me the keys to broadmoor so i can
go in there and [ __ ] rape people
with impunity and no one will like
[ __ ] say anything about it and even
if they do like nobody would believe
them or they'd think they were just like
oh whatever
it's [ __ ] up i mean that's
that's one of the like worst kind of
criminals because it's not even like he
was oh he didn't know what he's doing or
he just like was he absolutely knew what
he was doing it's very very calculated
you're all right
drop a [ __ ]
so uh so he sets up two charities uh the
jimmy savile stoke mandeville hospital
trust that was in 1981
and the
jimmy savile charitable trust 1984 that
was his base in leeds
now
so he gave like all of this money to
them like over the years but after the
scandal broke after he was [ __ ] dead
not until 2012
the charities actually the money they
got from him
they um
decided that they were gonna like shut
down and like you know send their money
elsewhere so
you know there was that too
now uh let's see there were some quotes
about him during his life
during his lifetime at the time of his
death savile was regarded as an
eccentric adornment to british public
life a ubiquitous and distinctive face
on television who relished being in the
public eye yano [ __ ]
and was a shrewd promoter of his own
image
and that is
exactly how he came across to me he
comes across as someone that
doesn't like i said i never met him in
real life obviously but everything that
i saw about him all the interviews that
i saw with him he seemed very much like
someone that was just all about
image and he was all about appearance he
wanted everybody to
think a certain way about him but he was
candy enough to know
that he's like well i'm doing all this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] so i have to have some
kind of like
defense mechanism or like i said that
like that psychologist called it a
double bluff where it's like well
i kind of know that there's all of these
rumors that i did this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
even though i've never been arrested for
it technically so he's like i'm just
gonna come out and say that i did that
[ __ ] without actually saying it but i'm
gonna say it in a way that makes it seem
like a joke or
that is like so over the top that no one
will actually believe it because he
almost came across
as
like a cartoon character like the way
that he looked he didn't look like a
real person i mean with his ridiculous
clothes and his ridiculous hair and like
just he would just say outrageous things
and so he kind of got
known in public as being like a
personality more than like a person you
know what i mean and i think he
absolutely
used that to his advantage because he's
like look everybody knows me as this
persona
and i'm gonna use that i'm gonna come
out and say oh yeah well they don't know
if i'm a pedophile maybe i am maybe i'm
not but he's gonna say [ __ ] like that
and because he's so brazen about it
i think that people were like oh he must
be joking he can't really be like saying
out loud that he would do that kind of
stuff so i think that he absolutely did
that on purpose but he was definitely
that kind of like narcissistic
kind of person the funny here's the
funny thing too his [ __ ] clothes were
so ridiculous
that for a while
um there were a series of halloween
costumes which were licensed by him by
the way like he allowed it to happen
uh that you could dress up as him for
halloween if you were if you were into
that um because if you've seen him it's
a very distinctive
look that he had honestly i don't know
if i'd call it distinctive other than
the hair
but
i mean once he got into that whole like
bleaching the hair and it was kind of
like this thin
white
thing that he had going on
and he would usually wear like a
tracksuit type thing and it was usually
like metallic like gold or like metallic
teal or some crap like that
and
but to me like i saw some other footage
of him and it just looked like he was
looking for the most ridiculous thing
that he could put it was like a tiger
king situation
which like i said i guess it worked for
tiger king too
it's like
you know if you just wanna
if you just want attention you just have
to like look as ridiculous as possible
and be willing to let yourself look
ridiculous and i kind of feel like
he absolutely
knew what he was doing in that regard
because it worked like i said he did get
absolutely famous everybody in the
country knew who that [ __ ] was
um he was also like a big uh real into
smoking cigars and he was always smoking
a cigar all the time
and one of his famous quotes was my dad
gave me a drag on one at christmas cigar
i mean thinking it would put me off them
forever but it had the opposite effect
so he smoked cigars pretty much his
whole entire life and lived until he was
85 so almost 85 so you know there
there's that
uh and as i mentioned earlier he was
also a member of mensah so he wasn't a
dummy
um and as i said too that margaret
thatcher was such a good friend of his
that uh she was actually the person that
kept pushing to get him knighted
even though some other people
in the government were like uh we've
heard some bad [ __ ] about him we might
not want to do that but she just kept
pushing and pushing and pushing and then
finally he did get knighted in 1990.
um
but apparently margaret thatcher and him
were such close friends that he spent
a whole bunch of like new year's eves
with them like with the thatcher family
like at their house so
it wasn't just some kind of like oh a
new market thatcher kind of thing they
hung out
now as i said he also hung out a lot
with prince charles
uh they apparently met each other doing
like some mutual charity work
and
because of his because of um
jimmy savile's work with
the stoke mandeville hospital
prince charles felt pretty comfortable
going to
jimmy savile of all [ __ ] people
to
get advice on
britain's health authorities quote
unquote
like i said jimmy savile was a [ __ ]
nobody he was a dude that like became a
dj and then got famous like on tv he was
on top of the pop stuff he didn't know
anything about medical anything the fact
that he just like had money and he
decided he was gonna like give money to
these like hospitals or whatever and
suddenly he's an expert on [ __ ] then
like prince charles says oh i'm gonna
like consult him on so but you know what
i mean that's like [ __ ] up he doesn't
know anything about anything
um now him and charles hung out
diana
uh
was apparently not so keen
now
when charles and diana were
at you know kind of going in for their
divorce or whatever
um apparently
uh jimmy savile was like inserting
himself into the thing like hey i'm here
if either of you guys need guys need to
talk i'm gonna like moderate the
situation between you guys like he was
doing that kind of [ __ ] and like prince
charles was kind of like okay thanks man
like thanks for being there diana
apparently thought he was a creep like
from the get-go and was just kind of
like she's like he would show up in my
house like at kensington palace like
where she lived like unannounced and
they and like the guards would just like
let him in she's like they don't let
anybody in
but because it was him they let his dumb
ass in it's like nobody invited him he
just like comes over and he's like hey
you want to talk about the divorce blah
blah she's like he was like super creepy
but diana thought he was creepy but
prince charles apparently thought he was
an okay guy so there's that
here's another thing
now
this is so weird because i kind of feel
like this is something that would be
asked about
more
i don't know i kind of feel like that
would be asked about more nap like back
then but nobody asked him about this
so jimmy savile never married
and even though he was rich and famous
was never seen with any girlfriends or
anything like that nobody and the weird
thing about it is like nobody said oh
he's gay or anything there were no there
was nothing like that
um which to me is very strange because i
kind of feel like if it was anybody else
people would have been like speculating
but nobody did and i'm really not sure
why that is
so um i've never seen the guy maybe they
didn't just see him as a sexual person
so they're like well it could have been
that because he looks yeah because he
doesn't look like someone who would get
laid right like you know buddy hackett
remember that [ __ ] funny as a
[ __ ] had all kinds of money they
weren't asking where his wife was or his
girl i didn't even know if that dude had
a wife or a girlfriend buddy hackett was
much cuter than jimmy sample gonna say
that little short fat drunk irishman
okay that's all right but he was funny
though oh man he was great on the liar's
club
yeah he was [ __ ] he was funny yeah
but yeah maybe that's why maybe they
just thought he was so like creepy and
gross and ugly looking that it's like no
that it never occurred to anybody didn't
even think of it
maybe that's what it was probably that's
possible because he didn't look like a
because they're only worried about what
what hot [ __ ] going out with
somebody that's true
that's true but yeah he never uh he
never married he never had a girlfriend
or nothing like that and it must be said
he had a really weird thank you zack
same with kevin spacey never seen dating
anyone and real secret about his private
life and then look what came out no pun
intended about him and the weird thing
about that though is that nobody's
speculated yeah he is and so is jimmy
savile but the thing about kevin spacey
was that kevin spacey wasn't a bad
looking dude so it seems like you would
get more like rumor [ __ ] about oh maybe
he's gay or something like maybe there
was i don't know i don't really follow
that kind of stuff but
the weird thing about that i found about
jimmy savile was that usually
if a celebrity of that magnitude if they
don't have a significant other or
they're not seen as being like a playboy
or something like people start
talking like oh maybe they're gay or
maybe something else is going on or
something like that but it seems like
nobody really did that about jimmy
savile which i think is very strange but
like i said it might be because he was
so [ __ ] ugly that nobody because he
is he was pretty [ __ ] ugly and funny
looking so um and not just
i mean if he had
he made himself funny looking he wasn't
naturally funny like he was a little bit
funny looking but if he had dressed like
a normal person and had a haircut like a
normal person or something like that or
if he'd made himself look good
um then he would have looked totally
acceptable but the fact that he made
himself look clownish or like as
ridiculous as possible um probably
didn't help everybody just thought well
what woman want to [ __ ] sleep with
that apparently nobody and that's why he
had to [ __ ] rape 12 year olds so
um but yeah there's that so uh yeah
american military 100 says savville did
not exude any sexual charisma yeah maybe
that's what it was like i said that's
probably why he had to be afraid okay so
one thing i will say and this probably
contributed
now as i mentioned earlier
jimmy savile was the youngest of seven
children and he said that he grew up
very poor and that it was very very hard
to get attention which like i said would
explain the attention whoring later on
but it was very very hard to get
attention with all of these uh siblings
now later on in his life though he
developed a kind of a weird relationship
with his mom
he called his mom the duchess
he lived with his mom until he was 40.
and
some now some interviewers did think
that was weird so they were just kind of
like well
do you have like some weird thing going
on with your mom it's like is that why
you don't have a girlfriend or a wife or
whatever
and he's like oh it's not because of
that it's not that me and her have
something going on it's that
if i had a girlfriend and i asked her to
move in then my mom is scared that i
would kick her out of the house that was
the excuse that he gave
like why there was this weird like why
he lived with his mom for so long and
why he didn't have a girlfriend and like
it just i don't know it just seemed very
norm and baitsy to me
so
there was that kind of situation and uh
after she died
he kept all of her clothes and her
bedroom and she liked it very much like
norman bates just the way it was when
she died every year he would have all
her clothes dry cleaned and he would
like do this big cleaning of the room it
was like a shrine yeah it's it's pretty
weird that's a weird that's weird
um
so
it is autobiography though because like
i said earlier of course he wrote one
he says
oh of course i had many sexual
relationships with women of course
of course
yeah how consensual were they that's a
different question but yeah
this is the quote from his autobiography
um when i i assume he's talking about oh
all the places he's had sex because he
thinks this makes him sound cool i guess
and he says there have been trains and
boats and planes oh the places i'm a
member of the 40 000 foot club like oh
i've banged somebody in a plane we
should [ __ ] you no you haven't well like
i said miles
not consensually yeah they got miles in
england come on
yeah you know what miles are yeah and
bushes and fields corridors doorways
floors chairs slag heaps desks and
probably everything except the
celebrated chandelier and irony board
like i said this is probably true
but were those girls willing partners
probably not jeffrey comes in with five
dollars this is i believe top brass in
the uk media knew and didn't want to
rock the boat i agree okay it does seem
like they did kind of know and they were
just kind of like well they crushed all
speculation that's what he said i got i
got to read out what his chat is yeah i
believe so thank you jeffy art i believe
yeah it's like and i don't even think i
don't even think the people that knew
about it
were necessarily in on it they were just
like they didn't really want to get
involved and they're like well look it's
like he works here it's like he makes a
lot of money it's like if we say
something bad about him he'll sue us
because he did threaten to do that he
also threatened to like you know have
people killed and [ __ ] like that so they
were like well it's easier just to like
not say anything so i think a lot of
people just like turned you know just
turned a blind eye to it and just let
him do whatever and like i said
particularly in the 60s and 70s a lot of
people were doing [ __ ] like that and
they were just kind of like well i did
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] too so maybe i
shouldn't report this [ __ ] you
know what i mean because then my [ __ ]
will come out so i think there was maybe
some [ __ ] about that too but yeah so he
so jimmy in his autobiography said you
know made took great pains in like
saying yeah i've had ladies
in all of these places
um you know she lives in canada you
wouldn't know her it was that kind of
thing um but like i said
i kind of feel like maybe that was just
so he would seem more normal or
me like i said maybe that was true but
the women weren't really consenting so
there was that whole issue
so even as far back though as 1991 as i
mentioned earlier
um
they've started doing interviews and
this is when the [ __ ] was still
alive
they started doing interviews with uh
you know psychiatrists and stuff like
that like trying to analyze this
[ __ ] because like i said the
rumors and accusations about this stuff
even though he had never been
uh formally questioned
he had never been like he had been
questioned by the police but nobody
really did anything it's like he'd never
been formally charged or anything like
that
so but rumors had still been circulating
like the whole time like it seemed like
a lot of people knew what the [ __ ] he
was up to and didn't really do anything
about it or couldn't really prove it you
know
so some psychiatrists came out in 1991
and said that he seemed to be as i
mentioned earlier quote unquote a man
without feelings
um they said pretty much all that he
talks about when you talk to him is
money like the material [ __ ] that he has
and
denying that he feels anything
um which seemed very uh instructive i
guess
and
so even back in 1991 some of the
interviewers thought that it was very
weird
that he hadn't had any like actual
relationships he could talk about he
didn't really talk about like his
feeling he didn't really talk about
anything like a real person would talk
about and so they speculated well he's
probably got some like you know sketchy
[ __ ] in his background like even back in
the 90s they were kind of saying early
90s they were kind of thinking he's
probably like got some really bad [ __ ]
going on because he won't talk about
things he's very like i said if you see
interviews with him he's very glib he's
very um
he he deflects everything if you ask him
a question that he doesn't like one
thing that he did on one show and i saw
a clip of this
um i think it was what is your uh or uh
this is your life
they asked him a question they said what
do you think about and this was back in
the 80s or 90s what do you think about
all these rumors about like pedophilia
or whatever they did actually like kind
of ask him about that like in a low-key
way
and he kind of like made like sort of a
flippant or like a jokey kind of comment
and then
he brings a banana out of his pocket and
starts to eat it yeah at which point
ever in the audience laughs like oh
jimmy you're so zany
um and everybody forgot about the
question and he absolutely did that on
purpose look i'm eating good banana
isn't that crazy and now everybody
forgot about the [ __ ] pedophilia
question that they just asked him so
tila jumps in and says talk she's
talking to tammy and she goes man isn't
that something about i actually liked
hannibal lecter from silence the lambs
[ __ ] you know uh anthony hopkins
and i want to say yeah well see
hannibal rising a [ __ ] great movie
all right
um
period piece
you'll see that hannibal actually was a
hero
just not the kind of hero you would
expect
he was batman in a certain way if you're
an [ __ ] he'll eat your ass
and
not your ass
he'll eat your brains well maybe your
ass too your ass is the most delicious
part
right according to cannibals around the
world right he okay some people might
fantasize about being batman
you'll never be batman you'll be closer
to hannibal lecter that's closer to what
batman actually was
hannibal
and if you see hannibal rising you'll
see what i'm talking about he was a
savage warrior outside of the moral
system and outside of the legal system
like a samurai
a head hunter
but see again and they ate his [ __ ]
sister so he's to eat you like i get
that that's right like i know it's a
fictional character yeah yeah but what
i'm saying is that yeah this whole thing
like oh i'm outside of your petty like
right and wrong
um that's essentially one of the exactly
one of the things that jimmy savile said
exactly um and that's how he got away
with the [ __ ] because he thought that he
was outside of everyone else's morality
he could just do whatever he was outside
the morality of england
he was he got away with it
and that's like i said that's what makes
me mad yeah because he got away with it
he got away with it but hannibal was he
died before they've like like i said
there were rumors about it but they
didn't like all the [ __ ] didn't come out
until after he was dead
hannibal's gestalt was very different
you are impolite
so therefore you suck and you are my
food
and
hannibal rising shows how he
how he
made that connection
a great movie
great movie
and it's the origin story kind of like
batman begins
roy says did you ever watch the
documentary with louis theroux and uh
savile yes i did i watched that earlier
today it was very disturbingly
insightful like i said i not only
watched it then i went back and read the
transcript of it i found a transcript of
it online too and i was like he said so
much [ __ ] up [ __ ] in that i think like
louis theroux did that was kind of like
a famous one and i think that
at that time
the uh you know speculations about him
were not as widely known and so i think
that louis theroux after like he went
back and did another one like in 2016
like being uh he made a documentary
essentially about how did i not see that
he was like such a [ __ ] pervert like
the first time that i did a documentary
about him like louis theroux he did this
it wasn't just him he did a show where
he had a whole thing
uh that was called when louis met and he
would go around and interview different
celebrities and he would like spend a
few days with them and like just like
talk to them about their life and stuff
like that it was like a little
documentary show that he did so he did
one about about um
jimmy savville but
nobody well i'm not just saying nobody
knew but like it wasn't like widespread
knowledge like what that [ __ ] was up
to at that time so
but reading it now reading the
transcript of what jimmy's jimmy savile
said on that show
is
[ __ ] up like knowing what we know now
like the the the [ __ ] that he admits
like outright and like i said it's
i read some like quotes and i saw so
like some clever was saying like even
back in the 70s
is like [ __ ] knowing what we know now
is like [ __ ] mind-blowing that he
[ __ ] said that out loud and everybody
was just like whatever
it's like crazy if you said that [ __ ]
like nowadays everybody be like [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you man we're arresting you but
it's like they didn't nobody thought
anything about it they just thought he
was kidding but you know he wasn't
kidding so
sad uh and mike says why did none of the
women come come forward meaning the
women that um he supposedly had all
these relationships with yeah i think
the reason that they didn't come forward
was because they didn't exist
i think
i think jimmy's whole thing
he didn't really like uh the whole thing
about consenting he made a lot of
um he made a lot of statements
pertaining to like um
this is paraphrasing but he said
something like
women gave him quote unquote brain
damage
um
he seemed like he's not a relationship
guy he doesn't really like to
he didn't seem like a big fan of
relating to women as like human beings
he kind of wanted to keep women
uh or girls because he preferred them
under age he kind of seemed to want them
and now i think he even said this
outright and this is another thing he
said something like
um i don't like
he said something like women know too
much
i like girls who don't know that much
like that's more my thing or he said
something almost almost exactly like
that i can't remember the exact wording
but that's pretty much what he said
so
the fact that he said that out loud
the fact that he said that out loud and
was allowed to say that out loud and
nobody like called him out on it
i don't like women who know too much i
like girls who don't really know that
much that's more my thing um that should
have been like instructive right there
he doesn't like
women that are people or equals he wants
a girl
he wants someone to be like a thing that
he can like just like use that seemed
very clear from the way that he was like
uh talking and the way he was
interacting so a lot of things that he
said about women he just saw them as
like things to be
used and that's why he wanted younger
ones but like i said he wasn't picky
he preferred
young teenage girls but if it was boys
if it was older women if it was older
men and they were vulnerable in a
vulnerable situation and they were
available then he would totally take
advantage of that he was an opportunist
he did have proclivities he did seem to
prefer teenage girls but
if something else you know presented
itself then he would take advantage he
just seemed like very opportunistic at
that point because like i said
a lot of the um cases that came up many
of them were teenage girls but some of
them were boys men women they were all
different uh ages and genders and stuff
like that so he was just a very
opportunistic whatever
vulnerable person came along he was
gonna take advantage of that [ __ ]
um but yeah so on this particular show
in 2000 which is what uh we were talking
about before the
the interview that he did with um louis
theroux this was back in 2000
and one of the things that he said on
that show i mean he said a bunch of
upsetting [ __ ] if you do a search on
do a search on jimmy savile louis
theroux 2000
transcript you should be able to find it
because i found it like without too much
trouble there's like a transcript of the
whole show
and um
[Music]
so he interviews them him and he says
one of the things that he says on there
like among the many alarming things was
that yeah when i used to
uh manage a nightclub one of the things
i used to do was like if people were
getting rowdy or something or
were doing something he didn't like he
would beat them up and lock them in the
basement so he said he did that
and so louis
did ask actually ask him what about all
the pedophilia rumors because like i
said this is 2000
uh and
the pedophilia rumors had been swirling
for a long time
and this is what jimmy savile said
we live in a very funny world and it's
easier for me as a single man to say i
don't like children because that puts a
lot of salacious tabloid people off the
hunt
what another thing that he said too on
that same show and i saw this interview
clip they were in a car
and louie was asking him again about
these pedophilia things and he kept
saying
they don't know if i am or if i'm not or
if i am he kept saying almost kind of
like saying yeah i am a pedophile but
it's like i know i'm not but they don't
know if i am he come he kept saying [ __ ]
like that it just seemed very very
sketchy
um but so people did ask him about it
but like i said he would always like
deflect the [ __ ] question
so uh and also he was a big fan of
whenever somebody printed something mean
about him in the papers
he would threaten to sue them he did
that like multiple times so anytime
somebody would like you know threaten to
sue him even if it wasn't about
pedophilia if it was about something
else um some other shady [ __ ] that he
had done anytime anybody said anything
in the least bit like negative about him
he's i'm gonna sue you i'm gonna do this
on the other and he actually did sue a
few people
for making accusations against him so
again that was another um kind of
suppressive tactic to stop victims from
uh talking about what he had done to
them because he's like well i'm i have
money i have power
i can destroy you i can sue you into
bankruptcy and no one will believe you
blah blah so that was how he another way
that he got away with it for a long time
um so this [ __ ] uh ended up
dying
in
late october 2001 actually two days
before his 85th birthday
um not suspicious nobody killed him
unfortunately uh he died of pneumonia
he'd been in the hospital with pneumonia
he'd had like some heart problems prior
to that so
nobody thought that his death was
anything other than he's old as [ __ ] and
he had pneumonia you know what i mean
and as i mentioned earlier
this [ __ ]
it was bad enough
that he was like this giant [ __ ] boil
on the ass of humanity while he was
alive
after he was dead
he wanted a [ __ ] gold coffin of
course
with like gold satin in it
he wants himself buried 45 degrees like
that so he can like look out at the sea
he has this big [ __ ]
if you've seen like the um they tore it
down now but
his gravestone was this ridiculous
three-tiered like or three
paneled
like big huge gravestone it had like an
etching of him on it with like all his
you know this beloved blah blah blah
charity this and top of the pops and
like of this big long paragraph of all
the [ __ ] that he did and it's like it
was like the ridiculous like [ __ ]
tackiest [ __ ] you've ever seen
this massive thing so we wanted that
because of course he did and all these
[ __ ] people show it to his funeral
because nobody knew like it wasn't
widespread like when he died
that um
all the [ __ ] that he did
so
yeah so they have this all these people
show up they have like the last cigar he
smoked it was like there it was like
deified it was like [ __ ] it was
ridiculous like the [ __ ] that that
happened
so
now as i said so
it took a while he died in 2011 like
late october 2011.
and even though
some journalists and stuff like that
were like can we please like print some
[ __ ] about like all of these [ __ ]
allegations can we please start an
investigation can we please do something
into like looking into what this
douchebag did during his life
and even then they were kind of like
well no it's like he just died it's so
tacky blah blah
and it's like that christmas i think the
bbc ran like um
like a
documentary about him but it was very
like laudatory like oh my god he's dead
now it's like a memorial kind of thing
even though a lot of journalists are
like can we please not run that can we
please do something more
realistic uh you know showing like
talking about all the [ __ ] that he did
but for a while it took a long time
because people didn't really want to
believe it i guess because he was such a
beloved
celebrity
so it took until almost a year after he
was dead um for the journalists to kind
of like get together and finally this
one magazine called the oldie
they published this big long expose
about all of these people that had come
forward and all of the police reports
like going way back to the 1950s about
all the times that this [ __ ] had
been like reported and nobody had done
anything about it so
that article sort of like opened the
floodgates like once a couple people
came forward and said hey this
[ __ ] did this to me and that and
the other and once they published
something and said yeah there's a
you know there's um
all of this history that he did this
[ __ ] back in the then the [ __ ]
floodgates open like everybody came and
said oh my god he did this to me and
stuff like that because you have to
think that for a long time a lot of the
victims and a lot of i saw a lot of um
interviews with some of the people that
have been victimized by him they said
well for a long time
i thought it was just me
she's like you know it's like even if
they didn't report it to the police or
even if they did report it to the police
back then like the police didn't really
tell you oh yeah we've had x amount
other complaints about this [ __ ]
they didn't tell you that back then they
do now but they didn't then
so it's like you came there and said hey
this dude like [ __ ] groped me or
raped me or whatever
and it's like if other people did it you
wouldn't know that so you'd kind of like
feel like you were all alone and so i
kind of feel like a lot of the victims
thought they were just kind of like i
don't know yelling into the [ __ ] wind
and no one was listening
so
sometimes like some people wanted to
testify against him but then other
people backed out because they were
scared like he would threaten them and
[ __ ] like that
and so it didn't really happen but once
he was dead
and any threat of him suing people or
you know him getting away with it were
gone and once a couple people came
forward and said yeah he did this that
and the other and they kind of had proof
of it then a bunch of other people came
forward too to the point where it was
just like hundreds and hundreds of
people i mean to the point where
nowadays they think that he's probably
uh britain's most prolific
sexual predator because we're talking
about like i said somewhere between 400
and 500
cases different cases of people that
have reported him for various things
another thing that he said too
is that uh
here's another thing that he said that
should have been a red flag but wasn't
he said that he didn't have a computer
at some point like during an interview i
don't have a computer
because people will think that i'm
downloading child porn
is that really the first thing you think
about right which like i said
well i wasn't thinking that but now i am
i can't have a computer that means i'm
taking child porn i'm like does it yeah
i was just playing solitaire on it i
don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
bro
like i said back in the 90s maybe he i
think he said that back in the 90s when
computers weren't as like obviously
nobody would uh question you for buying
computer nowadays but i think like back
in the 90s when it wasn't as widespread
but still it's like look i was just like
playing [ __ ] mist on the [ __ ] and
like like i said playing solitaire i
don't know why you would think why why
you would immediately jump to that that
seems a little suspicious but the fact
that he would say that uh should have
been a red flag but again was not
uh he also
even as far back as 1974 in his [ __ ]
autobiography
he willingly says some [ __ ] in that book
that he did that would totally be
illegal that was like as far as like
sexual [ __ ] assault goes and he's
like not
nobody said boo about it like i said so
he got away with a lot of [ __ ] and he
was like right out there in the open
with it pretty much
uh so let's talk about uh because you
keep you brought this up a bunch of
times
uh john lyden otherwise known as johnny
broughton yeah uh that's the boy there's
a very famous uh clip of him
from 1978
uh on radio one
and
he said at the time and this is what he
said i'd like to kill jimmy savile i
think he's a hypocrite
i bet he's in all kinds of seediness
that we all know about but are not
allowed to talk about i know some rumors
i bet none of this will be allowed out
uh so the bbc did edit that out
um
but he did actually put the whole
interview like later on one of his uh on
one of the pil albums
but
yeah that's the thing so
he said though i saw a little bit more
of that and i saw like a later interview
that i think he did in like 2013 where
he was like expounding upon that or 2014
and he said he's like it wasn't just me
because i know that you said like oh he
knew about it but it's like he's like
everybody knew like everybody
that
was like going on top of the pops and
stuff like that like everybody knew like
hey stay away from that dude because
he's like really [ __ ] handsy and
he'll like if he gets you alone you'll
be in big trouble based on what i
remember of what lyden said
from the recording
he's making it sound like he
personally talk to somebody who had
contact with savile and that he knows
that's the way he's making this sound
but we know johnny rotten it was the
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] grand standard a lot
even though yeah i mean he's great all
he said was honest man i bet he's blah
blah and he's like i know some rumors
and the thing about it though was that i
don't know what he's talking like i said
well i saw a 2014 interview where they
played him that clip and he was like
expounding on it yeah and he so he said
well everybody knew so it wasn't just
him he's like everybody knew that the
dude was like a creeper
and that you had to stay away from him
so he's like all the kids that were
going on like top of the pops or were
like doing anything it's like everybody
knew like stay away from that dude
because he's a creeper so it wasn't just
johnny rotten the new like everybody
kind of knew what the situation was
um
or you know most people knew so i don't
think it was just him that knew and
because like i said rumors about it
had been going back from like way before
johnny rotten was around
um the first police report was 1955 and
like i said even when he first started
doing the radio show
he was known and like i said this is
again probably like a product of the
time
back in the 1960s
he was known as like
like i said really handsy and really
[ __ ] molesty
but because it was the 1960s he could
play it off as like yeah i'm such a
ladies man you know what i mean oh you
gotta watch out for me blah blah and
everyone just thought it was like funny
you know what i mean they're like no
they absolutely do have to look out for
you because you're a sexual predator but
like back then you could get away with
it because like oh it's so funny i'm so
crazy look at me like um i saw one like
on one documentary they kind of compared
like he was almost like seen as like
pepe le pew you know what i mean where
it's like he would just kind of like
come up and like grab people and [ __ ]
and everyone just thought it was like
funny or like people that you know
weren't being grabbed thought it was
funny they'll say it that way i gotta
pee so you talk okay
jenny's going off to the restroom i'm
going to the restaurant yeah me and tia
we're talking about um
hannibal rising
and uh
i'll go back to that while she's in
there
i actually [ __ ] liked hannibal rising
i thought that was the
the best hannibal lecter movie
um after the first one silence of the
lambs
it was a european flick
it was very much a period piece
they got the costumes of the times right
which was uh mostly like 50s and 60s
and they showed hannibal's
situation of how he was raised and what
happened on the eastern front back in
world war ii
and how'd this cannibalism ship play
into it
and um
what did the russians do to him you know
what i mean
that was part of it he ended up in a
damn russian orphanage in his own house
because his elector castle got taken
over by the russians and turned into an
orphanage they were holding him there
and he ended up escaping and fighting
his way back across the berlin wall to
get the get to the west
and then he ended up in [ __ ] france
at his uncle's house
uh which is a big old big old french
mansion but it turned out that his uncle
had died
but he still moved in there and he moved
in there with his [ __ ]
st
his aunt who had married in who was
a japanese woman
and
she kind of taught him the way is the
samurai but you got to see it and then
his interpretation of it
and it is it's accurate the movie is
very accurate to the culture
and the philosophies of the time the
[ __ ]
the costumes were great the guns were
period correct and uh no i loved it
hannibal rising i thought was a great
sleeper classic
even when they showed the russian tanks
the t-34 tanks they had that [ __ ] period
correct
like on the eastern front with [ __ ]
bicycle
with a bicycle [ __ ]
wire to the side of the turret which
that's what they had
but okay go ahead jenny she's back
yeah tila says next movie i want to see
is the north man yeah i want to see that
too that's the new robert eggers i don't
know that one uh it's the guy that made
the witch and the lighthouse all right
uh tj myron says uh gary glitter is
another human stain yeah this
[ __ ] i think was friends with
and he actually i don't know if they
were friends but he actually defended
gary glitter
in the sense that he defended people
that looked at child porn like oh he's
not hurting anybody i'm like
really you're really gonna die on that
hill you're gonna defend somebody that
looks at childborn yeah we didn't see
the batman yet we've been [ __ ] too
busy and [ __ ] everything's been crazy
like i said it's it's sad because we're
still paying for the we still paying for
is this for the movie subscription i
don't know it's probably
i still want to see x like i should see
now did the north man start because i
kind of want to see that too we gotta
see the batman because like i said we're
still paying for the [ __ ] i know
amc thing but it's like the movie
theater is like farther away now
so it's like now if we want to go it's
like a whole day ordeal you know what i
mean whereas before i mean it was kind
of like a half day ordeal before but now
it's like a whole day ordeal we got to
get up we got to get rid it's like i
could put gas in the car it's like a
whole like
[ __ ] 40 minutes there 40 minutes back
like plus the time of the movie and it's
like so it takes up the whole day
so we have to like plan the whole like
[ __ ] week around it so it's that kind
of thing which just kind of sucks and
like i said that's
i looked to see if there was a closer
movie theater there's not
the same theater that was
close to our old house is the closest
one to this house there's not a closer
theater than that but yeah so uh yeah
where was i
so as i mentioned before one of the
things that [ __ ] blew my mind about
this case and pissed me off about it so
much and you can tell i'm like really
[ __ ] pissed off about this whole
situation this i've been watching
documentaries about this [ __ ]
like all day today and it's like really
it's it's you know
it's it's made me be away so
the dude came right out and like said
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] like on tv
but nobody really
even though everybody kind of was like
low-key like knew yeah maybe he's up to
some sketchy [ __ ] but
nobody really called him out like
everyone just thought oh he's so crazy
or it's always being funny or something
like that and it's just like it's really
disturbing i don't know it was really
disturbing to me like some of the [ __ ]
that he said
um
so he was kind of like i said and i
think that he absolutely cultivated this
persona because i don't think he
actually was a person in the sense that
he had like an inner
life of any sort like the way a regular
person would i think he was all facade
and it was all very meticulously
constructed to make himself look a
particular way
and i think that because deep down he
knew that what he was doing was [ __ ]
up and it wouldn't necessarily be
acceptable but he also knew on the flip
side of that that he was rich and famous
and had a bunch of like you know uh
powerful connections that he could be
able to do whatever he wanted i think he
kind of got off
on
saying some [ __ ] outright on tv that
kind of sounded like he was admitting to
some [ __ ] but he's like well no one's
gonna do anything about it so [ __ ] it
and i think that he kind of like got a
heart on like doing that kind of crap
because he said stuff like
so somebody asked him on this one
interview show and i saw this clip
uh somebody said oh you used to do some
wrestling because he did actually do uh
he was a wrestler like in his youth
and he's like oh i still do and everyone
kind of laughs and then he's like oh
yeah what are you talking about and then
he says
quote
i'm feared in every girls school in this
country
implying that he's wrestling with the
girls of the girl you know what that
means i'm feared at every girls school
in this country he said and he said that
like on an interview show like back in
the [ __ ] 70s or 80s and everyone just
thought it was like funny
now
that we know what he was doing not funny
but everyone just thought it was like
[ __ ] funny back then also this one
horrifying clip that i saw
where he was talking about this like
little girl she probably looked like
maybe 10 or 11.
and he says something about oh how she
was like so little and blonde and he
called her quote unquote
kidnappable
that's the word that he used he said she
was
kidnappable and everyone just thought
that was funny
dude that's not funny that's not funny
and it's like it's just the fact that he
said that it's like everyone just
thought he was hilarious
and so
another thing that he would do and he
did this on a lot of interviews that i
saw clips of
was that
he would make
if somebody was like calling him out or
like um you know saying some stuff about
hey we heard you did this on the other
he would like make veiled threats at
them or sometimes not so veiled but he
would make veiled threats and he would
make threats like
he always he was very big about it's
like i'm not a grass meaning i don't
like rat on people that's like the
british slang that's british criminal
slang for i don't like
you know uh report on people
i don't roll over on people i don't
grasp
so he was very big on using that word he
used it a lot i don't grass i don't
grasp and the way that he used it was
implying that neither should you like
because i know some [ __ ] about you and
the way he said it was like really
really threatening
um
you know implying that like whoever was
out there like accusing him something
uh you know you better not tell or you
know i'm gonna do something bad to you
you know what i mean um because he
absolutely could he could actually he
had enough connections he had enough
money he had enough power that if he
wanted to like he sued people for you
know making
accusations again they did that uh
particular police that were kind of
investigating him
allegedly he had them demoted or fired
uh so he could do that just by like
pulling some strings uh he could do that
as well because he was very well liked
for whatever reason because he seemed
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] but you know some
people like that i guess
um there was another thing and this was
from the uh the louis theroux thing that
we were talking about earlier
there was one point in that interview
where he pushes a like a pad of paper
like toward louis theory that has
louie's
address written on it like his home
address
and louis says why would you show me
that
like why would you show me a piece of
paper with my address on it
and
jimmy says
because i never knew whether you existed
or not you see and somebody gave me the
address and i thought well if he doesn't
exist shall i send round some of my lads
with strong sicilian accents to speak
with him
so he's like threatening people like on
tv but like i said in a way that seems
like he's joking
and then louie says how'd you get the
address and he says i'll get anything me
he says
and
later on they're having this
conversation so he's saying like i can
get any information i want so if you say
something that makes me mad
then there will be repercussions that's
basically what he's saying but he's
saying it in a way that makes it seem
like a joke
and it's very very obvious now that you
know what you know about him when you go
back and watch these interviews that
that's what he's doing
another thing that he did during this
same interview he says it's a lot easier
to make negative tv shows than it is to
make positive ones he says and then he
like says some other kind of [ __ ] then
louie said well that you know the shows
can't be all positive because that
wouldn't be like realistic so he says
and then jimmy says make it as
negative as you like that's all right
see you in court that's what he said so
like everything was like
deflection and like threat but veiled
threat
and he absolutely knew what he could get
away with
there was also this exchange which i
thought was interesting i copied this
from the transcript
louis says why have you said in
interviews that you don't have
emotions jimmy says because it's easier
it's easier you say you've emotions then
you've got to explain them for two hours
and there's a big pause then jimmy says
the truth is i'm very good at masking
them that's what he says
and he said that like on a [ __ ]
nationwide [ __ ] interview
uh he also said some [ __ ] like and i saw
this one too there was an interview they
did like um this is your life
and there was this whole thing about the
secretary that used to work for him and
the interviewer says oh i heard the
secretary was a little bit scared of you
you know implying that maybe he had done
something to her which you probably did
and jimmy says i should hope she's a lot
scared
damn
he said [ __ ] like that like on national
[ __ ] tv
so he was obviously not like afraid
that anything would happen to him like i
said he said he said stuff like i lie
when it suits me i saw him say that
um and i'm not in your world i'm not
constrained by anything he would say
things like that i'm like what a [ __ ]
douche
like saying [ __ ] like that i'm just like
oh i can get away with anything
he was right though but that's what i
mean i think that's what pisses me off
about the most about this is because he
was so [ __ ] smug about it he knew
that he would get away with it now he
wouldn't have got away with it if
somebody somewhere that knew what this
[ __ ] was doing and a lot of
people did had [ __ ] actually like
dropped their nuts and said absolutely
not i'm gonna like [ __ ] turn your
stupid ass in
um
i don't know how that would have gone
but it would have been nice if somebody
and i'm not saying that people didn't
report him because they did it's just
that people reported him as far back as
1955 but nobody did jack [ __ ]
um and even in 1955 when he wasn't
really all that famous you know i guess
he they didn't really have proof or
anything like that which okay fine but
once he actually got famous and
people actually did start reporting it
somebody absolutely should have done
something about it and nobody really did
so i think that that's kind of like the
other story behind this is that not only
was this [ __ ] just allowed to
like run
[ __ ] a rampage and just molest
everybody in [ __ ] sight um
but a lot of people kind of knew what
was going on and just kind of were like
ah not my problem
you know what i mean i don't really
think it was
like i said i don't really think it was
necessarily that there was this big
cabal of like pedophiles or anything
like that i just think it was people
that were like well it's not my problem
i think i'm not involved i'm just going
to pretend this is my job and i don't
want to lose my job and i don't want to
get sued and blah blah and it's just
like easier
to not worry about it because it's
because it's not you you're not the one
getting molested you're not the one on
the
end of it so you don't have to worry
about it you can just be like well
you know if i say something i might get
fired or he might sue me or
you know it might come out like my [ __ ]
might come out or something like that so
i kind of feel like it was more a case
of that then it was like a sort of
conspiracy of like everybody trying to
protect him i don't necessarily think it
was that i just think it was a case of
people just trying to cover their own
asses
and i think that's most of the world and
well yeah but that's what i'm saying so
so it's like much more likely because
like i said that's why i'm not a big i'm
not saying there's not conspiracies i'm
just saying that's why i'm a big
advocate of like not so much these big
complicated conspiracy theories you
don't need deposit that most people
you know in this kind of situation
i mean think about it if you worked with
a dude like this yeah
and you knew that if you reported what
he was doing
your career might be put on the line or
he or he might put you in his sights you
might get sued you or something bad
might happen to you
most people would probably think twice
be like maybe i shouldn't maybe i should
just shut up and like keep my ass to
myself it's nothing to do with me it's
not happening to me so i kind of feel
like that's and i'm not saying that's
good i'm just saying that that's what
most people are not a huge [ __ ] crowd
for did we really show yeah 52. well
like i said that's kind of this show
that's a lot that's a lot further it
might be because jimmy savile is like i
said they
it's kind of like a big case and they
just did the netflix show about it which
like i said
i didn't even know
until a couple days ago that there was a
netflix show um
we just like somebody like i think it
was dj maniac right like recommended it
i was like oh yeah we should do that i
remember that and we decided i put in
the poll like a week or two ago and we
decided to do it and then i was like oh
yeah there's a netflix thing so i kind
of feel like that's maybe why i'm
getting a drink okay but yeah so
but that's what i'm saying so i'm not
saying that conspiracies don't exist i'm
just saying that
in a lot of cases like this one i don't
think you need to posit that there's
like some big pedophile ring or anything
and i'm not saying there's not that i'm
just saying you don't need to posit that
i'm just saying that it's enough
that most people were just trying to
mind their own business or trying to
like not get you know put in the sights
themselves
uh they knew that he had a lot of money
they knew that he had a lot of power
they knew that
he was very capable of getting you to
lose your job or suing you or you know
ruining your career or whatever
if you said something about him
so i kind of feel like most people
wouldn't
want to go through the hassle because
like i said it wasn't them that was
being molested it wasn't them it wasn't
their kid
um so they didn't really have a dog in
that fight so a lot of times people
probably just like
they just probably thought it wasn't
their problem i kind of feel like there
was a massive case of not my problem
happening in this situation which is how
he got away with it for so long i mean
the fact that he was famous and nobody
really wanted to believe but like i said
i think that's kind of why bill cosby
got away with the [ __ ] that he got away
with for so long because oh he's famous
and he's rich and he seems like such a
nice man
um although jimmy savile didn't seem
like a nice man but bill cosby did at
first
but you don't want to believe it you
don't want to believe
that this person that is this beloved
celebrity
everybody knows them it's like oh they
raise all this money for charity and
they do this and that the other thing
you don't believe that that person is
like secretly a [ __ ] you really don't
want to believe that because that like
upends your whole
conception of the world i guess
but
you know and i get it like if i found
out that somebody that i really looked
up to
like some i don't really look up to any
celebrities necessarily but if i did if
you like uh
because a lot of them suck
even if i like their entertainment like
i don't really like them as people
necessarily but um don't ever put your
heroes on pedestals i'm just saying
because they're just human like the rest
of us and they have horrible flaws
um even if they create beautiful things
i mean they might be horrible people
it happens people are complicated but um
yeah just don't dfi humans so uh so yeah
but i could see how if
you this was like a person you'd grown
up with particularly i kind of feel like
i feel more empathy toward people that
grew up with this dude like with jim
will fix it and or on top of the pops or
whatever because it's a dude you saw on
tv like all the time and he seemed like
a nice man and blah blah
and
then it turned out that he was a monster
and that would be like really hard for
you to deal with and i get that i get
that but
like i said you gotta understand like
people kind of suck and they're they
don't suck they're just complicated um
everybody has
dark secrets everybody has
you know bad [ __ ] that's going on nobody
is like a [ __ ] angel so
there's that but yeah so
i hope she's a lot scared said about
that [ __ ] woman jesus christ
now listen to this so this is i saw this
really interesting documentary which was
kind of focused on i mean it kind of
gave an overview of the case but it kind
of focused on
um
psychologist psychiatrists and stuff
like that that had
um
watched a lot of his interviews listen
to a lot of his interviews or trying to
like analyze his
psychiatric
whatever the [ __ ] was wrong with him
like from his interviews thank you
strawdog78 thank you thank you thank you
nicholas says he wore red sunglasses as
if he was literally bloodthirsty or they
might have been rose-colored glasses i
kind of thought that when i was like
looking at him
yeah and they were talking about the
glass eye that he stole off a corpse
yeah i heard about that
yeah yep yep
but yeah
so one of the things that this was a
really interesting quote because i
wanted to quote this at length because i
found this really interesting i saw this
documentary now the woman that
uh or the person that directed the
netflix documentary which is jimmy
savile of british horror story
rowan deacon uh went through a lot of
interviews of this
douche 700 hours of the [ __ ]
which
that deserves some kind of medal in
itself because i couldn't talk sin is
ten i know it's like okay because i
could not really watch like more than a
few minutes of this dude he just like
made me want to like [ __ ] kick him
right in the tank
within like a minute of meeting him
um
but they said and a lot of psychiatrists
that i saw that were talking about him
as well said that what his whole thing
was as i mentioned earlier was like
quote unquote hiding in plain sight
whereas he would come out and say things
that sounded like he was admitting
good that sounded like he was admitting
to
uh the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that he was doing
but he was he was doing it in such a way
that was like isn't it silly that you
believe that i'm just making a joke
about it so it can't possibly be true so
he he really actually knew what he was
doing
uh so the director of the netflix show
said i think in the 1960s and 1970s
what's most shocking is that his what we
now describe as lascivious creepy
assaulting behavior on women which you
know very well documented
which is happening in front of the
camera on broadcast footage
which like i said i saw some of that on
youtube which he totally does just like
grab and everyone's just kind of like oh
whatevs it's
it's amazing
uh what's shocking about that is not
that he's doing it because we now know
what we know it's that nobody blinks an
eye it's completely normal
so i think the social conditions at the
time normalized that kind of behavior
yeah that i think that's why he got away
with it for so long
i don't mean uh the thing that we found
out he was also doing but sort of public
lasciviousness and creepiness that was
not judged as anything problematic and
like i said he even like admitted it
back then himself like oh i'm sorry you
gotta watch your you know watch the
ladies around me because my hands they
can't like he was like making a joke
about it yeah and but everybody like all
the women were like yeah that's not
funny because he actually is like really
a creeper and stuff but but he was just
like making a joke and everybody else
was just like oh oh you so it was that
so he got away with that for a long time
because of that kind of like cultural
attitude i guess but by the time like
the 90s rolled around and that wasn't
really that acceptable anymore he
started going because then everybody
started seeing him as like you know
creepy old dude
so he started
going more brazen with the stuff that he
was saying like on tv almost like he was
like i said like he was trying to
deflect it's so ridiculous that you
would think that i would do that look
i'm gonna say this that and the other
thing if would i say that out loud if i
was actually doing all this sketchy [ __ ]
that you say of course i wouldn't you
know i mean that's outrageous i'm just
making a joke so he very deliberately
changed his tactic
once it wasn't as acceptable anymore for
him to act that way and once he was
getting to a point where he was so old
that he couldn't really get away with it
too like to the extent that he had
probably in the past
um
so yeah uh yeah she says he's the one
saying the creepy things and suggesting
that he's up to no good and i think he
does a kind of double bluff with the
audience so it's quite confusing and
people end up thinking well he's sort of
saying it so it can't be true and if you
go back and look at some of the
interviews that he did later on like
post 90s
you can see what she's talking about um
yeah he's basically like coming out and
basically all but admitting that he does
that kind of crap but it's like would i
say it you know if i if i was actually
doing it of course not it's that kind of
thing and the super chats people just
wanted to say that yeah okay come here
oh
she's crying
what are you crying about poke oh
we're gonna get up here on the [ __ ]
she's like i don't want to be on the
show i don't want him you want to be on
a show no
she does not want to be on the show look
she's like i know nothing okay
[Laughter]
she's down there playing she's like what
she's like i was playing in here
interrupted now she's back to playing
[Laughter]
i was trying to get you to do something
funny on the show
right yeah um she's very lovable she's
very affectionate yeah she hangs out
with you all the time but you cannot
make her do something she does not want
to do yeah she doesn't really like she
doesn't like to be picked up and like
she's like put me down [ __ ]
i mean she'll do crazy [ __ ] on her own
but she doesn't like to be like
she's like i'm not a performing monkey
what do i look like
yeah she's very independent
very independent
um but yeah
so
i don't know i kind of so in march 2008
like i said so this goes almost up until
the time the [ __ ] died right
uh march 2008
he sued a newspaper
that
implied
that he had something to do with like
some abuse at like a children's home
uh on on uh jersey
so he sued them so that like shut them
up so that was kind of another thing
it's much like scientology that's kind
of like with it every time you criticize
them it's like they have all this money
so just like well they just sue you and
that like shuts you up and like i said i
think it doesn't help that as far as i'm
aware i don't know if this is still the
case but um the uk has like much more
stringent libel laws in the u.s
libel laws are kind of
a wavy
um if you're doing like a joke or a
parody or something like that and you
can make the argument that you didn't
expect anyone to take it seriously about
the person
then
you're all right you're on solid legal
round um it's totally fine you can do
like [ __ ] crazy cartoons about people
as long as it's nothing that
can be construed as you actually like
making people believe that they did that
um
if you're kind of making it seem like
realistic then you're on like more
questionable legal ground as far as
libel is concerned
but
in the uk it's much harder to make like
any kind of like accusations that you
don't have proof for like you can't just
say any like pull anything out your butt
and then just say oh well i never
expected anyone to take me seriously
like in the u.s you still have that
loophole uk not so much um so you really
got to kind of watch your p's and q's
over there because you can't just say
anything about anything anybody or
you're going to get your ass sued which
like i said you can over here too but
it's a lot harder like uh bar to clear
is what i'm saying
so uh he sued them so that kind of like
uh they either settled or whatever
uh now 2009 i will say jimmy savile did
get brought in by the cops he didn't get
arrested or nothing like that but they
did interview him
um
having to do with uh an alleged assault
that he might have done at like i said
the mention or the duncroft manor the
girls school um
so they did question him about that this
was as far as i know the only time like
he had been brought in like a couple
times but this was kind of like a big
deal they brought him in
um but at the time they determined that
they did not have enough solid evidence
to pursue the case
so they decided that they would let him
go so 2009 that was like the last
official report that they ruled now that
same year though
um another woman who was actually 43
years old she reported to the police
that jimmy savile had sexually assaulted
her on a train journey like on the train
between leeds in london so that was
another one they took in i don't know if
they questioned him about that
but that was another report that they
took in that uh same year now as i
mentioned earlier
uh in a 2009 interview so right up until
in 2009 he was 82 83 damn he's an old
fart he's an old man this [ __ ]
should have been dead at 82.
he should have been dead yeah at birth
most people don't live to 82. he should
have been dead see evil never dies it's
true
it's true that's why like the worst
[ __ ] yeah they just keep living
and living they just won't [ __ ] die
some of my aunts
evil as [ __ ] i mean i can think of lots
of people that i'm just kind of like why
won't you [ __ ] die just died it's
like they're the worst and then like i
think of like all these like lovely
people that died like way too young
yeah we're [ __ ] our [ __ ] little
[ __ ] girlfriends and [ __ ] that have
[ __ ] died over time [ __ ]
god damn amber died we didn't tell you
guys about amber that's right we forgot
about that amber was another one that
died yeah
this
she died
she died a couple weeks ago yeah died a
couple weeks ago cancer pretty little
guy
should i pull up a picture of amber
i'll pull a picture of amber yeah so you
guys i'm gonna put a face to it so you
guys know what we're talking about she
got a cancer too she was also not though
every time i'd see her she was just
skinnier and skinnier and i was looking
like amber
and
man i felt really [ __ ] bad
there wasn't much i could say
i mean i knew she was dying she kept
coming out for a long time though yeah i
mean
she did keep coming out for a long time
yeah
but we knew i mean she was fighting
cancer a long time years and years and
um yeah
she finally he came in the other day and
said yeah
and i was like
yeah that's there's amber
trying to get that [ __ ] to [ __ ]
is it gonna
oh man
tila said jen didn't the other friend
pass from the seaward two yep
and same eight i mean similar age amber
well kaylee was 34 yeah when she died
and amber how old was amber uh young
she was only in her thirties thirties
and she loved [ __ ] fallout
me and amber would talk about fallout
when we were over at um
at the castle
and she came to memento a lot yeah most
of the time too
just um
wonderful little woman
dying
well it's creepy how many people that we
know have died
yeah and you know what's weird i was
like i was on facebook the other day
like posting some [ __ ] about the show
and amani our friend of bonnie yeah
she came on and she said oh i was
cleaning out my facebook um you know
friends and she's like and i was alarmed
that how many people in my facebook
friends have died in the last couple
years and i was like right
yeah and it's like forever i know but
it's like a lot of them but the thing
about it is like they're not yeah it's
not like it's not like we're [ __ ] 70.
no and it wouldn't be a surprise it's
like i'm not even 50 yet and like we we
know people that are a generation
younger than us that are dying young
women dying from
cancers that started down low
something to do with intestines or
ovaries or
uterine stuff and it's just it's killing
them it's [ __ ] like what well kaylee
i think that was stomach stomach that
was stomach cancer yeah what does that
actually my grandma died today yeah and
i just can't believe that kaylee's dead
katie was a baby
and that [ __ ] little swolled up so bad
man [ __ ] and then his mom died well
she well yeah
that yeah that didn't help yeah i told
you because yeah he had his mom die and
then kaylee died who he loved more than
anything else on earth yeah yeah he
walked to the [ __ ] gates of the to
the pearly gates of heaven he was
calling her every [ __ ] day
and then
he couldn't get a hold of her one day
and then the second day he couldn't get
over the third day he found out she was
dead
yeah cause she moved away and he talked
about but do you remember that we used
to [ __ ] we used to pick kaylee up
yeah every friday night yeah and go to
visage
and get a venue and go to venue 13. pass
her around dude she was cute she was a
kid for years and years we picked her up
at her house every friday night i took
her to menu 13.
and then and then
i mean like i said
she moved away so we didn't um
yeah you know she got married like her
wife laura was um kind of i think they
got divorced actually but then laura
kind of came back to take care of her
but um she moved away so we didn't like
see her as much like once she got cancer
we didn't like we didn't know she had
cancer until after she had moved away
amber
um we knew she had cancer because she
kept coming back to the club and it's
like
um we have another friend who is our age
who has
uh had breast cancer
and her and amber were like this is
[ __ ] up but they were like cancer
buddies so they they would get a like
treatment together they would go to get
um you know the the treatment together
and
uh you know the friend that has breast
cancer that's our age she's still around
but um
amber we weren't really sure
that was killing kaley yeah and you just
can't believe that such a young
woman died
of cancer it's [ __ ] it was
heartbreaking well like i said it's it
happens like [ __ ] when i was a kid my
[ __ ]
yeah
30 odd my 32 year old uncle died of
brain cancer for dad's sake
you just sometimes you just get unlucky
life doesn't care about you
you know it's [ __ ] terrible which is
awful
terrible but i can't believe kaylee's
gone
i know it's weird i kind of think like
think about it like i said we used to
hang out with her like all the time yeah
she was at our house she was like she
used to come to our you know we used to
go out with her like every [ __ ]
weekend every weekend she we used to go
out with her
like [ __ ] crazy and like i said we
used to see amber every [ __ ] yeah
god it's like it's [ __ ] weird i mean
i knew that was coming because she'd
been like struggling with cancer for a
long time like for years
so we knew that was gonna happen like
inevitably all these [ __ ] dying
[ __ ] man the [ __ ] up stop fighting
stop dying
[ __ ] don't victim blame tom [ __ ]
hopefully i don't get cancer because
he'll just be like man up don't die well
no
i'm i'm um
i
i'm abhorred you know i mean it's
abhorrent you know i'm [ __ ] horrified
cancer doesn't care yeah who you are or
how old you are
or anything
i know that's terrifying for people but
the universe does not care about you no
no you know
it's not it's not hostile it's just
indifferent it's just a different god is
an indifferent thing nothing different
it's which yeah i think a lot of people
have a problem with that right i mean i
have a problem with that but i've
accepted it
i don't like it i just accepted it yeah
because that's the way it is that's the
way it is it's just a different
uh but yeah so what do we say yeah
we were talking about gary glitter
earlier we should do a show about that
[ __ ] too yeah
it'll be probably like similar to this
one but right
um
so 2009 like i said two years before
this [ __ ] died and he's in his
80s because he died when he's 85. can
you believe like i said most like you
were saying most dudes don't even live
till they're 85. this [ __ ] look
at pokey what's she doing look at her
oh
she woke up oh i was talking you messed
it up you know i messed it up what was
she doing
sleeping inside the [ __ ] toys you
were sleeping with your head leaned up
against the [ __ ] mice i saw it i saw
it oh you were being cute it's okay
she's always being cute she's like yeah
and
i can't help but be cute
man i'm just uh
i might have to go through and watch the
expendables [ __ ] series again
because to cheer you up man myself back
up
mango says i count myself lucky i beat
cancer and it's a [ __ ] oh yeah
it is it killed my grandma killed my
uncle most of the people in my family
died of it you eventually die of it
everyone will eventually die of it if
you live long enough um i that's one of
the things that i remember from one of
my genetics classes
that you know if humans live long enough
they will all die of cancer because you
will get like replicating errors and
your genes yeah that can't be overridden
because
i don't know if you know but people have
like a natural
if some [ __ ] up [ __ ] like replicates
it's like oh let's get rid of that and
they kill that cell you have that
but
if it replicates enough times or if you
have some kind of like a disorder that
subverts that process
then but you do have a fail safe i mean
your body is kind of like aware of that
but it can be overridden you're right so
if you live long enough and you get like
enough gene copies and there's enough
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in there then yeah
eventually everyone will get cancer
but
you know it's not like karen lee says i
have a two-year-old baby in the family
with the with the big c and i never
understand how it could happen i don't
understand how it happened yeah that's
what i mean because little kids die of
it i don't understand it like childhood
leukemia that's the whole reason
yeah of some good and like i said it's
not
i know it's very well
the thing about it like
humans evolve to want agency for things
so it's like you want something to blame
you know you get like you have a baby
and it has cancer it's like well god did
that why did god do this it's like
nobody did it it just happened i know
that's like really hard to
you know it sucks i don't like that
either but that's just the way it is
nobody did it
it's just
it just happens it's a mistake
you know it's not
it's not hostile it's it's just
indifferent
which maybe to some people is worse yeah
but like i said i don't like it but
that's just the way it is
just the way it is
i know wow this went dark didn't it yeah
well i mean we were already talking
about a [ __ ] pedophile so it was
already pretty dark so you know what i
mean it's all common to us i'm just
gonna [ __ ] hang out with burt
reynolds me and bert me and bert are
going to watch this yeah and his
mustache that's [ __ ] and he's dead
already i'm going to i'll be joining
bert
burt reynolds do you know what you
should do the southern action the
southern access star of all actions
taylor says somebody solo joke yeah
right yeah do you know what you see me
and burt reynolds bro
you should you should dress up like burt
reynolds for halloween but i mean a
specific wait what did burt reynolds
wear in cannonball run
oh he had some [ __ ] on with the
mustang was it a zippy
no that was the that was the hot girl
i'll have them look to see what happens
i don't remember what he was wearing i
don't think it was anything of anything
nothing of if he wasn't like sammy davis
jr that had like the priest out there no
he had a seven day yes
he was the cavs cannonball run two
oh that's right i get that well i saw
them both we haven't seen two yet
i've seen it but i thought a long time
ago i mixed them up though because i saw
them like both of them like at the same
time cannonball run two he's got sammy
davis junior and dom de louise as
priests in the [ __ ] no it's not dom
deluise i think it's um uh
[ __ ] uh
no it's [ __ ] uh [ __ ] what's his name
i don't know the drunk uh i thought it
was dom deluise no it's d uh dean
d martin need martin d martin okay okay
it's dana martin
that's right dom deluise was captain
chaos yeah that's right that's right i
mean dom deluxe was in it he just wasn't
a priest it was dean martin it was dean
martin and sammy davis we got to see
cannonball run too a southern classic
that was that was white exploitation
by white people for white people
in the south that whites that was
legitimate white exploitation i'm gonna
make you a shirt that says buy white
people for a while for white people
that's that that could be taken really
wrong pretty much
pretty much anything with
[ __ ] uh
with burt reynolds in it was a studio
that was doing that
yeah but that's not a bad thing you know
that was the same thing that was that
was the same thing that was was going on
with
with [ __ ] black exploitation flicks
with like [ __ ] dolomite
you know
rudy ray moore was it was black product
you know it was black people making
product for black people
watch the show
the devil's son-in-law yeah yeah it's on
tv for free
it's super fun
it's terrible but it's fun but it's not
a genius and and base based on that
that's where the eddie murphy films came
from yeah but eddie murphy understood
that there was a that that there was a
huge white market for blaxploitation
because
black people are creative they're funny
[ __ ] they have a lot of charisma you
know especially guys like i watch all
that [ __ ] i don't care what color you
are yeah yes
especially eddie murphy is it fun is it
entertaining yeah okay especially eddie
murphy and [ __ ] me and my friends
grew up watching [ __ ] beverly hills
cop one two and three and
golden child and and eddie murphy was a
hero of ours you know and and it went
across race you know
that that wasn't the issue it was
[ __ ] it was eddie
i go back and look at the material now
and it's kind of pedestrian it was very
simple by today's standards but they
didn't have social media back then
you were confined to
film and vhs tape
and that was the well and things were a
lot more i mean everybody kind of saw
the same things well not everybody saw
the same thing there was like a
mainstream that saw
these things yeah and then there was
like an underground that saw
these things but it was film and vhs
yeah yeah
yeah and but by today's standards that's
nothing compared to what social media
can provide
that's why that is kind of going away
and it better get back
to the underground feel
or it won't survive it
it has to be we still have that it's
just not as
i know it's a weird thing to say but
it's not as universal because i kind of
feel like back in the old days yeah you
had
you know just talking about movies or
music or whatever you had a mainstream
thing you had like top 40 charts you had
like temple movies ten poll movies blah
blah blah but then you had
underground music you had like
underground movies you had like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like like john waters and stuff
like that yeah yeah and everybody that
was into like [ __ ] that wasn't that yeah
had seen this [ __ ] they didn't all love
it like sometimes she had like sub
genres but most people were versed in
all of that stuff but the thing about it
i don't know i kind of feel like
nowadays it's kind of like a blessing
and a curse because everybody can make
their own [ __ ] which is awesome
but it also like
diffuses everything so it's kind of like
now you can sort of
i like this very very specific thing and
now i can just like watch nothing but
that specific thing
and you don't really so there's not
really this kind of thing where like
back in the old days if you were like a
weirdo like a goth or a punk or whatever
and you liked like alex cox movies or
something you could find your people
and they didn't like necessarily love
the same [ __ ] as you but they loved like
other like
you know stuff that wasn't mainstream so
you could find some common ground with
them now it's kind of like everybody is
so in their own niche because you can
find your own niche there are so many
niches
that
there's no crossover like back in the
old days
there was just basically two things you
have like mainstream culture and you had
underground culture which encompassed
everything else yeah and that
encompassed a lot of different things so
it's like i hung out with people that
were you know i was a goth i was into
like you know a specific kind of like
weird ass movie but i was also friends
with like you know skinheads or i was
not nazi skinheads but like
other kind of like just punk skinheads
and you were friends with like people
that liked all different kind of mute
like sky you were like scott because
that was a mainstream
and so there was that and like people
that like particular kind of underground
movies that maybe weren't you know i
like david lynch and stuff maybe like
some other kind of [ __ ] but
you
like [ __ ] that wasn't mainstream so you
had that in common so you all hung out i
don't i feel like that doesn't happen
nowadays connor barcelona just jumped in
says no man we're talking about
the girls that we knew that have died of
cancer recently and just like how that
kind of like is like damn
and they were young
young and pretty i showed pictures you
can go back and look at look at it later
and we're just like [ __ ] man which is
kind of freaky because
i don't know i don't i don't think a
great deal i mean i'm i'll be 50 in
september
and it's kind of like i don't really
think a great deal about my own
mortality sometimes it's weird because
sometimes i think
man
conceivably i don't know if i will but
it's like conceivably i could live
another 30 40 years i'm like jesus
christ that just makes me tired thinking
about it we may not though but then i'm
kind of like i may not i don't i don't
know i don't really care either way it
comes when it comes i don't really care
there's nothing we can do about it it
comes when it comes is it bad that like
i think oh i could live another 30 40
years i'm like god that would just wears
me out thinking about it yeah that means
i'm old comes when it comes
but it's sad when a young and pretty
what that's what i mean they weren't
even as bold as i know they were young
young and pretty they were young enough
to be our kids yeah pretty much and and
it came and it got them and it took them
yeah
and for all we know there's a simple
cure for it that we don't know about
i don't know man maybe one of these days
we'll find out but you would think that
if it was simple they would have found
it by now
some people have said that no that the
cure is out there
some people have said that i'm sure
there is i'm just well there's cheap
cures but they've suppressed them well
the thing about it so i've heard that
certain kinds of cancer
can be suppressed early on if you catch
it
by what they call that damn i don't want
to say the word because they might
[ __ ] block us but the the horse
dewormer
that i have that i've used
that if you catch it early on that it
catches parasites and it also attacks
um cancer cells that are going [ __ ]
chronic well the thing about it though
is that when you gotta get it early well
when you say a cure for cancer it's like
what kind of cancer are you talking
about yeah
well the thing about it that it's a lot
more
complicated than it seems it's not
there's one one kind of disease it's not
one disease it's a bunch of them um it's
a bunch of different ones that's one of
the reasons why it's difficult to kind
of get a handle on but
i got some of that downstairs i'm gonna
[ __ ] take it
don't give it to me i'm not doing that
[ __ ]
they say well it doesn't hurt you if
there's nothing wrong with you but you
know it doesn't hurt you
uh but it kills parasites and possibly
cancer early on we'll see
i don't believe it sorry
but yeah i mean it doesn't surprise me
if that's what it was because i've seen
some [ __ ] now because corporations will
tell you one thing they're very simple
very different from what reality is
we don't know the science because they
don't tell us the science
they'll suppress the science if it costs
them money all this science or science
whatever they call it
money's involved in that that [ __ ]
cloud's everything let me go to the
restroom
tila says you need to put on a wig and
take off your shirt oh wait wait hold on
t well because we need to keep trying to
get teachers well no because we need
laughs because we've been talking about
like
dark
topics
everyone's trying to like have some fun
damn [ __ ] boys show going i go to the
restroom too i don't have any time for
that
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
so where was i
i mean we're almost done seriously
so
yeah 2009 i think i
alluded to this earlier
and this should have been again a red
flag by this point he was almost dead so
people should have been like not worried
about like upsetting him or whatever
but
he doesn't interview
jimmy savile in 2009
defending
people that watch
child porn
which
again is that really the hill that you
want to die on i know that you think
you're being
do you think you're being cute or
subversive or whatever the [ __ ] you
think um to everyone else to all the
normal people in the world uh you know
just as a pro tip that is a huge red
flag
so he's defending
viewers of child pornography uh
specifically gary glitter which like i
said we should probably do a show about
gary glitter as well
um because that was another whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] show
so his quote about that was that people
that view child pornography
quote didn't do anything wrong
but they are then demonized yeah i
wonder why that could be
somehow he doesn't see anything wrong
with that which like i said
that's a little that's pretty sketchy
um
and he said that gary
had been unfairly vilified
for watching
dodgy films
and
gary's not tried to sell him not tried
to show them to the public or anything
like that
if it was for his own gratification it
was for his own gratification
whether it was right or wrong of course
is up to him as a person
what he is failing to
address
in his uh
little
diatribe there
is that
actual children
did have to suffer in the making of that
child porn
and that maybe
uh if there was not a demand for it then
it would not be made
so
he seems to be like conveniently
forgetting about that
part of the equation
and
it seems like he's very very willing to
say hey we're just like watching some
job we didn't actually well he did
actually but
we didn't actually like he's just
watching a movie
knock it
off um which if you were just talking
about like a fake ass horror movie okay
yeah that would be a valid
complaint but
the fact that you're watching like real
child porn that exploited real life
children
that's a whole different can of worms
isn't it
um but he doesn't really seem to see
that distinction i don't know he kind of
seems to be framing it like it's a
like a free speech issue
which
you know i'm willing to go a lot of ways
for like free speech but child porn yeah
no i'm not going i'm not going there
sorry
sorry
that's like those kids can't consent
sorry they're underage um
and filming them
and watching it you're contributing to
the problem i missed the beginning of it
you're contributing to the problem yeah
yeah
if you're under the age of [ __ ] 18 i
don't think you can really consent
that's what i'm saying and you see and
that's what the law says too right
that's what the law says why 18.
why consent well you gotta you gotta you
got you have to place
a boundary somewhere
that's what i'm saying and you have to
place that boundary at a place of
how old can you can a [ __ ] be
how can how old can they be
and be draft eligible to go to warfare
that's when you're an adult
and if you ask me around 18 you could dr
you can draft someone at 18
and send them to war
because you can say well that's a man
or a woman
anything before that then they they
don't have the rights that's yeah of a
[ __ ]
which tells me right then i'm gonna
[ __ ] agree with the state of
louisiana if you could draft a
[ __ ] at 18 then he can [ __ ]
buy a drink in a damn bar at 18. i'll
yeah i'll give you that okay this 21
thing well i know why they did that
right but i'm just saying that if you're
gonna have that long be consistent right
if you were able to be drafted at 18 if
you can vote at 18 then you should be
able to drink at 18.
just get it if if that's the age of
adulthood
then just do it across the board and
then i'm so i'm not bothered at least
i'm the [ __ ] that's fine i can't [ __ ]
strip or do porn or whatever at 18. yeah
i don't have a problem a woman can do it
at [ __ ] 18 sell her body at 18 then a
man can sell his body to 18. because let
me tell you i was there as a [ __ ]
army [ __ ] airborne soldier
at the age of 18 um a young man is
selling his body to the state
at the ultimate [ __ ] level and the
thing is a couple people like tila said
i can't imagine being 18 years old going
out to fight but now there's an argument
to be made that maybe it should be older
than 18. it shouldn't though um
but i'm just saying if it's 18 or
whatever age that you want or if it's 20
or whatever i'm just saying apply that
across the board you're airing it that's
all i'm saying you're airing at the
minimum
at least at 18 you're you're you know
what's going on oh that was a dumbass i
was i think people knew what was going
on
i understood at 18.
that's the minimum
and the in the nation needs i mean
they're out of high school right they're
going to college like i said i don't
want to like push back too far but
like i said there is an argument to be
made that maybe 18 year olds are too
young but like i said the the argument
that i'm making is whatever age you
determine
let's apply that across the board can
you be drafted at that age can you drink
at that age it should be the same age is
this adulthood that's adulthood tila let
me trip you out
and during world war ii
bomber crews were flying over germany
and japan
dropping death
on civilians
german and japanese civilians sleeping
babies
[ __ ]
people
in their homes at night dropping [ __ ]
thermite bombs high explosive bombs
burning down whole [ __ ] cities
average age of the bomber crew was 19.
no no no no no no 19. do you remember
that song i remember that was another
one yeah it was vietnam was also was 19.
in vietnam yeah average age was 19.
y'all the girls in the 80s you all know
what songs are talking about
castle
kids
dropping death i don't know why i just
thought
and you said well mankind has progressed
no they haven't demand crime has not
progressed it's been the same for
thousands of years
thousands it will it will not progress
because of the limitations of mankind is
this well
it'll go up and down up and down up and
down but it will always revert to the
mean it just will
people are what they are
stop trying to [ __ ] make human beings
something that they're not
there's a certain amount of zen
i have found a certain amount of sin
sin
i have found a certain amount of zen and
allowing things to remain [ __ ]
up you see some shit's [ __ ] up just
let it be [ __ ] up you mean
because this is a certain amount because
that's just how it is yeah but like
it won't change i'm also a human yeah
and
one of my things is that i can't really
have find the state of zen because
people
are a constant source of disappointment
yes why are they not better thank you
because i must say this out be better
and sophie's gonna i could be better so
other people can be better we can you're
talking about individuals we can do this
you're talking about individuals stop
sucking you're talking about individuals
stop sucking individuals yes but not the
masses okay yeah but it'll never happen
what i'm saying is that if if people on
a large scale stop sucking it won't
happen this is my plan stop sucking yeah
then
everyone as a whole then largely we
would stop sucking and it would be
better for everybody 4 000 years of
history have shown that like i get that
i get that they've gotten a little bit
better but not that much better man
people always they let me down though
y'all let me down it's
just people let me down and like i said
i'm a person too i'm not like an alien
or nothing but it's like
you know i know there's others out there
i'm gonna say this [ __ ] and [ __ ]
sophie's gonna be out there laughing
because me and her be [ __ ] texting
talking about
evil human beings
are evil
hairless monkeys that's what you are
you're an evil hairless monkey don't
tell me especially that
sorry but i still love you
that
you're not a cybernetic organism out of
[ __ ] 2001 and the monolith well no
one said that i've never seen that it's
just you're not some elevated thing you
are what you are and i'm an able i guess
i understand that probably better than
most yeah
and yet
still
and yet still i am just i'm constantly
disappointed
by the actions of my fellow apes it
takes out it takes thousands and tens of
thousands get your [ __ ] together if you
look at the fossil record you're talking
tens of thousands of years is what it
takes
and if you jump in there like these
[ __ ] from the w after we'll you
will use genetic engineering
that will backfire also
it'll be like something out of star trek
and [ __ ] con
and the augments if you know you're
talking about yeah
you'll make super you'll engineer
super humans and they will be [ __ ]
psychos
though
because that's that's kind of what
humans are
yeah
so
go
slow your role people
or as i said stop sucking
yeah so you roll just enjoy [ __ ]
chill the [ __ ] chill out chill the [ __ ]
out be okay stop trying to change [ __ ]
just be what you are and enjoy i mean be
good to other people don't be a dick
just don't be a dick i mean that
shouldn't have to be said but apparently
it does
don't be a dick right
just be okay like be be a nice person if
you can't be a nice person
just be indifferent right yeah don't
like actively do anything right do
anything that like is [ __ ] up and like
i said i hate that i have to say that to
other people but
apparently it does have to be said
because yeah some people
apparently need that admonition which is
very sad
this is why people are disappointing
like i said right because i have to keep
telling them that
tammy says stop sucking that's that's my
motto
tom that's the right way to be man that
was a long time ago i don't know what
you're talking about you're gonna have
to be more more when you make comments
to me you have to be specific tom thinks
he's right about everything so you have
to be very specific he's not right about
everything
so i don't know exactly you have to be
specific about what exactly he was
writing so he can be very excited
[Laughter]
you're right
so yeah
uh where was i i was almost at the end
yeah
um we're gonna eat and then we're gonna
eat so okay that's good i might need
another drink though yeah before that
happens uh okay you want another
are you questioning my i'll get you
another one i mean you know okay
i'm already kind of sick i don't know if
you guys like i don't know what the [ __ ]
is the matter with me
but
the last three or four days
i have had
really bad i don't know if it's i think
it might be a sinus infection i think i
have a sinus infection
um
i've had like really bad headaches
and like my there's like horrible
pressure like behind my eyeballs
i've been like [ __ ] tired even though
i get normal sleep i'm like really
really tired
and then i'm like kind of coughing and
sniffling and like in the mornings but
it's mostly like headaches and [ __ ] i
took some antihistamines and that seemed
to help but
i don't think it's allergies i don't
have allergies that i know of but unless
they've developed later in my life but
yeah
so
yeah
so i think the thing that pissed me off
as i said the most about this case was
that this [ __ ]
died
at the age of 80 [ __ ] five or almost
80 [ __ ] five
and he died
with everyone thinking
that he was still awesome that he was
still like a hero he had like the
[ __ ]
seriously go look at the [ __ ]
headstone and the coffin the coffin's
gold
it was like ridiculous and the headstone
the headstone they've torn it down in
the meantime which happily
because they were like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and they tore all that [ __ ] out um
so they did that but
he
got what he wanted
he was lauded throughout his life yeah
there were rumors and [ __ ] like that but
nobody could prove anything
so he basically just got to like run
around and do whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted his whole entire life until he
was in his [ __ ] 80s
and got away with everything had a life
of luxury everybody loved him blah blah
blah he had all this money
and he died all these people showed up
at his funeral
and it was only after he died that
everyone was kind of like you know
[ __ ] came to like the forefront and
everybody like realized what a [ __ ]
monster he was and that makes me very
very angry i don't know why that makes
me so angry but it does
and the i don't know
i kind of feel like every time
every time we talk about like serial
killers or like people that did that
kind of [ __ ] i always wish
and i know this is stupid because i know
it probably would never happen how am i
going to say something what
looking con jumps [ __ ] but but jenny
where our evil is
what do you say no like no one's evil
it's not evil
it's just but then he jumps in and he
gets a great quote
from [ __ ] um that h.g wells flick
[ __ ] the time machine the second
version with guy pierce because who are
we to question
millions of years of human evolution
that's what that damn
morlock said
and more like said who are you to
question
hundreds of thousands of years of
evolution yeah but quotes like that i
feel like fall into the naturalistic
fallacy just because like something is
like natural that doesn't mean that's
necessarily like good for us like that's
what we do the warlock came from
hundreds of years of
hundreds of people i know like i get
that i get that and you know who are you
to question that and that's
but
i understand you're like well yeah
that's kind of a fallacy there's not
you know but history doesn't mean
anything in nature doesn't mean anything
but in a certain way
it kind of does it's reverting back to
the mean and the very basic
it's it's going back to the basics of
natural selection now people don't like
natural selection
a lot of
there are a lot of people that don't
like the concept of natural selection
especially
um people who are very uh [ __ ]
intelligent why
because they got beat up in high school
they got bounced off [ __ ]
lockers and [ __ ] back in high school so
they don't like natural selection they
want a special selection
but that's not the way the universe
works just we really by rights should
still be dinosaurs and that is that is
[ __ ]
it was just it happened to be that a
rock hit this place and made us not
dinosaurs
that is kind of [ __ ] weird when you
think about it it was random
but it
it's random it's not special in my
experience it's random in my experience
people that don't like the concept of
natural selection yeah are not people
that are like uh smart or nerdy that got
beat up in high school it's people that
are like jocks it's those type of people
that don't like the concept or religious
people are people that don't like that
kind of i guess it depends on how you
look at it
you got dumb people everywhere
uh yeah no [ __ ] yeah
but i'm just saying in my experience
that's not yeah that's not what you're
talking about um yeah not my experience
okay in my experience it was kind of the
other way around the jocks didn't know
anything
well yeah natural assists
i'm just saying it was mostly most of
the people that i saw that were against
like natural selection as a concept were
like religious people
yeah but intellectual people are also
kind of religious it's just not it's
just no it's really not it's
um different gods but it was still the
same gods yeah but see when you talk
about that you're talking about people
like me though and it's just like i
don't believe that i don't know anybody
that believes that so i don't really
know where you're getting that well
my
i don't know if grafters are still here
because i can name names
guys that i grew up with right i get
that but it's like i don't really know
where you're getting that what they like
on a large scale i don't really the gods
that they believed in were the frankfurt
school gods
they were highly uh i guess you say it
was
well the thing about it too is that
[ __ ] too well the thing about it too
and something that i found with
you know i i did a lot of um research
into particularly like creationists
creationists versus evolutionists one
thing that creationists like to accuse
evolutionists of if you want to use
their terminology
is that we always like listen to
authorities but that's what they do so
they're projecting it on to the other
side yeah so that's kind of like
something but
people that are like scientists they
don't do that
but because religious people do that
they think the other side does that also
so they project that onto that's not at
all what i was talking them so they're
talking about oh well you guys your god
is like richard dawkins now whoever or
whoever the evolutionist of the day is
and i'm like really that's not
what it's completely different it's
completely different i totally agree
with you we don't have that whole
i think we listen to like one person
we don't do that you're right you're
right i totally agree with you that's
projection it's projection i you are
right and it's very common you are right
and i totally agree with you but that
was nothing to do with what i was
talking about
it just sounded like that no yeah
nothing to do
[ __ ] um
because both sides were always
projecting that they were selected
okay but they weren't
but we can go back we just go back to
the [ __ ] story
doesn't really matter i never thought i
was selected for
anything you had i'm just here randomly
[ __ ]
drunk as [ __ ] and that [ __ ] was too
[ __ ]
too complicated for me to [ __ ]
explain right now but you're right but
that's not what i was talking about not
at all i saw something very different
than what you saw
i'll talk about it on another day i'll
i'll remember i'll remember okay but no
that's not ex not at all i'm not a big
believer in like a person just like
talking from authority i don't i don't
like that that's kind of like the whole
thing about the scientific mindset right
is you don't you only believe evidence
you don't believe like evidential stuff
you don't believe like something people
say
because like what the who the [ __ ] are
you but that's that that's kind of a
stock answer but that's not what i was
talking about i'm just kind of too drunk
to talk about it to explain it
okay yeah what i was talking about is oh
[ __ ]
how much time do we have left
what are you talking about time we have
left because it will take me time to
explain it i'm trying i have to defend
myself now
but defending yourself against what
these accusations that i'm wrong no one
act no one accuses you of okay all right
all right don't get competitive okay no
one's accusing you of anything okay
[Laughter]
see i don't i mean the thing about it i
kind of feel like
i don't know there's this whole thing
and i got into it like a lot of times
like i said i haven't kept up with it
but
i do kind of feel like during the whole
evolution versus creationist wars
you kind of got a whole thing where
creationists were trying to project on
the other side that it's like oh science
is just a religion blah blah it's it's
completely not the same thing it's a
it's completely 180 degrees
opposite
of religion
um it's really not the same mindset at
all and then i was talking about and
that's well somebody said that in the
comments that's why i wanted to
it's so it's really not the same thing
so every time
i see somebody say oh science is just
another religion it just really really
makes me angry because i'm like
seriously it's really not the same thing
that is just like religious people
projecting their mindset onto the other
side and they completely know nothing
about it so but you have certain people
that believe in philosophies
okay that have nothing to do with
science and that is their religion okay
and if you go to the frankfurt school if
you look at which is social studies that
has nothing to do with real science it's
more like scientology okay
they will tell you all kinds of things
that it's not true
all right
uh they think it is but it isn't
and you can it's just word games if you
redefine words you can make anything
sound
like anything you want to because you
can't agree on any terminology or any
words
you know
but that jenny isn't really fully
schooled in that and that type of
argument well because he doesn't really
know what i'm talking about you have to
go back to the [ __ ] hegelian dialogue
i know what you're talking about she
doesn't really know that they hit aliens
i know what you're talking about it's
just not really germane to the situation
right right right it's not german into
the situation right and agnes says
science is not a religion absolutely
it's not because science is not
just a tool it's not a set of beliefs
right it's just religion is a set of
beliefs we believe these things because
of faith and that's fine if that's the
route you want to go science science is
a method science is a teacher it's not
truth it's not right a sense of like we
believe this because people are confused
about what science is because social
studies will [ __ ] make a false
version of science
to tell them what science is and that's
not science
because there's no data science needs
data there has to be numbers
well that's what i'm saying and without
numbers then there's no science and uh
so
like i said
the two thought processes are complete
and like i said i'm not [ __ ] on
religion if you want to like believe in
a particular religion that's fine but
like i said religion is a set of beliefs
that
are by their definition
not provable right um and you believe
them on faith that's kind of like the
whole idea of religion science is a
it's not a set of beliefs it's a tool or
a method right for arriving at a
conclusion right and science must have
mathematics it has to have numbers
well it has to have evidence behind
cause that's proof it has to happen and
without numbers evidence and proof there
is no science but you can't have you
well you can't have a foregone
conclusion and like find evidence that's
right to get to that what people in the
audience are talking about is of
pseudosciences that are out there
that will reject sign reject numbers and
mathematics as being racist
and that [ __ ] science has to do with
truth and truth comes from being life
and faith but and there's there's not
there it's not there the thing about it
though
is that
some people that have more religious or
faith-based beliefs
can
massage
science yeah uh in the service of their
beliefs so you have to kind of like
watch for that as well right and
somebody brings up straw dog 78 says
there's real science and there's
unverified fantastical science people
have a hard time distinguishing yeah
there's a lot of like
sciences out there also
um where people will
cherry pick
um
evidence of certain studies or whatever
and like uh discard other things that
don't agree with their
foregone conclusion true science does
not have emotion in it it is cold it is
cold hard
well you can't have a foregone you can't
like try to prove a thing it's like i
want to prove right and religions did
that end right uh and then i'm gonna
find science to like prove that because
that's gonna like winnow you down a
certain thing
what they're talking about is there's a
lot of things that are being betrayed in
in common
in common culture right now as being
science and it isn't
it's more like emotion in politics and
and faith
but it isn't and just because it comes
from the and just because it comes from
the left that doesn't mean it's not
faith it is faith
it is faith there's
religious there are re religions and
then there are [ __ ]
secular religions which are religions
that are not religious but it's it's
also faith well it's not i don't know
what you guys are talking about it's
it's not necessarily religion it's just
like i said it would be almost like a
science in the way that
you're trying to find what you're trying
to find is like you have a conclusion
your bias is based on this [ __ ] it's not
it's not gonna happen so it's like
you'll only like for example like i want
to prove you know whatever the end is
right and then i'm only going to
uh you know
bring in the studies that seem to prove
that and throw out all the ones that i
don't think right confirm that by saying
oh they weren't been properly done or
whatever so it's kind of that so there's
that too but
it's imperfect but humans aren't perfect
um we're never going to be perfect
and
it's just never going to happen if you
go back to rawcism which is my [ __ ]
philosophy and you embrace the concept
that humans are evil hairless monkeys
and they're not alive
that they lie
and that it's about power that there is
that there is no truth there is only
power
they will tell you anything
okay as long as it empowers them
all right that that's the basic
monkeyology we're not needing silence
even monkeys aren't evil yeah yeah well
no no no monkeys are just what they are
that points humans are the evil versions
of monkeys
because they know
those [ __ ] lie even though i can come
back and say no monkeys know about what
lies are monkeys understand lies but
because a monkey i would already know
the monkey and then when the male monkey
sees each other and they go oh you'll
try to hide his heart on like i wasn't
trying to [ __ ] her yes you were yeah but
humans do that too well i was just
saying monkeys do but i'm just saying
monkeys are as evil as you evil evil no
what i'm trying to tell you if you'd
shut up for a second
is that evil to me
implies intent
and a lot of things that humans do yeah
that seem
evil like i'm not saying that humans
don't do evil [ __ ] they do yeah but a
lot of [ __ ] that they do
i think that the reason that they're
doing them
they're not really thinking of it as
they're not really thinking of it as in
that way they're thinking of it in like
a self-serving kind of way
they're not really thinking of it yeah
they're thinking of in a more like
self-centered kind of way not like in an
evil i'm gonna [ __ ] the whole world kind
of way
to me like evil seems like i'm gonna
like kill the whole [ __ ] it's like a
more psychopathic thing
if people are just being like selfish
that seems to me like
pretty standard yes to what humans do
like monkeys do whatever yeah it's so
bad
that's what yeah that's what i'm saying
so to me that doesn't seem like evil
because it's not
evil to me is like look i know this is
bad
i know killing all these babies in this
orphanage for example is bad but i'm
gonna do it anyway just for the [ __ ] of
it that's evil okay doing [ __ ] because
well i'm gonna do this [ __ ] because i
want to do it but it's like i'm gonna
like
think of some like [ __ ] uh reason for
it like some self-serving reason
that's not
i mean from our point of view that's
evil from that person's point of view
they're just like doing
that's not evil i don't know it's not
evil in a larger sense you know what i
mean if you're gonna say evil because i
kind of feel like that has a religious
connotation
so it has to be like much larger scale
you know what i'm saying so i kind of
feel like
that has to be like very very deliberate
i know that this is like really really
bad but i'm gonna do it anyway
knowing that
and i feel like most people when they do
bad [ __ ]
they think of self-serving reasons
why
they're doing this they're excusing it
in their own mind in a lot of ways
um
[Music]
so by that definition
even though we would see it as evil i
don't think they see it as evil you know
what i'm saying it's a it's a tricky
term
you know but um there's all this
apologism going on no i'm just saying
it's i'm trying to like make a
distinction because
evil is a loaded word and i don't really
like to use that a lot because like i
said it has a religious connotation i'm
not a big fan of like religious
connotation with [ __ ]
but
[Music]
to me you come from a planet where
[ __ ] kill each other [ __ ]
over emotions yeah i just call it i
should be evil no i do too
and like i said to me it's about power
i'm i'm to the point now where i've
[ __ ] i [ __ ] kind of wintered it
down
to where
humans that have power
don't give a [ __ ] about truth there is
no truth there is only power
that's what they're thinking
they're thinking there is no truth there
is only power but the point is only say
whatever empowers them the point i'm
trying to make
is that
and it's monkey [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] the
point i'm trying to make yeah that's it
is that
one thing that people that want to
understand
um people that do quote unquote evil
things like serial killers for example
one thing you have to understand is that
these people
who in our narrative are villains
obviously
they don't necessarily
see themselves as villains or if they do
um
they justify it somehow usually and i
kind of feel like that's something that
we need to understand if we want to stop
that from happening you know what i'm
saying yeah
um and like i said that ties into the
jimmy savile thing that we were talking
about earlier because people liked this
because he was a [ __ ] psychopath for
sure
but the fact that he asked me he had
power he had the power to do this and
there would truth and right and wrong
didn't matter but here's only but like i
said that's what i'm doing the fact that
you have people like this yeah that know
about the power structure they know
about this kind of stuff and they are
[ __ ] up and they know that they can
manipulate people
to
their point of view
that is something that we absolutely
have to look into because
look at the psychology of this
[ __ ] for example which made me
so angry
as much as this makes me angry like
reading about this dude
i think that it's really instructive
looking at cases like this because
this was a guy
that
got away with [ __ ] for decades and
decades
obviously was getting off on the fact
that he was getting away with [ __ ] for
decades and decades and thought it was
funny
it was amusing to him to some degree to
the fact where he was comfortable enough
saying some like pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ]
on
tv like to millions of people
and
you know was comfortable with the fact
well no one's gonna do anything to me
and nobody did um because like i said
until after he was dead they didn't
really do anything
so
as [ __ ] up as it is to like look into
cases like this we should because the
psychology of this kind of will help us
prevent this in the future we can
hopefully
see this kind of crap
coming and
nip this in the bud
more than we more than happened in this
case because i kind of feel like in his
case
there were many opportunities
where somebody could have stepped in and
said hey blah blah and nobody did it
like i said i'm not blaming any one
person because
you know a lot of the times that he was
doing this [ __ ]
again not excusing it but culturally
no one was really listening to
girls or women or little kids or
anything like that they were saying hey
like some dude like touch me
inappropriately everyone's like yeah
whatever shut up it's like no one really
cared about it
and
um you know when he got away with it he
kind of flew under the radar for a long
time because of the
kind of laissez-faire attitude that
everybody had about
victimization of
women and children and you know other
vulnerable people in the population at
that time you could get away with it if
you were a dude because
you know oh as you know i i grabbed the
ass of the secretary oh it's like you
know that's what dudes do blah blah blah
it's like oh it's funny you know what i
mean everyone just thought it was kind
of like funny
you know
so i'm glad that we're kind of getting
past that but
the fact that he was able to get away
with it for like what 50 years
50 years and he [ __ ] died and he
never even got arrested one time
and that just i don't know that just
makes me really angry but
the fact that his case is so widespread
nowadays i'm hoping
that that will prevent it from happening
again
um because everyone's cognizant of it
now but
i don't know we'll see how it goes i
don't really know
i don't know tom it's like
thank you zack jenny said massage
science
did i say massage science i
i don't remember saying massage science
was not talking about massages my mind
immediately imagined someone getting
rubbed down with radioactive lotion
did i
i would have
hot
i don't remember saying massage science
did i say bizarre science or did i say
like some other word i don't know
i don't know where is that but um yeah
i don't know
i don't know why this like this whole
researching this whole show
delving into the mind of jimmy savile
over the last two days while i was
researching this show
it's put me in a weird mental place
it made me
i don't know i was thinking about this
like before we put the show on i'm like
should i even do the show because it's
like i want to just hit everybody
i said
i was watching documentaries about this
[ __ ] for a couple of days like
in preparation for the show and like
reading about him stuff and then like an
hour or two before we did the show i
said should we even do the show today
because i feel like i want to hit
everybody
now
it's just
this whole situation made me so bad and
it's like i don't know it's like i said
we've done like shows about serial
killers and that makes me mad too
obviously but
i think the thing that made me mad about
this douche was that he was so [ __ ]
smug about it
and i think that that's what pushed me
over the edge you know what i mean that
just like i just i was like when i hit
everything i just want to hit everything
and i was just kind of like can i even
do the show i just want to hit
everything it just made me so so angry
but you know that's it happens um
it happens you know how i do khan's been
watching [ __ ] jordan maxwell he said
constant time you need to write a book
called the illusion of us
uh [ __ ] what you have to give me more
[ __ ] khan [ __ ] i could probably
come up with some [ __ ] like that
i'd have to go deep deep into some
research
uh and write a philosophy book like that
and then i'd need [ __ ] jenny to
[ __ ] ghostwrite it for me and and she
wouldn't do it she'd be like i write in
the book it probably dude i got other
[ __ ] to do she kind of should do and you
understand that [ __ ] a book
a book a book like that if you go back
and you read [ __ ]
uh schopenhauer
or nietzsche
those books could be [ __ ] massively
condensed they padded the [ __ ] out of
that [ __ ] okay to make those books well
probably just like nowadays they're
trying to get like a longer page yeah
they were like oh man maybe they got
paid by the word yeah they wanted that
[ __ ] to be like they did back in the day
the size of my [ __ ] right there
this is some substantial [ __ ] i got some
like truths to tell you look how thick
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
i know the game yeah i write books again
they've been playing games for [ __ ]
hundreds of years all right you're like
oh this is what i got to say look at the
size of that [ __ ]
looking you know careful my book is
bigger than your book i gotta read
tolstoy read war and peace that [ __ ]
just like that and it was meandering all
over the [ __ ] place when i read that
they did that a lot back then
honestly i've even read short stories
from that era i was like dude this could
have been like a paragraph right it
could have been a paragraph calm down
right
well it's a bunch of white boys that
[ __ ] liked this whole idea about the
pen
and vocabulary and they're showing off
their vocabulary it's like dope [ __ ] on
that i'm into that and they're like whoa
i wrote that [ __ ] and i used this word
and that word
and and they're like man the story
wasn't all that
you're you're you're wrong it's
something it's not there's no i'm not
[ __ ] on me there's a fine line
between because i you know i read a lot
of fiction
there's a fine line between
you have a book your because when you
have a book you don't have the uh luxury
of a movie
of visuals so you're painting a whole
entire world and inside someone's head
so
i will give you like some descriptive
language and [ __ ] like that but
you also have to like
get to
the interesting stuff too just give me a
little bit of the descriptive and then
get to the interesting stuff
so
i get where like some people and i feel
like back in the old days before they
really got the
wave of that
um
[Music]
i don't know there were a lot of good
stories from back then but a lot of them
were like overly descriptive they kind
of gave a lot of stuff that you really
didn't need to know
in the in the
you know service of the story it was it
was the social medium of the time
okay they didn't have right uh [ __ ]
facebook and instagram
so when you picked up a book they even
have movies they didn't have you know
they had live theater but
you picked up their books and you read
them and it was just like going into
their version of social media and it was
like oh yeah but they were trying to
[ __ ]
make it as big as they could possibly
make to make it really you know and they
were showing off vocabulary and they
were showing off their [ __ ] skill
their language skills and their [ __ ]
thinking skills
kant
scope schopenhauer and nietzsche are the
[ __ ]
probably like the
those dudes were the bedrock of [ __ ]
western philosophy and thinking
but their work really could be [ __ ]
massively condensed down to nothing but
that's not what that era was about that
era was about expanding and being
[ __ ] flowery and entertaining and
well you have to think too that
that would drive you crazy well back in
the old days you kind of have to think
that
when they were writing a lot of the
stuff that we take for granted nowadays
was maybe they didn't take for granted
back then
so
had to be explained yeah um also another
thing just from a cynical point of view
uh back then a lot of the stuff
particularly the fiction was written for
magazines and stuff like that and they
were paid by the word
um so it would it behooved them to
write as much as possible right
i'm not saying that and actually i'm a
big fan of like victorian ghost stories
and stuff like that but a lot of them
were very
wordy yeah we'll say
i was but they did paint a picture
i read one by [ __ ] um
uh this is back in like 2004
and it was called the birth of tragedy
it wasn't very big
but he's going on and on about how
western civilization has to have a new
source of entertainment through theater
and blah blah blah and this happens and
this happens and is
in the way the audio of visual
teaching and i'm
and it has to happen every and i'm going
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
and i'm realizing and then it dawned on
me you know what this [ __ ] has never
seen television
well yeah you know they've never seen
television they've never seen that's
what i mean
they're talking from a point of view
right
he was imagining
a theater that was kind of like
television
and he was wrong
about a lot of the stuff that he didn't
know but he was right about a certain
ideas that
television and mass media could
create a culture that's all he's talking
about in that it's just that it it
doesn't it didn't turn out the way he
was imagining it you know nothing ever
does no
no like i said i think that's why it's
pointless to try to like uh extrapolate
like to the future right
there's no point but you don't know
what's gonna happen there's a lot of
other niches writings that are [ __ ]
really good same thing with scopenhauer
you know oh [ __ ] all kinds of money just
showed up thank you very much who is
this
this is from manga badger oh it might be
i may be behind you oh thank you manga
bears
here's all the hairless monkeys down
payment for my ticket to planet tom
dad you go to planet tom you're gonna
get laid
because i'm gonna have all these it's a
whole planet of times yeah we haven't
established like what the female toms
look like
yeah they probably just look like you
but with the wig on
so they will still like
they will still like stick their [ __ ] up
in your booty what did he say what do
you say um
you've done a great show on a grim
subject chad has been awesome as always
you guys rock i hear the beer god
calling me again okay go ahead i'm here
go ahead bro thank you so much i got i
got i got [ __ ] um
uh carnitas down there waiting i'm
having a good time though we're gonna
have some sit down yeah i mean i know
jenny up but i got my i got card thank
you cause like you ready to go you have
a you have a tendency of just like
wandering out yeah like [ __ ] i'm
gonna eat
[Laughter]
yeah you do that even when you're sober
and i'm just kind of like oh okay bye
well i think we did that on the like
matinee show we were talking about and
he was totally sober and he's just like
bye and i was like oh there he goes okay
i had enough
i guess i had enough
at least have some decorum have some
decorum yeah
jesus christ all right
i mean khan's coming in because mango
liverpool and manchester city advance to
the semi-finals okay whatever he's
talking about he's talking
well
[Music]
i mean like i said i kind of feel like
well okay maybe americans now now that
the netflix series came out maybe they
know like what a big deal this is like i
said if you live if americans want to
know like what the uh
scope of this is
it's kind of the same [ __ ] as like the
bill cosby [ __ ]
right because the bill cosby [ __ ] we
should probably do a show about that at
some point too um
everybody loved bill cosby back in those
oh he's so funny he's like comedian he
was like america's dad he was on like
this long running sitcom he seemed like
a nice dude blah blah blah
and then all of a sudden it comes oh
he's a sexual predator you know what i
mean
which
honestly like i should have been
surprised but i was kind of like i'm
kind of surprised but not that surprised
i wasn't that surprised
i was like uh figures
so uh you know so there was that
and so that happened so i kind of feel
like it was that level but
maybe like amplified because as i said
jimmy savile was kind of like everybody
everybody knew who he was in the uk it
was like a massive thing and he'd been
around for like decades and decades
and even though there was like you know
[ __ ] going around like back in the old
days like people were kind of like yeah
this dude's like a creeper like stay
away but
it wasn't like widely disseminated
nobody really knew about that [ __ ] till
after he was dead yeah
like i said
he died 2011 and they still did like a
[ __ ] memorial show about him they did
like the whole big funeral they did the
whole gravestone and it was only like a
big because journalists were kind of
like can we not do this because he was
kind of like a bad person we're
investigating this and they're like no
he was awesome and so they did all that
and then it took like almost a year
after he was dead until finally like
everything came too late and then
finally like 450 500 people come out and
be like yeah this dude was like a
[ __ ] he like raped me he like
sexually assaulted there was all that
like hundreds and hundreds of people
yeah jesus christ a lot of them when
they were like [ __ ] children
i got people in there quoting nietzsche
about you know [ __ ] that that which
does not kill you makes you stronger
look you have to understand something
in pop culture nietzsche is pretty he's
kind of portrayed as some kind of hard
very serious kind of
dude
uh in the writings then that's not what
you're gonna see all right he is a very
uh jovial
kind of [ __ ] clownish dude
he's funny and he's more of a
commentator he's not a philosopher
i would say he was he's the german
howard stern of the 1800s
um
he does come up with a lot of
cool truthisms
a lot of it's built upon philosophers
that came before him he kind of calls
[ __ ] on it and like goes oh come on
these values that [ __ ]
scope and how are you is [ __ ] talking
about these are not the values of a good
man these are the values of a [ __ ]
loser so he's kind of more of a
commentator
on philosophers
uh he's critical of philosophy
um
and funny
funny he was more into arts and uh
and uh i guess you could say
uh free spiritism in a certain way
uh so he's not at all what a lot of
people think they've equated him
sometimes with the [ __ ] german
national socialists and [ __ ]
the
the nazis did like a lot of what he said
but they wouldn't have agreed there's a
really good book called nietzsche and
the nazis you can get a [ __ ] an audio
version of it on youtube
listen to that you'll see the truth
there's a lot of difference between
nietzsche and the nazis all right
the the nazis kind of like plagiarized
and picked up a lot of his ideas and
expounded them but nietzsche wouldn't
like them he was not into
totalitarianism
he wasn't in he was in he was very much
a man of free will and he didn't like he
didn't like
governments
he would have been
he would have been an anarchist really
when it came to government you know
he he didn't trust people
he would have been like me you evil
hairless monkeys that's what that's what
he would that's way that's the way he
was
and um
he had a lot of fun kind of a goth type
dude of his time
smart guy but everybody's imperfect and
even he said that even he said that and
he and nietzsche would say look man
figure this [ __ ] out on your own i'm not
here to tell you how to live
which and i'm not here to tell you
what's real
and that that's a sign of a [ __ ] very
honest man all right
don't tell other people what's real
they figure that [ __ ] out on their own
bodica x says uh jimmy savile was wired
into the british elite and the royal
family he was protected by the british
security services untouchable
to a large extent i think he was and
honestly i don't really know
if the royal family knew what i was what
he was doing
i kind of feel like he
purposefully
uh
befriended the royal family
for the very purpose of
giving him some cover so i don't really
know if the royal family knew exactly
what he was doing or if they just turned
a blind eye or whatever but i do
definitely think that he
was cognizant
of i need powerful people behind me
i have fame and money but i need some
like that was why he approached the
royal family that was why he approached
margaret thatcher that was why he
approached the pope
um he's like if i have all these people
behind me
then if somebody comes forward and
accuse me of something then i can say
hey i have margaret thatcher in the
royal family and like the pope they're
behind me like who are you to accuse me
so i kind of feel like that was very
very deliberate on his part that he
sought out french friendships with like
people and uh very very powerful people
he knew what he was doing absolutely um
nothing that i've read about him like
makes me think that he was because he
was actually very intelligent and i
think that he was very
manipulative and i think that his whole
entire life
um
was built around i don't think he had
any like
soul or like any inner
self of his own i think his whole entire
energy was expended on
this
persona that he constructed and the
persona that he constructed uh was a
powerful person that was friends with
all these powerful people and could
therefore act with impunity he could use
like whatever he wanted and if you
complained about it then he would just
say hey i'm friends with the the queen
or the prime minister i'm friends with
the royal family i can do whatever the
[ __ ] i want to you and
that was most like that was enough to
like shut people up
so
he absolutely knew what he was doing
so
as i said they didn't really get into
the [ __ ] until after he was dead in 2011
so 2012 late to 2012
they did this whole thing like this
whole investigation
and they were like yeah we think this
[ __ ] might be like the most
prolific sexual predator in british
history
450 alleged victims
uh they had contacted police in 10 weeks
since the investigation was launched
so they started looking into almost 200
different crimes 17 different uh
jurisdictions
um
31 allegations of rape analysis report
82 of those who came forward were female
so
like i said mostly it was mostly girls
but
he would go after boys too if they were
available he would go
he would go after anybody anybody that
was
vulnerable yeah he was he preferred
young girls
but if all that was available was boys
or older women or whatever he would hit
that too he didn't give a [ __ ] it was it
was whatever was laying around sounds
like he had [ __ ] some kind of sexual
addiction if i couldn't like he that he
didn't care
it was all good he didn't seem to like i
said he did have a preference it did
seem like he liked
very young teenage girls
like you know 14 years old
if it was a boy or if it was like an
older girl that's fine he didn't really
he didn't care if they were like
unconscious or something
he was gonna
take advantage
um he just seemed like an opportunist
like i said in a lot of ways a lot of
good uh nietzsche quotes of it uh coming
out of the damn
comment section nietzsche basically said
man was an animal and that he was sick
because he didn't understand his own
nature
and that man had to find out what his
own nature was and you're not going to
find that
in the social cut zeitgeist especially
the social social guy zeitgeist of his
time
of his time
to what they thought man was was
something that christianity would tell
you what man was and that's
that's not what man is
but you guys understand it i mean
anybody in there nietzsche would tell
you any man in his heart would
understand what man is
don't let other people tell you what
humans are and what you are
you are what you are you know what you
are
do what it is that you feel that you
should do
you know that's what nietzsche is
basically saying all right but he also
says don't allow yourself to be pumped
out fight for your own survival he said
a lot of things that are but he's a
commentator he's and he's a man like
like us
wait
i don't listen to any [ __ ] don't
listen to you because no [ __ ] are me
you do what you need to do in the
situation that you're in sorry
[ __ ] right right which these are kind
of revolutionary ideas in nichi's day
okay
and i have never heard a single thing
from any other [ __ ] right that
sounded like anything that was
approximating anything that what i was
into so i'm just kind of like why
right don't listen to anybody no just
you do you you do you you take care of
you i think that's kind of like the
platonic right you do you yeah it's okay
all right
don't listen to nobody don't compare
yourself to nobody
you were just you right now you just do
that now jimmy seville probably was
probably thinking the same thing
well it is is that you don't do not fall
victim of solipsism
you are not the center of the earth
just because you flipped out of that yet
doesn't mean that other people want it
that's what i mean they will make you
pay for violating the rights of other
people right that's that's kind of what
and even nietzsche will tell you that
you can't go up against reality you do
you but when you actions have confidence
when you other people also are being
them right and when you start [ __ ]
over other people they retaliate sure
and
anton levay tells you this
i mean duh that should be like
self-evident but apparently it's not
right
apparently it's not right like i said
you do you to the extent that you are
not impinging on others on the you of
other people right you're right um when
you're doing that if you get your ass
beat that's your own goddamn fault right
largely right
um
and i kind of wish that somebody had
beat jimmy savile's ass right nobody did
well he had expansive power
and he abused the [ __ ]
and he made it and he abused it to a
point where he
was so confident in the abuse of it yeah
that he talked about it on tv and like
nobody called him out on it
i mean they did like they were kind of
like hey what about this but he was able
to like flip it around
i can only blame this on the weakness of
other men
nobody went after and they knew
they had to have known
i mean i'm not blaming anybody
particularly but
i'm not i'm i'm just going to say i
would not have been sad had somebody
like murdered this dude to sleep
somebody should have yeah i'm not saying
anybody in particular should have
i'm not blaming anybody for not doing
that i'm just saying that it would have
been nice
if somebody had did that
just
quietly i mean you could have made him
suffer a little bit before
but
somebody should have just like taken him
out back in the like 60s probably
ideally
would have it would have been the best
situation
um no
khan comes in here
and he's coming in here
as [ __ ]
as
as buddhist as he possibly can he sounds
like a cross between
scopenhauer and [ __ ] siddhartha he
says
he says to live is to suffer that's
right that's buddhism right there
to survive is to find some meaning in
the sufferings that's right that's right
man that's exactly right
that's quite accurate yeah
buddhist thought is
one
[Laughter]
we stuff
hold on i can't even [ __ ]
are you gonna like come on yeah [ __ ]
i got some [ __ ] yeah we should you guys
should get she got [ __ ] good you do i
was gonna say if you if you can't i
gotta [ __ ] make i gotta cook as soon
as we get done okay
uh x says
uh or no american military 100 says
there's a very very prophetic and creepy
quote from bill cosby like i said i was
comparing both those cases just in terms
of like magnitude
bill cosby said when he hosted showtime
at the apollo's stevie wonder special
what's the use of being a star if you
can't use it and abuse it oh [ __ ] and
the fact that you would even say that
out loud
what does that say about you as a person
like why
the fact not only the fact that you
thought that
but the fact that you felt confident
enough
to say that out loud to other people
that is very
disturbing
that's very disturbing why would you say
that out loud and that's kind of like
that's why i compared the two because i
kind of feel like bill cosby had the
same kind of [ __ ] vibe going on
he also had the same kind of like oh i'm
very powerful i'm very rich
no one can and you know he had the same
thing where it's like you know if you
say something about it you know no one
will believe you blah blah everybody
loves me
so there was that kind of [ __ ] going on
too and a lot of people didn't believe
it even after
you know hundreds of people like you
know all these people came out and said
about it but
i don't know man i kind of feel like
there's this whole thing
i don't know this bothers me it's real i
don't know it's really like bothering me
this whole [ __ ] situation
this researching the show made me really
really angry
it just made me really angry
i mean
that's kind of my default state i'm not
gonna lie she's always there i'm not
gonna lie that's kind of my default
state but it just kind of like amped it
up i was just kind of like
why why did nobody do it and why did
nobody kill this dude jesus christ
because it would have been me
well i don't know i wasn't there
but i wasn't there in the whole cultural
zeitgeist i'm not blaming anybody that
was there but it's like if if
21st century jenny
was somehow thrust back into a time
machine
to top of the pops 1965 and that dude
like grabbed my [ __ ] tit or something
like that i would have [ __ ] killed
that dude
yeah
knowing what i know now
but i understand why they didn't back
then it was like a whole different
thing but nowadays people would be just
like boom
you know what i mean
but back then you didn't do that
and i you know that's the reason why he
got away with it for so long like i said
that's i i kind of feel like that's why
it's better that we're aware of that
[ __ ] now
john comes in with some deep [ __ ] listen
to this [ __ ] did he really
there was always some madness in love
but there was always some reason and
madness yeah where were you getting that
man where are you getting that that
sounds like some [ __ ] that [ __ ]
nietzsche would say
that's not like somebody would say
that's true though
or scope shower always says this is it
yeah
that's true that's good
i mean you know i get it yeah
a says but you're all just a figment of
my imagi of my imagination
he's probably like going back to what he
said yeah i kind of feel like
jimmy savile struck me
as someone who his entire life i think
this is what made me mad his entire life
he never seemed to realize
that
other people existed but him
he seemed his whole entire life
and he died thinking this apparently
i can go my whole entire life
and do whatever the [ __ ] i want
and there will be no consequences and
sadly that was true
that happened he believed it and it was
it happened
and that
really really makes me angry the fact
that that could happen
the fact that so many people so i don't
think i don't know i'm mad at him
obviously but i'm mad at all the people
not so much the victims i'm not mad at
them
i'm mad at people in authority
that saw what was going on
and were like meh
meh
yeah [ __ ] do something yeah stop that
person from like doing that again jesus
christ khan says that is from nietzsche
yeah
of course
of course think about it there is always
some madness in love
but there is always some reason there's
reason and madness there's always a
it's crazy to love this [ __ ] but
there's always a reason why you're crazy
loving this [ __ ] of course of course of
course yeah it makes sense when you're a
man
why do you love me though because i'm
[ __ ] crazy there's a certain amount
of is there a better reason than that or
no there's a certain reason in why it's
crazy you know what i mean [ __ ] but
yeah that's exactly what i'm looking for
a larger for for a larger explanation
it's because there's a certain reason
too
is there it makes sense does it it makes
sense i guess it makes sense that's it i
guess it does you can't explain it so
maybe not and i guess it does
it's about well that's another thing
niche wasn't about the logic of [ __ ]
in the way that you think it was he was
also about emotion and feelings okay
[ __ ] so you know just go back
there was a certain amount of emotion
and feelings to [ __ ] me i know yeah
i've read it also right
so are we done
i suppose okay you still have oh you
still haven't answered the question
though what question
what was the question nevermind i didn't
see the question
pookie what you doing i'm just
downstairs
is a whole bunch of pork
and i'm gonna i got carnitas down there
okay can we just say make some [ __ ]
tacos so here's the thing so here's what
happened okay after jimmy savile okay
yeah died just wrapping up so everybody
2011 he dies i was like oh my god he was
like so amazing blah blah blah now he's
dead blah blah then like less than a
year later all these journalists finally
get their way and it's like can we
please finally like expose this
[ __ ] for like what he was so
they finally did that they just said
they did panorama they did all that kind
of [ __ ]
everybody's like holy [ __ ]
uh he sucked yeah
um
and then after that like after they
exposed a couple of like uh people
stories like everybody else started
coming forward and said yeah that
[ __ ] that's not in the other
because you know they're like hey we
reported to the police a long time ago
and
no one listened to us imagine that
so
people did report it so it's not like oh
why didn't they report it they did uh
nobody paid attention though
so but finally they did that
so
now
in the uk his name is like [ __ ]
mud
he had
all of these [ __ ] honorary
uh degrees he had all these plaques
he used to live here he did this and
that they tore all that [ __ ] out they
took his
pimpin ass gravestone which was super
tacky i saw like pictures of it they
tore it out they said we're not even
they didn't leave anything they tore the
[ __ ] out i mean you can still find it
like on youtube but they tore it out and
they just like we're just gonna it's
unmarked [ __ ] that [ __ ]
so they just want to like wipe them out
of history because
like i said they were i kind of feel
like the british public were
offended
that this dude had
pulled the wool over their eyes for so
long and they're like you pretended that
you were like this good person like all
this time
and you made us do all this stuff and
then
now that you're dead we found out all
that [ __ ] so they were
super mad it was like a whole big thing
over there
so they tore out his gravestone they did
they tore out all the [ __ ] that had his
name on it they just like they were
trying to like do remember like back in
the old days like when a pharaoh would
die
and they did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
everybody's like yeah we're gonna like
tear all your statues they did that
yeah they're like where they took off
all the [ __ ] that had his name on it
like on the side of buildings and
whatnot
and even all like the [ __ ]
uh
charities that he had set up were like
well we're gonna like disperse this
money and we're just gonna like buy we
don't want his name associated
so
i will say even though he's dead and
he's like past any [ __ ]
uh judgment i kind of wish
i don't wish he was still alive because
he sucked
but
i wish that he had lived long enough
to see
some
repercussions for his actions because he
never did i think that's what makes me
the angriest
is that
he died thinking everybody
like still loved him he had the gold
coffin and the big [ __ ] he had this
whole big thing and everybody was like
still they had tribute programs on bbc
and blah blah blah and it's like so he
died thinking oh i'm so awesome
everybody like [ __ ] love me whatever
and it's like that
oh that makes me so so angry well
it's like always like away with it
that's what i mean he got away with it
that makes me so so mad now khan comes
in and he says he gives another
nietzsche quote that's [ __ ] great
insanity in in in individuals is
something rare
but in groups parties nations and epochs
it's the rule [ __ ] right hell yeah
you see that now
yeah
mass insanity is very common very cold
no doubt very common no no
seville no he got away with it he got
away with it jenny like i said
well i think that's why well like i said
i think that's what pisses
people off about his particular case
yeah is that
he
like nobody really
knew like people knew but they didn't
know the extent yeah until after he was
dead
after he was dead like people when
people didn't fear his wrath anymore
like a lot of people came forward and
like i said i'm not blaming them because
some of them did come forward back then
and they got ignored yeah so
the fact that they were like well now
he's gone and i can finally like come
forward and say like all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that he did and it's like i'm
glad that we know now
but i wish that he'd been alive to at
least see that his
whole entire career and his whole entire
life was like [ __ ] on i wish that he had
seen that if only for a few minutes yeah
i wish that he had seen that but he
didn't khan comes in with another
[ __ ]
quote from me jesus he said
okay
this is a good one this is and a true
man wants two things danger and play for
that reason he wants women the most
dangerous play thing so there's the
answer there's the answer
that you wanted from me jen you're right
kahn that's right
because there is a certain amount of
risk risk and danger am i dangerous
yeah a little bit yeah in what way i
would i'm not going to [ __ ] get into
this [ __ ] and fight
i'm well i'm curious we got we got to
because the [ __ ] could go wrong
everything is an investment that could
go wrong
it's just the way it is
and that's with all human beings it's
not just between me and interesting yeah
it could go wrong it could fail
it could blow up in your [ __ ] face
but well i'm well aware of that outcome
i've had that happen many times you've
had or we both had it [ __ ] so that's
what they're talking about so i'm like
i'm really not that old
she heard about it jenny
what
i got foods downstairs away let's go
ahead and make something to eat
go ahead and shut the go ahead and shut
the show down all right say goodbye to
everybody and i'll start cooking because
okay don't be weird though you gotta
like do the goodbye with it we're gonna
we're gonna do buy and everything i'm
not going anywhere yeah so anywhere like
i said we're gonna end the show yeah
this [ __ ] they tore his [ __ ]
gravestone down yeah i'm just mad that
he didn't live
to see everybody she's getting his name
he got away with it
like i said that's what makes me mad
yeah well it makes me mad that he got
away with [ __ ] for like 50 years but it
also makes me mad that like he didn't
live to see everyone [ __ ] on his
name like they are now
i would have liked for him to seen that
at least for a few minutes before he
died that would have been awesome but he
didn't see that he died thinking
everybody thought he was awesome and
that blows that makes me very upset but
you know
i can't do anything about it i don't
have anything to do with it but
uh you know
so yeah all right so
what is it it's wednesday yeah
next show we're going to do
is the friday night show right our drunk
ass
sidetrack show that's good fun we'll
have fun
and this was a fun show yeah even though
it made me angry every single thing that
i talked about made me angry don't worry
about it it made me angry but you know
what i mean yeah i think that made it a
funner show though yeah
rebecca says thank you for a great show
watch something that makes you happy
jenny yeah i know i'm in i'm in a i'm in
a way i have i'm in a mood so i have to
like i have to watch something fun
although maybe
i'll probably go watch unsolved
mysteries to be honest with you i've
been watching unsolved mysteries the old
ones like on to be
they're depressing but they're also kind
of like comforting in a way but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by thank
you for super chats we will see you guys
on friday evening for our side track
show hopefully you guys will drop by for
that so we will see you again in a
couple of days
and we will see you then
bye